thank you
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
what happens when an Unstoppable Force
meets another Unstoppable Force we are
ready for a big Winner's final and I'm
here with Danny Ranch Danny what do you
predict when not back up to satrov takes
on Magnus Carson I predict we're going
to see what happens when a current world
number one takes on maybe a future world
number one now Notre back abdusa turnoff
won the last time we were all here but
that was the chest kid cup and somebody
was missing from that field his name was
Magnus Carlson and I predict Magnus is
going to show up and bring it today and
see himself in the grand finals it's
going to be a nerve-wracking fight
welcome to the Champions chess store
oh
God didn't you live for anybody anyone
who needs a cheerleader I'm there I'm
there
[Music]
Magnus takes it because it gets him the
match with three from eight players we
are down to six and two more will be
eliminated today it's high stakes
matches in the losers bracket and a bit
Winner's final to call all the action in
the studio from Master David Howell
an international Master Danny wrench
David it was a fantastic day of chess
what was the highlight for you you know
what a day of Chess it was Tanya the
Highlight for me was Abdul satorov's
performance just blistering chess
fantastic open preparation and just
world-class potential he demolished 11
Iranian
and chat David might have left a little
bit of an Easter egg for you brownie
points if you find that one out but
whatever performance it has been for
another back up to satro he's a
knockdown love on our onion he's knocked
down Wesley so into the elimination
bracket he faces Magnus today Simon what
are you expecting from him I I think
it's going to be a brilliant match I
mean you've got the younger generation
versus uh dare I call him the old man
but he said the old champion and uh both
players really want to show a bit of
dominance in this match I mean Magnus
wants to show who's boss and naughty
Beck wants to say I'm coming for you I'm
coming for the title so it's going to be
just a brilliant match yeah who will
assert his domination in that big
Winners final Danny what does it take to
get by Magnus it's a question that a lot
of people have been trying to figure out
for a long time I'm not sure I have the
answer I predicted Magnus is going to
win this match I think I poked the bear
a little bit yesterday when I
accidentally wasn't specific enough that
Magnus is the current and reigning world
rapid Champion he made sure he'd let me
know that he is and I think he has the
ability to bring it when he really wants
and uh I think it's going to be tough
for another book today and he really
wants it he wants it he's back in the
Champions test or after missing the
Chaska cup he's definitely looking to
win his second title of the season and
this is the menu for the day we did see
a Vladimir photos and Jordan van Forest
being eliminated on a day two meanwhile
not a back Abdul satro knocked down love
on our onion it was Magnus Carlsen who
took down Fabiano caruana we start with
the losers quarter final
Fabi taking on Wesley so love on our
onion against itri Saga and later today
we will have Magnus Carlsen versus not a
back up to such a the big final that
we're all waiting for and of course it's
a quite a clash earlier this year they
played their first classical match
against each other and it was not a
backup to satro who took that win David
is it a grudge match for Magnus yeah
Magnus has a score to settle not just
did he lose in the Tata steel Masters to
Abdul sotorov but also in 2021 when
Abdul satoroph became World rapid
Champion Magnus lost there too both
times were Queen end games and not many
people get the better of Magnus in that
phase of the game it's uh yeah it's
going to be exciting today it's going to
be super exciting but not only in the
loser loses bracket when
was one of them will be eliminated Danny
what will be the deciding factor in that
one
uh it depends on whether we're gonna
have
uh Fabiano caruana of this year in the
Champions Chester or Wesley so of last
year if you look at their all-time
record Wesley actually has the the
better of the two especially in Rapid
but I think that Fabiano has been
playing better this year so we'll see
who's in better form today
and that's also going to be the question
when love on aronian takes on Eduardo
etizaga we saw how much this means for
itarizaga he's the underdog Simon what
does he need to do to create his chances
against love I think he just needs to
create a mess I mean we saw Lev lose
horribly yesterday when um nordi Beck
did the same just create a mess get him
out of his comfort zone and get some
Chaos on the board
Chaos on the board that's the name of
the game and the big fight is for the
season and playoff to make it to the CCT
Grand Final and chat we've got a
surprise for you
Athens Masters chess of all Masters
chess kid cup and now aim chess rapid
they all lead to one thing the Champions
chess tour finale the finale will be
played between December 9th and 16th in
Toronto Canada
top eight players from the season will
compete to be crowned the 2023 Champion
three spots are already taken and the
remaining five will be decided in the
upcoming tour events so follow us to see
who will join Magnus Carlsen in Canada
in December
we are so excited about the year and
finals in Toronto Danny tell us
everything Toronto held the chess.com
Global championship last year it was an
amazing City we had a great time and uh
we're going back we're pretty pumped
this time there will be even more
opportunities for fans to get involved
we will have tickets available so don't
stress for those of you who crash the
party at the hotel we almost couldn't
keep them out literally but it was
crowded we're gonna have a different
kind of outlay and a different venue
there so be ready to join us in Toronto
it's going to be a lot of fun and the
winner of the aim chess rapid punches a
ticket to Toronto and also wins this
super cool NFD Trophy and you can bid
for one just like the winner Trophy and
get VIP tickets to the season finals in
Toronto make your NFD bids at chess
Champs dot IO and you could be in
Toronto with all the big names and for a
spot into the grand finals into the
finals of the aim chess rapid we've got
a clash of generations in division one
today but it's not just in division one
because take a look at what happened in
the other two divisions
Division II saw some action in the
second day of the aim chess rapid in a
hard-fought battle Iranian Grandmaster
Amin tabatabai overcame Peruvian
Grandmaster Jose Eduardo Martinez
Alcantara that's it I mean tabarabai
wins American Prodigy Sam sebian stepped
up against The Talented Armenian
Grandmaster Aram hakobian making a case
for himself and advancing to the
semi-finals gattacamski proved that
years of experience does matter with his
victory over the impressive Jeffrey
Zhang punching his ticket to the
semi-finals as well in Division III GM
Chuan minlay once considered the
strongest I am and the Chinese super
Grand Master Yang Yu are set to face off
in the finals after facing a gauntlet of
skilled Grandmasters who will continue
to shine who will rise from the losers
bracket only time will tell
it's time to shine in division two and
three with the finish line inside and
keeping us up to date with all the
action Katie in the studio Gary the
younger generation is really shaking up
the World Elite that's right Sonia they
really want to get in the first Division
and get the first price 10 000 USA
dollars and here you can see the lineup
for today and matches amitavatabai will
face Dennis lazavik these two so far are
having great tournament danislavic in
fact destroys everyone on his way and he
has won matches 3-0 or 3-2-1 now we can
see him on this screen I'll just jump a
bit here so he's 17 years old he became
International Master 2021 and very soon
he became Grandmaster in 2022. you can
see how fast he is progressing his uh
chesscom rapid rating is 2800 which is
really impressive
super impressive stuff then last had a
breakout moment in the protest League
season earlier this year he's just 17
years old can he book a ticket into
division one of the next Champions chat
Star Event and Katie we've also got
super GMS fighting it out in division
three that's right Sonia in division
three we have Yugi Chinese super
Grandmaster we all know about him and
there is manly maybe not many people
knows about this name but if we say
wonderful time you guys know him for
sure this is a streamer as you guys
heard he was the most famous
International Master streamer he became
Grandmaster last year he found his fans
really wanted him to play more over the
birthday numbers to win and that was the
moment when he became Grandmaster I love
that
that's right he has a lot to celebrate
Tanya he's winning a lot of title these
days and also he's recognized as one of
the best speed chess player in the world
will he be able to continue the
Celebration by taking on you yangi that
is a big ask it is big fights in these
other two divisions and you can catch
all the games and all the action on
chess dojos twitch Channel as well as
chess.com events so definitely check
that out and as we get ready to kick off
day three of the aim chess rapid let's
relive the dramatic armor Gardens and
the flashy wins from yesterday
for less important capture and it was on
move 72 so we're already just a few
moves away from that 50 move for all
feather save needs to move upon or
capture a piece in the next five moves
otherwise this game's automatically a
draw
ER
[Laughter]
there he celebrates as the game ends in
a drop
oh
commentator
commentator's curse this feels wrong on
multiple levels though this is really
all in now right you know you're giving
Pieces away you're not liking your pawns
or your pieces anymore I'm very risky
under 20 seconds
[Music]
and now this black king is not going to
survive the white Bishop's White Queen
are going to come in you can just trade
queens and mate on E5 oh that's
beautiful that is beautiful
in Levon is freaking out he's got five
seconds it's over unbelievable not a
backup to Satur Optics the second win
the inner or in the Winner's bracket I
think this one is pretty much over
probably not offering a draw because
because Magnus won't take it yeah it's
three points down it's just uh hopeless
at this point unfortunately Magnus
locking up the cage for that black king
not allowing a Trader post not allowing
the black king to centralize itself
repetition there a Magnus takes it
because it gets him the match Wick tree
what a match performance this has been
by the world number one taking down one
number three Fabiano caruana
it was thrilling matches across uh both
the losers bracket and the winners
bracket and we start with the losers
quarterfinal today Fabiano caruana
taking on Wesley so another big Clash of
the Titans and then we've got two
extremely creative players fighting
against each other as Lev uh plays
against Eduardo and these four players
face elimination two will be knocked out
later today at the big Winners final
that we're all waiting for not back up
to satro of just 18 years old takes on
Magnus Carlson I was clear from both
these Players yesterday that they were
looking forward to this match this is
the matchup that they wanted and that
just means Danny we get a big fight yeah
I think one of the things we haven't
talked about yet is U.S note Rebecca
great question who we'd rather face
Fabian or Magnus and he gave an even
better answer which is that he's already
played father he wants to play Magnus
that's a Champions mindset he wants the
number one if you're going to be number
one you gotta you gotta take down the
king I love it you gotta beat the best
to be the best Simon can not if I do it
today
I think you can yeah I mean it's going
to be really tough because Magnus is
when he's on form when he really wants
to take the game down he's really hard
to beat but naughty Beck is an amazing
talent and here we see some stats which
are also very impressive yeah Simon it
looks like both players are really well
matched here incredibly High numbers we
see that another Beck actually has the
edge over Magnus in terms of Advantage
capitalization that means Killer
Instinct finishing off promising
positions he's more resourceful than
Magnus actually saving more difficult
positions when it comes to the end game
not many players can compare Magnus is
the favorite there but not about shows
he has strengths of his own and yeah
certainly capable of winning today
just shows how close a match up this is
going to be but this is coming up later
before that we do have the losers
quarterfinals and exciting matches there
as well as Levon aronian takes on
iterizaga is there I want to ask is
there a favorite but there is a clear
favorite in this one you think lavonda
Roni and I think you're suggesting
although I'll say again that eturizaga
had to go through Armageddon to stay
alive and and we've seen that that can
really pay off because these players
sometimes need a wake-up call and it
makes you it makes you have all the
adrenaline pumping and so I think
iterizaga will have something to say
about whether he's that big of an
underdog and he's very motivated we had
a had an incredibly emotional interview
with him where he mentioned just how
much the aim chess rapid means for him
David are you expecting an extra
motivated to three Saga today certainly
one actually one fact that I forgot to
mention yesterday I've only ever lost
one Armageddon game and that was again
he's super quick he's super fast and as
we saw yesterday not many people can
match his uh passion his motivation
right now it's going to be uh I think a
very close match this one actually and
another super close match impossible to
pick a favorite in this one is as
Fabiano caruana takes on Wesley so take
a look at their head to head tanwin so
Fabi Wesley so leads their oval overall
rapid history with 13 wins but Simon we
know when these two play it's just hard
to predict a winner yeah they're so
closely matched normally uh I mean at
the moment Wesley is not playing great
chess so he's got to do something to
improve his form and Fabiano is playing
pretty well okay just lost the Magnus
yesterday anyone can do that so overall
Fabiano has been playing better this
year I think than most people in the
tour right so I totally agree with you I
think Wesley is the one temporarily not
in as good a form Fabiano seems to found
a home here in the Champions chess Tour
event so I totally agree it's Wesley who
really needs to prove that he's going to
show up today safabi is the player in a
better form David you agree with that
I'll say yes but I've seen Wesley when
he's at his best I've seen him just play
Godlike level chess so I I think it
might depend on the first game or two if
Wesley can survive those then uh yeah
he's got a chance and he had a great
armor Garden yesterday when he won and
Fabi meanwhile la lost to Magnus Carlsen
in just in four games he had his chances
there but failed to convert yeah but I
think that's a good point is that Fabi
did have his chances and I think we kept
talking about the fact that if you just
took back game one where Magnus won the
opening prep battle went into that sharp
Sicilian Fabiano was pressing in those
next games so he has to take that
positive mindset that overall I played
really well and again not to not to pick
on Wesley at all but I think that Wesley
hasn't been on form even if he overall
has the better record he's got to show
up today and really write the show and
in just a few moments we will have the
players on our screens the clocks are
ticking we will have the first move
let's take a look at the regulations for
our losers bracket it is the best of two
so the margin for error is zero you lose
the first game you already have to win
on demand the next one the minimum
margin to win is one and a half points
it's 15 minutes with a three second
edition
every move you make
you're eliminated if you lose the match
you continue in to the loser's bracket
if you win they are on their last strike
they are on their last life that is
heavy pressure and that we've got the
two big players of the game Fabiano
caruana taking on Wesley so Fabi starts
with the white pieces and we've got
moves the king spawn opening yep it's uh
E4 from Fabiano how will Wesley react
we're used to seeing him play Ultra
solid chess especially with the black
pieces and there we go it's E5 where we
see the Spanish the Italian case the
Italian game that's good no Berlin
defense today we've uh moaned about that
one before but uh yeah this is a
promising start all pieces will be on
the board for a while
and uh yeah I've got to admit the
Italian game it's uh one of the most
tense openings but it's one of the ones
that's hardest to evaluate Simon
yeah I mean I've never played the
Italian game it's just far too subtle
for me I I can't I don't understand it
at all uh it's little poor moves where
you put the bishop in certain positions
sometimes you put it there I mean it's
really really uh sort of intricate the
way you play it uh I prefer the more
blunt approach something a bit more
aggressive these subtleties they go they
go flying over my head
um but these two players that it's great
to watch them in these types of
positions because even I pick up a lot
of stuff about their maneuvering Danny I
mean they're they they are two of the
best players in the world in the Italian
right they really are and you know these
positions always they teach everyone I
think they teach each other a lot every
time they play because David you were
talking about it how you know you're
preparing Chess at a very high level and
uh these positions are super hard to
figure out you talked about the
intricate details the flexibility that
both sides have to play D4 to play B4 to
back up the bishop to challenge the
bishop there's so many opportunities to
uh to go wrong in your prep even just on
a human level right even no matter how
well they know the position one subtlety
of where you put a piece can change the
whole dynamic yeah and it always
explodes eventually so we'll build up to
that moment meanwhile still a very well
known position as the players Blitz out
their moves Fabiano caruana they're
declining some trades in the position
all pieces spawns on the board it's
going to be a strategic fight we will
also have the first moves in our other
matchup Lavon aronian taking on Eduardo
eturizaga and there we see the players
Lavon with his chessboards and chess
books at the back starts also with the
King spawn opening
and it's E4 Levon he switched towards
this in Rapid chess in recent years and
he's had a lot of success in a sicilian
and wow a transposition to the C3
Sicilian the elephant that's Queen
coming out this is one of my favorite
openings I'm getting nostalgic here guys
just get you get a little excited over
there I mean given how lame the elephant
is can I just be honest it's like it's
like calling out the London player in
the room given how lame the elephant is
you're getting a little excited but I
will say Obviously Lavon knows these
positions really well but look at the
turizaga playing quickly he knew the
elephant was coming Simon now this
Knight E3 move is the first moment he's
given pause but he's already moved again
I have to say whenever I was facing
David over the years and we've played in
so many competitions uh and uh don't ask
the score please but whenever I have
face stable whenever I got the black
pieces uh I just know that if I go for
the Sicilian he will do this to me and
it's put me off playing the Sicilian
against against him on any occasion
because it's a certain it's a certain
aspect to this opening where as black
you know kind of want a lot of action
but you don't really get it when white
plays this way yes it does have a very
drawing reputation but it's a very
risk-free approach from White right I
mean white can push try to get some kind
of nibble out of the position and black
doesn't really get what he wants that's
that's the problem uh for the player of
the black side in in generally in the
alapine alapin
yep so even though black is doing fine
out of the opening it is every Sicilian
player's nightmare because you just
don't get the kind of open positions
that you want yeah I think I think the
point is Sicilian players being one are
used to opposite sides castling right
night orbs and Dragons they're used to
Queen Side Pawn storms versus kingside
Pawn rushes whatever you want to call it
this is a very positional game sometimes
it reaches isolated Queen Pawn iqp this
is not one because the Knight recaptured
but either way it's a game where as
Simon said white has a nibble not a huge
Edge not a potential to maybe blow black
off the board but not a position that
Sicilian players dream about and David
everyone's talking about this nibble
advantage that White House you're an
elephant player what is this Advantage
yeah um right now I would say that white
has a very pleasant position for many
factors here you have a slight leading
development what's minor pieces looking
active if you look at the porn structure
white has this queen side majority uh
the three versus two on the left side
there long term maybe a little Factor
there it's easier to push those pawns
than it might be for black to push on
the other flank and it's just kind of
simple play obviously it's roughly level
it's roughly balanced and it will come
down to who understands the position
better but uh yeah it looks like it's
not as Dynamic not as wild a position as
any or a lot of Sicilian players would
want and I think it's just a
psychological
Factor here of course opening is going
trends go in fashion and right now it's
come back into fashion this type of
position with white just nibble away
with minimal risk as Simon mentions and
do you think levon's strategy to use the
alapan is also playing the opponent
iterizaga known for this aggressive
style attacking style of play in the
middle game he just wants to shut all of
that down is that a factor I completely
agree with that I think that's that's
probably the biggest reason he chose it
so I think that's a great call out I
think it's a practical decision he
doesn't want a tourism at home and the
wild stuff that he's well known for and
all of his success online we mentioned
on day one he had the third highest
winning percentage of any player in the
protest League this year behind Magnus
and Hikaru this guy wins in Rapid chess
a lot there's a reason he's still
standing here and and Lavon isn't
looking to mix it up in in craziness
against him
yeah he said in his interview yesterday
to razaga there were nerves he doesn't
often get the opportunity to play these
kind of elite players but uh he's on a
winning streak now he won two clutch
victories yesterday and he looks full of
confidence to me blitzing up to this
point already even though it's maybe a
bit of a sideline of this uh of this
opening and I'm expecting him again to
Blitz out his move levon's trying to put
pressure bringing his Queen out the
bishop the Knight they're all hitting
blacks Knight and C6
one thing he needs to work on maybe
tourism is his air quality looking very
uh he was very warm there in his room
not great to see you two levels but good
position
yeah and I totally agree what you're
saying and uh I think we we love an
underdog don't we I mean I don't know if
it's an English thing but we kind of
celebrate it a lot in England uh of you
know players who are sort of nearly
become Champions but they don't so like
losers basically like we love an
underdog and um an Underdog Story and I
I think it's worth you know just
mentioning that again as you say like
Eduardo he doesn't get the opportunities
to play in these big money events in
these events where he can dice with the
top players it's a real honor you know
it's like sometimes I expect the other
players they get a bit used to playing
the same guys all the time as part of
their part of their job so for Eduardo
this is a really special occasion and
it's great he's got this opportunity so
I for one would love to see him do well
um you know and put up a strong
performance at least against uh aronium
I agree and he's also got the right
mindset you say he's got the opportunity
now and he's got the right mindset a lot
of people drew attention they freeze
framed his tattoo I don't know if you
guys saw it on social media but a
paraphrasing because uh don't hold it
against me but basically it's like if
you try hard and fail you try again and
you fail better and he just anyway it's
it's a famous quote but his mindset is
uh is one that keeps him focused and
keeps him fighting and I love it yeah
very quickly Danny I mean I was speaking
to David about this the other day and uh
I saw that nepo has a tattoo
um and I don't know if anyone knows I
think it's quite new yeah he's got a
full he's got a sleeve so uh and we were
talking about getting tattoos as well uh
David you were you were too real as well
hand in hand we can skip in that tattoo
place I'll get a green Pawn on my arm a
green a green Pawn oh yeah of course
yeah I can see what you're doing there
yeah with Danny's face on it
I think that'd be a good chat for people
at home though the the perfect chess
tattoo what would it be but I'd also
like to know what nepo's tattoo actually
says you know so uh interesting but
meanwhile a couple of changes in this
position and a big position from Levon
aronian uh he has shattered Black's
Queen side pawns a couple of isolated
pawns over there but if we jump in he's
allowed a trade of his dark squared
bishop and this goes against what a lot
of top players prefer they normally love
their Bishops but he's allowing Knight
takes Bishop here shattering the white
porn structure if we compare the
structure now White's Pawn on E3
extremely weak long term yes these two
don't look great for black but I do
foresee a future where at this point
eventually becomes a big weakness and
big big moment I'm surprised by that I
mean it looks looks good for you
teresauga to take and it's certainly an
imbalance that normally you would go for
the two Bishops so
teach me something I don't understand
about this because I think the uh
the engine also thinks that black would
be fine I don't know
yeah I think some Black's doing great
Tanya
so perhaps
you just imbalance the position and try
and create some player on the king side
yes you weaken your Pawn structure you
give up the bishop bear but you have the
F line open and we remember what
nautiback said about his game against
Levon yesterday he walked into a knowing
lost line because he knew that
objectively it's hard to counter and
these are those kind of positions that
it doesn't matter what the valbar says
as long as the position's in Balance
you've got less time on the clock you
can create plates anyone's game I love
that point and honestly now that I look
at it and you're talking about the
imbalance I'm looking at White's pieces
are actually deceptively ready to
coordinate here David right the queen on
A4 she started on the queen side but
that fourth rank is wide open for
business either E4 or G4 you already
have an openf file right the Knight is
ready to pop in and now there is no
Greek gift right now there's no Bishop
takes H7 Knight G5 but that that should
be something that's uh on the radar and
so I I agree I guess from a practical
perspective Lev is still sort of playing
playing to get get himself some chances
and uh and I like it it's gonna be a fun
one yeah it's going to be a fun one just
to point out some of the ideas you
mentioned Danny just The Rook might come
eventually the Knight might move you can
swing your queen to the center
threatening some checkmates bring the
knight in I think this is the space
maybe even show what happened if white
would have put the Rook on E1 because
this actually works if you put the Rook
on E1 in Black plays Bishop C5 now you
can actually play Bishop takes H7 you
see that eval Bar following by the way
I'm just I'm just spawning out these
tactics so I'm proud of myself I was
right and and the reason it only works
with the Rook on E1 is on Queen H4 King
G8 Knight G5 is otherwise Bishop takes
E3 chuck would take the Knight so Brooke
had to go to E1 in order to make that a
threat and uh anyway so this is an
example of the type of things that um
you got to be careful about yeah uh big
danger if black isn't Vigilant and here
okay he just slices King to H1 so maybe
similar ideas in mind Danny again Bishop
C5 would be a losing blunder um because
it gives control to White of the G5
Square Stakes are higher in this one
when you take such big decisions of
giving up the bishop bear and these
strategically weak Bond structure we see
Pawn Islands here White's got three Pawn
islands that e-pawn is a glaring
weakness for the rest of the game is it
making intentions clear that you now
need to go for the attack you have to
find the initiative and timing is really
important you can't play a slow game
anymore Simon yeah I I think this is
just clearly a battle between uh White's
short term or shortest shortish term
ideas of going for the black king
because he's got these open lines he's
got the bishop and the Knight but black
has the the long-term potential here
because uh black has a decent Pawn
structure I mean it's not necessarily a
lot better because he's got his own
weaknesses but he's got two Bishops he's
got some nice open lines so I think if
uh
um you know if Eduardo can survive the
next 10 moves without you know making a
position any worse so being a very very
good situation going forwards and it's a
risky strategic strategy that Lev Levon
is doing here because it might not pay
off so we'll have to wait and see yeah
big risks taken by love straight from
the opening he's going for the win in
this one we'll see if the plan works out
or not but let's hope let's head over to
our other big matchup with Fabiano
caruana with the white pieces against
Wesley so and Wesley's night start
jumping David yeah the Black Knight has
jumped into f4 on the last move to me it
looks like a huge success for this
opening for Wesley so blacks Bishop on
A7 the dark Squad Bishop it's uh
poaching from afar just sniping down at
the white King on the same diagonal it
looks like symmetrical Pawn structure as
well and just no issues here at all for
black
body language experts here maybe needed
Body Language by the way for anyone who
hasn't seen Wesley so from the fair play
cam view we've leaked it a few times he
has a big monitor but he likes making
the chessboard super small
and I think he thinks it makes him
better in time scrambles and then he
tends to really get dialed in on a small
a small board which again I don't know
that I don't know that the math checks
out I think you might as well have a
bigger board during most of the game and
then make it smaller if you need it but
I think he doesn't want to mess with it
as the game goes on so anyway just
wanted to call that out that's why he
does that so it's a tiny board and that
pose that we just saw from Wesley he's
just trying to focus into it it's crazy
we've seen on his screen that it's a big
screen but he makes them on he makes the
the board really small here anyway I
wanna if it's okay to call for the
analysis board I'm fascinated by how
this position got here because this is
not your normal maneuvering Italian
David if you don't mind giving us an
instant replay this has opened up much
more quickly than it normally does am I
right about that yeah completely right
Danny and it all stems back to here uh
black blew open the center with a quick
D5 normally it's white who's uh kind of
breaking first in the middle of the
board with white you start with an extra
move and if it's almost symmetrical
you're the one to conquer the center and
this is how things exploded white
captured here in the middle and the key
tactic is that this Pawn is now poisoned
black can get away with this trick
because if you capture it looks like
you're winning a pawn here but a nasty
double attack after Bishop takes Pawn
check forcing the king out and uh this
check would then win material for black
the white Rook would drop off so
utilizing this small trick this tactic
black was able to blow up in the center
and white decided okay I have to do the
same and total symmetry here after a
trade of Pawns and this is how we
basically see the Contours of the
position it's like Fabiano maybe just
with the wrong move order allowing this
break and if we fast forward this is the
current position after Bishop to E4
I think the big decision rests upon
whether black Parts with his beautiful
Bishop here and trades off for this
Knight this gives white an iqp an
isolated Queen's pawn and uh long term
this Pawn in the middle might be weak
but padding with the bishop pair just
like we said with the other game big
decision long term
yeah I think he's gonna go for it
um I don't think he will I mean I I
think Wesley will look at ways to try
and keep the tension uh keep that Bishop
I mean it looks like such a strong piece
and it has great potential but he he
obviously needs to try and find
something to to keep any uh uh a chance
of an advantage here that he can the
only thing that you that you could say
that Black's really got going for him
are his slightly better pieces and his
slightly better Knight and if White's
given time then then white should better
deal with that so um he's gotta he's got
to find something reasonably quick I
think here if I would just whispered
something to himself under his breath
after Bishop b5a if I had instant replay
I might be able to read lips I do I do
read lips for another job
um so but I I miss what job what job is
that yeah you can't talk about it
um okay very interesting um
more questions and answers
that's by Design
um all right but Bishop D5 has played
and the offer of an exchange although it
does does keep the the dark squared
Bishop on the board
is kind of inviting a little bit of a
release of the tension so I don't know
that's funny even though the position is
cleared up and I agree a move order
mistake if we want to call it that by
Fabi kind of allowed it as I look at the
clock he's still up a couple minutes
there's not really a lot of teeth I feel
like to either player's position so um I
I hate to use the the ugly word of Peace
in chess but I mean I'm not I'm not
seeing a ton of fireworks Happening Here
yeah depends on the type of piece but uh
yeah no peace treaty yet
I didn't want to say draw sorry I don't
know what you're talking about Danny all
pieces on the board not a single trade
so far and you're predicting a draw in
this one I think it's a far way off and
look at that the last move by Fabi
keeping the tension on the wall when I'm
wrong the shows are usually better when
I'm wrong so that is great but the
question is are the moves better when
you're wrong hey the suggested movies
are normally better I I've actually been
doing okay okay I've been holding my own
I know sitting next to these two grand
Masters and very strong International
Master to my left so you know doing my
best you've been doing great Donnie but
the question is this last move by Fabi
we saw the eval bar creep down a little
bit saying that this was perhaps an
inaccuracy David yeah it looks like he
was talking to himself again there Fabby
for a moment it looks like he was like
oh I think I think he's literally like
dude wake up he's like talking to
himself like sorry go ahead no I think
you're right and already there's some
tactics in the position the evaluation
Bar says uh that there is an advantage
here for blackened I did just peep here
I thought it was level it looks roughly
balanced to me but apparently there
might be a tactic in the air White Queen
has planted herself on a really
vulnerable square and for example if
black takes this Knight now if white
naively recaptures then I think black
can get a winning Advantage by taking
this piece with his rook and the problem
is here there's simply a pin your queen
is vulnerable and black is going to come
out with two extra pieces just for
White's rook and material advantage I
was looking at that F5 idea but hadn't
considered The Rook taking first and
there you go that would be that could be
a huge moment because if what does that
mean that means if Wesley takes D4
Fabiano has to go down a pawn right
because you'd have to take D5 first and
allow the inner meso Bishop takes F2
check yeah and this would be the outcome
you simply lost the F2 Pawn for free
that's why fabby's cursing himself and
Wesley maybe his Spidey senses are
tingling here he suddenly stopped for a
couple of minutes is he calculating this
that's the big question big moment here
for Wesley to sees the initiative or
extra material by trading on D4 will
Wesley spot this he's down to about five
minutes on the clock not great clock
management by Wesley so far Simon no no
not at all but he's got a well I don't
know maybe maybe it is because he's got
a great position if he plays uh if he
plays Bishops if he finds this move and
uh you know winning with black would be
amazing I don't just you know I'm sure
we'll move on to the other game very
shortly as well and we'll wait and see
if this move is played but I'm just
looking at their backgrounds and uh I
know that Wesley's still in the room and
Fabiano is that is that a lamp behind it
looks like a big mushroom to me and he
doesn't find it he goes for retreat in
the center so the balance has been
restored big missed there by Wesley but
there is Big action on the other board
as well let's quickly head over to
Eduardo is he winning where is White's
Queen I was just gonna say is he upper
Queen indeed he is and I I was quickly
spying it right before we switched so uh
apologies for getting ahead of it but
yeah if we want to back up just a few
moves things have gone wrong here for
Lavon aronian and he actually just
willingly parted ways with his Queen on
the last turn because the position was
that bad you know let's show what
happened the queen was attacked and look
at how she couldn't find a safe home she
tried to use the G4 Square she was
harassed she was hit by the pawn she
tried to use this Square she was hit by
a bishop and suddenly The Rook is coming
to attack her as well and like you said
Danny she tried to find safety on C4 but
suddenly a skewer and the queen is gone
you simply have to part with your queen
or you lose your bishop and to catch up
with the live game we saw this move and
Bishop takes H2 bang capturing a pawn
similar to that Greek gift in front of
the white king if this uh Bishop is
taken then simply this would be winning
this is a pin and if you try to block
this a nasty double attack beautiful
geometry here from iterizaga and this is
looking this is quite shocking I mean
with the black pieces against aronian
this could be a major major first round
win you can see the head I don't have to
be a body expert to see that he's pretty
happy at the way things are going and
yeah I'm becoming a bit of a fan of
Eduardo you know he was so nice in the
interview you can tell he's a nice guy
and uh you know I'm I'm cheering for him
Eduardo vamos Eduardo I mean I'm a fan
I've been a fan of this guy for for
years no serious seriously he's an
aggressive player he hasn't just
enterprising entertaining style he has
won games in miniature fashion for years
in in the in the protest league and some
of the other events online want himself
a few title Tuesdays this is a guy who
deserves a chance to make a name for
himself and I'm not surprised that he's
delivering and his fist bumps after
those victories are legendary but Levon
aronia and he had that one move Rook
drop against naughty back up to Sutra
now getting his own Queen trapped It
Feels Like Love is struggling to find
his form here yeah something seems to be
wrong and wow it looks like he was about
to resign that body language looked like
he'd just given up but uh yeah
something's gone wrong I think it was
just that strategic decision he kind of
banked it all on a short-term initiative
and suddenly he got carried away
everywhere he went he got chased he
wasn't ready for this switch of momentum
do you think I mean I'm shaking his head
yeah I mean the position is pretty
hopeless here as long as black keeps
this cool but do you think there's a
danger that when you you know for
someone like uh Levon
um when he's playing like Eduardo and
this is no disrespect to Eduardo or to
live on but Eduardo is the low rated
player right and do you think that in
your mind you're thinking I can take
more Liberties against the lower rate
player I can take more risks because I
just don't see Lev playing this capture
on E3 against Magnus Carlson I just
don't think he would do that against
Magnus I mean it's just so
anti-positional and you're taking a lot
of risks with with the white pieces so I
don't know it just seems a very strange
decision that way
um yeah but is it is it the opponent or
is it the form because against another
backup to start off as well we saw him
take some very questionable decisions on
the board yeah and I don't think he was
under wrestling estimating Notre back I
it's interesting because Lavon started
out so well I mean we were calling him
as maybe the top performer after day one
I mean he really really played some
great chess
um but maybe sometimes that can backfire
because you weren't even challenged like
he won his first match in two and a half
games all right sorry two and a half
games yeah three games right two and a
half out of three and so I don't know
sometimes you see that backfire uh some
players actually start off slowly and
then um it's a wake-up call and they
find their form as they get poked
throughout so yeah Lev has not been the
same player after the first day and I
think what might have gone wrong today
as well is he didn't use his time that
well he's still got eight and a half
minutes left but you don't carry that
over to the next game he lost his Queen
by playing very very quickly and I think
I think he could have calculated this he
could have seen the tactics coming but
he was just blitzing and only stopped
when it was too late
dead lost position now blacks queen
versus the white Rooker Knight far
superior piece there but also look at
that massive pawns black has on the king
side yeah
big Underdog Story in the aim chess
rapid continues Eduardo etherizaga on
the brink of taking a match lead here he
could very well be winning this one
which would mean that Lebanon has to win
at least one game in this four game mini
rapid and right now struggling in form
he is in a think tank are we expecting
him to fight this out or throw in the
towel soon
let's remember it's actually only two
games right because we're in the losers
back and I only I only say that because
your point is a good one that like I
think he has no choice but to fight it
out because it's only two games right he
has to keep fighting and hope for a
trick Hope For A Swindle but I think I
speak for the crew here in that pretty
hopeless this is not a this is a
position that is very hard to lose as
they say I could win this position
if that's how winning it is
Simon because I could almost die I'd
have some good chances to win this
position uh it's just too much I mean
you you've got those pawns coming down
you've got you've got everything uh you
just gotta stop that night activating uh
this is maybe a Lev's only chance
because Rooks are pretty good I mean you
can bring one of the Rooks in with a
check it doesn't achieve a great deal
yet but if you can coordinate three
pieces and it have to be every single
one of White's pieces then that could
cause some trouble I don't think two
pieces is anything to worry about but
three pieces you notice there's some
chances but in you know I don't see it
happening here as long as Eduardo can
keep his call but it's a very good point
it's only two games and losing with the
white pieces is massive you have to win
with the black pieces in the next game
uh okay please ask big ask just one
trick to avoid I want to point out if
white for example pushes the pawn to E5
watch out for your king uh if you're
iterizaga because there suddenly would
be a huge threat of almost a Czech
mating attack you would have to part
with your queen here so still a little
glimmer of hope but I saw the same
tactic but if we back up a move I wanted
to point out the other natural thing to
do was to play G3 because your Pawn was
under attack right well then Knight G4
comes in and now you save your rook and
go to G6 you know I wanted to point out
the same thing but just a different way
for the F6 Square to be guarded because
now the Knight guards the Escape Square
um and uh maybe there was a more more
reasonable trick that could have
happened but again uturizaga not
interested in either track it's pretty
pretty dodgy when we really have to
scrape the power for these tricks there
was a chance of losing your focus you
might play G3 I mean Simon Williams
might have played Keith very easily on
on a Friday night to have a good night
at 3am in the morning I might be afraid
tempted to play uh G3 but I'd hope I
wouldn't do it anywhere else uh and the
good night is obviously our friendly
chess Pub in Oslo
great place
um but yeah I can't I just can't see how
ronian can do this I mean blackshear's
got to get his Queen I would feel to a
good uh good route here and that that
will be that'll be it but you mentioned
this idea of getting black skin into the
Killzone by pushing that e-pawn and
taking away the Escape Route how would
black fight that if that check meeting
pattern was to happen yeah let's show
this on the board I think it's worth one
last try set one last trap here for
Levon he doesn't look too optimistic on
the camera but for example if you were
to close that cage on the black king
Tanya then I see two ways of dealing
with this firstly you could actually
step towards the Rooks I'm a bit
reluctant to do this but at least now
you cover the square with your queen and
king uh the more attractive move to me
would be for example to move the Rook
just to create an escape square and you
can see the king walking into relatives
into relative safety here uh supported
by its Pawn so for example a check you
simply walk forward and you're safe as
houses if anything it's the white king
that's going to come under a mating
attack soon so yeah I'm pretty sure
Eduardo has foreseen this but worth a
try maybe from Iranian looks like
everything else is just as hopeless
sometimes
yeah desperate meshes Times Desperate
Measures and uh thinking but it might
just be too late to use up that clock
should I have better time management in
that situation when the queen got into
trouble but we've seen love with this uh
match strategy throughout the Champions
chess store where he plays fast puts
pressure on the clock and the
disadvantage of that is that sometimes
you tend to miss these critical moments
yeah just looks like the case today he
just blinked for one moment and suddenly
his Queen was gone and that can happen
it's so hard against the top players uh
and I'm including in tourism that uh
just kind of blitzing in chess because
yeah things slip it's funny I agree with
you Simon that regardless of whether it
was for form or perhaps for some
underestimation I do agree with you that
in hindsight this decision to allow
Knight takes E3 I want to say was a bit
of parlor tricks right he was going for
a flashy kingside attack and I had fun
with that it would have been great to
see the bishop sacrifice right but in
hindsight objectively there was really
nothing there and questionable it's very
risky very risky decision I mean you've
got the white pieces you really uh got
to try and avoid him with white in these
tournaments and uh
um you can take risks but if you've got
an alternative which is just as good
risk-free then why not do the
alternative and he did so it's a strange
decision by Levon to to destroy his Pawn
structure so earlier on in in this game
and the more he's thinking the more it
feels as if he wants to press that
resign button uh down to about four
minutes on the clock now and little to
fight for he looks extremely dejected I
agree I can relate to that moment where
you're just uh what you resist persists
and you're trying not to think about
resigning and unless you can see the
button on screen because you're like I'm
just so frustrated with my position I
can't even stop thinking about the fact
that I want to get rid of it
um but uh
either that or it's a last minute trick
well I think it's time I think he just
you know the best move for left is to
just resign just just resign get it done
and um yeah I don't you know like the
next one get the pain over with as I
mean there's a lot of people will play
On and On which is absolutely fine uh
just because it's a mental thing right
you wanna you wanna prepare yourself for
resigning and you've got to get ready
for that next match and you know you're
just kind of playing out Spike getting
the the bad energy out of your system uh
even sometimes uh four and a half minute
think though I mean it feels like you
might as well resign at this point
you're clearly not thinking about
anything if you'll live on Iranian it
feels like stages of grief right now I'm
not actually calculating what's going on
on the board I I agree I think that's a
great call out right what are the stages
right you start out with denial right
then then anger then acceptance I want
to see the anger and sadness all right
well I I agree I think uh Lavon was
doing anything but but really coming up
with a plan that could mix it up and I
sometimes wonder what the right
psychological thing to do is when you're
getting beat if you should throw in the
towel and allow yourself to shake off
the emotions away from the board or if
it's good to keep playing moves because
I feel like sometimes that can backfire
where you sort of reinforce the fact
that you just had a really negative
experience and you let it go on many
more minutes longer than it should have
I I don't know what the right psychology
is there yeah maybe that's part of like
the healing process for the next game I
made the mistake of calling this the
best of four match it's only two games
Lev has to strike back in the next round
so maybe mentally he's kind of already
thinking about that and letting this
play out and sort of calming himself on
the inside David what's you're the super
Grand Master here what's the big
strategy in these moments
I wish I knew Tanya I think I would also
be playing on um I'm not sure whether
that oh wow look at Lev on there just
reacting looking away again but uh yeah
I'm not sure whether that's part of any
big strategy it's just kind of
yeah it's just forcing your opponent to
think maybe it'll come down to a Time
scramble you can try and mess with their
nerves slightly but this one is totally
hopeless look how beautiful Black's King
is in the center King of the Hill here
it's safe as uh yeah it's the safest
King you'll ever see and Black's Queen
is slowly inching her way in for the
kill King of the Hill most underrated
variant yeah
my favorite it's a great variant right
now Eduardo Saga is the one who's
enjoying his King on the hill Simon that
King on E5 it's not every day that you
get to see a king in the center of the
board with Queens on with heavy pieces
on so it's so cool that that's the
safest Square actually well I mean you
should you should see some of my games
this happens a bit far too often
actually
um but you're right Tanya the the king
in the middle is actually it's very safe
there
um there's no good way that white can
check it that King if white tries to
check it in any way white will lose a
piece and Black's pawns are doing a
fantastic job of of shading it you know
like uh some tropical trees there aren't
they they're just stopping the night
from coming in that night moves but
where can it go there's another tropical
tree stopping it uh coming any nearer to
the king and um as long as black just
doesn't uh blunder here Black's got this
in the bag I mean I I mean the thing
about resigning I mean I would resign
here but that's just me but these guys
should probably play on I mean there's
no point resigning us there and then
there's all those tricks I will call out
one interesting kind of cycle ecological
play here is I'm just observing what's
going on observing the clocks observing
Lev's body language and behavior and
there is one chance you have in these
positions which is to sort of convince
your opponent by your behavior by your
body language that you've already
checked out you've already resigned but
as I would always tell my students as
long as your opponent is still playing
moves they still believe there's a
chance whether it's a win or a draw and
so you have to keep your focus and I
just want to point out that now both
players are under two minutes there is
an awkward King in the center there's
still a knight on the board and levona
ronian is is nothing if he's not
resourceful and and full of Tricks so
until this game is over I'm just I'm
just pointing out I think we got the
result that's it okay after that thank
you for that
it's finally over
with the biggest upset of the aim chess
rapid so far takes the lead in The Best
of too much Levon has to win the final
rapid Game On Demand to take it to
Armageddon and he's just sitting there
look looking at what happened what went
wrong and it seems everything did yeah
we've got Eduardo
[Music]
what an awesome game that was by Eduardo
uh against Lavon aronia and now it's
back to this one and favis managed to
create an advantage with an extra pawn
two extra points Tanya he has an
advantage on both flanks uh look at the
queen side probably not the most
impressive extra Pawn those doubled why
a pawns but it's on the other side of
the board fabby's worked his magic here
and uh it's a two result game it's
either going to be a win for white or a
draw but can he milk this Black's Queen
and Knight look fantastic but okay the
bar reacts again White's just gonna
slowly inch forward and at the right
moment maybe start playing on both
flanks and look at the clock as well the
clock is really in fabby's favor he's
got an extra minute but more importantly
Wesley's under 10 seconds pretty much
and uh this is this is looking very good
for white the only I suppose it's the
only good thing about Black's position
is Queen and Knight Queen and Knight
coordinate really well together that
Knight is in the center of the board so
it's well well positioned and White's
Bishop is not a great piece so uh it's
it's still still seems a little bit of
hard work to to convert this one to a
win interesting I think Fabi might have
missed Queen G6 check there in H6 he
backed up I think instinctively but
Queen G6 check and H6 might have been
lights out I think he got worried as to
the point Simon said that the queen at
night can be dangerous and so Fabi was
not interested in any kind of risk five
seconds on the clock for Wesley right
now Fabi with 40 seconds
this is uh getting into danger time zone
the bishop Retreats the night Retreats
David two extra pawns should be fabi's
game it should be but I agree with Danny
I think just these one or two small
missed opportunities not finishing it
off when you have the opportunity
yeah yeah look at Black's night now
dancing now the night's dominating H5 is
suddenly overextended instead of an
asset I think Queen G6 was actually was
actually critical because the other
thing that happened you highlighted
those pawns being useless David but
actually the B7 Pawn was super weak when
the queen had access to C8 not anymore
so I'm actually like suddenly it's
turned and I think that Wesley's gonna
hold this Fabio declines the repetition
so he's still going for the win in this
position watch out for discover checks
the queen and the Knight lined up
against the white king yeah just light
Square domination here for black and
great compensation I agree as well the
White H Pawn looks like it's over
stepped it's Mark Harry getting too
excited there Simon and there goes the
pawn as well I mean uh that's that's
quite an important point because black
has a very useful passport okay white
trying to open up the black king now but
black gets the first check-in and he's
threatening mates there is a big Threat
all the time now who's there four
seconds three seconds he's got a mate to
defend well he's got to be careful the
queen is zigzagging her way closer and
closer to that white king and what queen
takes Bishop is is very does it work I
don't know I don't know Queen takes
Bishop Knight D3 check then he comes
forward picks up the F Bond okay so
Wesley's calculating it but 193 first
doesn't work because Queen takes F5
check yeah so maybe you can do that
anyway no he does it allows it
and now the maximum what you can get is
just a Perpetual check white has to keep
giving checks because the white Bishop
will drop if you stop and yeah you have
to just go for the draw now I think Fabi
oh wait he plays on no he wants more
he's going for the win the Fighting
Chess is on both sides playing for the
win now but Black's got pawns too look
how they're running now who's winning
the king upon ending because we're going
to find out right now where the Wesley
goes for it keep pushing
[Music]
he should have maybe he should have now
the bishop can wriggle out he keeps
checking first B7 is also falling okay
will we see a draw by repetition
oh my gosh The Bishop's attacker Queen
trade office
lead declines
I
I think white can go for B7 but they're
afraid to do it the bar has no idea
who's playing
but now now's your chance if you want
the pawn nope he doesn't yet
choose which Pawn to take maybe Fabi
wants the G Pawn huh he's gonna give
some tracks he needs to get a bishop
into the game somehow White's Bishop is
just a bystander right now okay
repeating 15 seconds gets 20.
now we can pick up the G Pawn with some
chap win G5 with Jack you see it oh you
missed it Abby oh he had a winning check
there he could have dropped himself on
F5 and that would have been game over
okay what's these grabbing pawns oh my
God I love it Wesley's turning this
around
12 seconds right now Queen comes back to
defend the a pawn but what a moment that
was Fabi could have wrapped up the game
right there with the right check but he
missed it now wait Bishop can re-enter
the action there we go Abby is finally
going for that black G Pawn but some
checks
I'm really scared here
it's a little too late I mean it's just
it's just changing and remove this one I
mean uh I I expect it'll be a drug I
don't know just because it's so crazy
I'm expecting Wesley to get this I think
the whole thing is switched around Fabi
missed his chances the queen at night
are now super dangerous against the king
the C Pawn has passed
Barry for white king I think yeah will
this be the draw no I think Wesley's
gonna see it he's gonna push yeah Messi
will be the one to try for a win I think
so I think he's feeling it I think he is
Queen and Knight are so dangerous
together this one momentum as well all
on black side just trying to get his
King to a much safer space there to
avoid the checks and now uh that Knight
in Queen though they've got to find a
way in and it's not seriously okay he's
pushing joins the body and now it's
fabulous trying to repeat the moves
I think he's been super smart with the
King
get out of out of Harm's Way so he can
advance the pawn
I think Wesley's taking this one
a check repeating the position first
though uh oh yeah don't do it Wesley
what time they want time on the clock
that's why they're repeating moves
doesn't necessarily mean they want to
draw
yeah
he goes the other way Queen H7
he's walking into the center
and David it's good strategy for the
black king to stay on light squares and
not allow a check with the bishop yeah
you have to be really careful walk onto
the wrong square and you might get Forks
skewered that white Bishop is just
poised there but he's using the light
squares Tanya just can he get out though
the White Queen is keeping this cage
shut
maybe it's a draw maybe there's no way
out for the black king I think it's a
draw now I don't think there's any way
you can escape this right this is very
risky dude he wants it uh even with the
pawn on dark squares he's not afraid of
the queen trade
why does one move away from that eval
bar crashing down and they're being a
Checkmate attack so Wesley is banking on
a blunder by Favi here be careful don't
take that black pawn The Black Queen if
he gives one check that would have ended
in Checkmate so if happy has to be okay
he moved and now Queen trades and the
pawn is hanging but he gives a check
another one
repetition maybe it's finally time if
it's fine
no he wants more he's still going let's
go Fighting Chess
I love this move he's walking all the
way up the board if he can the Knight
blocks the best defender is a knight for
a king and no more tracks so irritating
for the White Queen to be blocked by the
night
the pawn pushes and the eval bar goes
crashing down black king where's it
going is it going back or is it right
now forward to D5 or C5 C5 that's it
because you can regard the pawn when the
king moves yeah he's running into open
air here just side Steps step into the
center of the board hey this looks good
too the king's gonna hide finally it's
running towards the corner Black's gonna
make a new Queen
this is game over just like that that's
it oh and that's a pain you can't pick
up the C Pawn because of the king and
Fabiano caruano resigns what a win by
Wesley so keeping the tension keeping
the pressure what a fight this was could
have gone either way and you can see
that Fabi is not happy
not happy uh but Wesley is look at the
uh the fist pump he's turning it around
as we said sometimes you start in bad
form and you find it as the event goes
on that might be exactly what's going to
happen to Wesley so if I'm everyone else
in this event
I'm I'm scared of what's happening with
Wesley cell right now
what a game that was uh Fabiano caruana
goes down which means that Fabi and love
have to win on demand the final rapid
game it was an exciting two games in the
losers quarterfinals a lot to choose
from David but what stood out to you
yeah I'm just going to go back to that
dramatic game between Carolina and
Wesley so where Fabi let it slip he just
gave the wrong checks and we saw the
potency of Queen and Knight as a combo
they are extremely dangerous and it was
here that Fabiano missed a winning move
he could have played instead of Queen E3
dropping back allowing black to actually
grab this Pawn he could have played the
movie Queen to F5 this is a check and
not just a check your next move take a
very valuable Pawn with track and when
the black king continues to run you can
start pushing a pawn of your own this is
one thing that Fabiano lacked a past
born in the end of the game did turn
around to the black queen and night did
Triumph
what a finish that was had us on the
edge of our seat which means that Fabi
has to win the next one on demand a nail
biting game one in the losers
quarterfinals for both these matchups
and there we see Lavon with a disastrous
loss with the white pieces what a moment
it was for Eduardo and both Eduardo
iterizaga and Wesley so celebrating with
first bumps there
the Eduardo win that is a big upset a
huge upset for eduardoichirizaga again
he would say not so much uh and I just
want to call out that it's interesting
that every time we have a must-win game
to force Armageddon that player is
playing Black we have Fabiano caruana
and levona Roni and they will get the
black pieces and a muslin situation
where we have more Armageddon I'm I'm
hoping for it honestly we would love to
see the adrenaline focused armageddon's
if it comes down to that but two players
have to win on demand for that it's
going to be a fun round too and we also
had a lot of fun in Oslo when Dany and
Simon took to the streets for Chop some
chess Hustle the full video is coming
out later but take a look at what's
coming up
Simon has a distinct Advantage because
his openings are so bad they tend to get
more blunders look at this slow position
just going on over it
[Music]
three three three okay I'm coming for
you
oh that's the subtlety you didn't see at
the end of the line I'm in the lead
Simon sack your queen
come on I'm freaking out here where is
the wind bro
there you go there's another one
Precious on I'm playing against two
enemies here Simon Williams and the
clock
that looked like a really close fight
did you guys have fun how was that uh we
had a blast it was pretty close I mean
we don't want to spoil any ending don't
give it away I'll let I'll let Simon say
about um just how close it was yeah very
close yeah very exciting match went all
the way to the wire as you expect with
us to and um yeah right right in the
harbor of Oslo as well a lovely place to
uh to play a bit of Chess and uh we
might have even had a surprise guest
come along and play a game or two as
well so uh we'll have to yeah wait and
see intensely what happens yeah we will
be revealing the result of that final
challenge between Danny and uh Simon in
Oslo later today so don't miss that one
for now it is all about game two coming
up in the losers quarter finals right
after this shot break don't go anywhere
thank you
the most elite bullet tournament returns
you don't want to miss the fourth ever
bullet Chess Championship featuring
Magnus Carlson for the first time he'll
join reigning champ Hikaru Nakamura 2021
champion alireza ferrugia and more to
fight for their share of the 100 000
prize fund it all kicks off on July 17th
at 9am Pacific
use exclamation point BCC in chat for
all the details
[Music]
basically it's a tool for improving your
chess game it gives you tailored lessons
for different phases of the game and it
seems like a very useful tool so again
better than players around your ratings
it looks like you get a really nice
overview over over your games and what
you need to focus on and what you are
good good enough at
to have all my weaknesses black and
white on paper is devastating and
interesting and fun at the same time the
middle games are a really rough and
aimchester said it to me again so and
that is definitely the most popular move
there today I actually learned a few
tricks in the opening that I
if you're a beginner it will pick out
kind of the basic things you need to
improve on and also Advanced plays is
very detailed at getting straight in
working out if you're opening is worth
your tactics and giving you some
personalized lessons so it's pretty
broad pretty much everyone
and aim chest was great at finding out
that most nearly everyone we had their
endings were actually very bad so they
need to work on yeah work on that area
of the game to be honest I think aim
chess can help everyone
um it's helped me especially approving
the opening realized my strengths and
weakness is there and in the end game
where actually I thought I was very good
but it pointed out areas that I could
work on if you want to improve on
anything from start and opening to end
games
I suppose
[Music]
it's the fast way to get stronger get
your targeted training in with aim chess
analytics and lessons and right now you
can get your first month free with code
CCT that's CCT at
go.chess.com aim chess
so go there right now and get working on
chess right now there are two players
who need to get working and it is Love
on our onion and Fabiano caruana as they
go into their final rapid games are we
going to get armor Gardens I think we're
going to get at least one Armageddon is
it going to be this one I don't know
that Bobby is feeling so fresh anymore
honestly we saw a pretty dejected
Fabiano when he when he faced this same
situation against Magnus uh but we'll
see maybe I'll have more energy against
Wesley and believe he has a better
chance to pull it off yeah if there's
even 10 of the twists and tons that we
had in the previous game then Fabio will
get a chance yeah so he just has to stay
in the moment and stay positive uh I
think that's the main thing the last
game could have gone either way it was a
bit unlucky maybe we'll see his luck
return here but Wesley opening with E4
Simon with a draw in hand if uh if
Wesley's feeling solid you think he'll
get it
well I mean we see the opening stage
Fabiano repeating the opening that you
played against Magnus Carlson so this
kind of uh potentially a hippo and I'm
wondering if Wesley will now bring the
Knight out and copy magnus's play uh but
he seems to get quite decent chances
there so we're kind of knowing now at
least level if you need to win this is
the way to play the modern which is such
a fun but dangerous opening and uh the
reason we don't see this all the time is
because look at White Center White has
this fantastic Center that black gives
away and we call this like a hyper
Modern Way of playing it was something
that chess plays didn't originally start
to do when chess became popular but you
attacked the center from the sides and
uh Wesley now having a big think about
uh what's set up he wants to go for yeah
I guess it's something you play if you
need to play for a win or something you
play when your back is against the wall
and you have no choice right because
there's a reason they take on a position
that is objectively so much worse for
black there are forcing lines that the
best player in the world know against
any of the other major weapons whether
it's E5 or the Sicilian or the Cairo or
the French and so you get these
positions where Bobby knows he's taking
on something that isn't going to be fun
but at least it'll have a dynamic of
chance but he's dead this this before
right I saw you were saying against
Magnus in a must-win situation this was
the setup that he employed and the fact
that Wesley slowed down before taking
out the bishop do you think he did see
that game the fact that this has
actually happened in the M chess rapid
100 yep 100 and uh the only difference
there is that the pawn in front of
Black's King was pushed one square uh
earlier which black can still play going
into that hippo and Wesley is is
basically no will know exactly how to
play against us I mean this is the thing
at this level right David that these
guys you can't you can't really surprise
him you know I mean like it's so hard to
surprise uh you know a play of these
this caliber you just can't do it uh but
Black's keeping all the pieces on the
board and uh this uh this is the
strategy you have to go for no matter
how risky it is yeah we've got a fun
game guaranteed and full of tension as
well so even if Wesley knows what to do
even if he knows the most promising
setups for white even if he goes for
something like Magnus did yesterday uh
Fabi will get a position
and yeah he's playing really really
quickly up to this point so I do believe
in Fabiano's chances I think he'll get a
moment or two where uh yeah he has a
shout and the other player who needs to
believe in his chances right now it is
Levon aronian they are ready to start
their final rapid game Eduardo they're
looking confident with the white pieces
he needs only a draw to further advance
in the aim chest rapid he starts with
the night move first and Lavon taking
this approach he's going to be
aggressive in this one David yeah it
looks like he's uh taking a leaf out of
Fabiano's book just playing G6 here
white isn't going to occupy the center
in the exact same way as Wesley is doing
but uh yeah Levon is just staying super
flexible feeling tattooing his Bishop
this is a key moment will he take some
of the center with one of the black
pawns or will he just set up like a
king's Indian
and there we go iterizago was sort of
inviting as well the system that he got
against Jordan uh over the the last
couple games now he lost the first one
to Jordan then ultimately won the second
chance he had on the white side of those
G3 Kings Indians right so Leb not
interested in that plays E5 we get a
more traditional English named after the
the gentleman here the English opening
your favorite my favorite accent as well
oh yes oh boy good boy
hold on now when you play it now it's
not a traditional English with F5 this
is this is a Leningrad Dutch potential
transposition here which we know can be
very aggressive for black on the king
side but also something that that can
get in trouble quickly
traditional anything went out of the
first form
at makes three pawn moves David it goes
against any traditional opening wisdom
what's going on here yeah yeah it's
essentially a reverse Sicilian where
black is trying to set up in a really
kind of close way you just keep all the
pieces on the board and attack and
wow with this last move of tirizago he's
saying okay I don't want as much tension
I want to clarify the situation in the
middle and yeah provocative chest from
both sides Black's taking every
opportunity to step forward with pawns
and now this Knight's doing a bit of a
dance it's going to lose a lot of time
but now that this Center has clarified
Eduardo knows exactly how to try and
chip away at the head of Black's Pawn
chain this one could get very spicy very
quickly
yeah definitely this is quite a typical
setup and a light White's move where he
pushed that pawn to D4 in front of the
queen I think that was the way that you
should play these positions you should
try to disrupt Black's Pawn structure
Black's got this uh Pawn chain of form
four pawns but they're quite static now
before they're a bit more mobile they
have more potential to cause problems
sir but Lev developing attacking the
pawn in the middle and now White's got
to make decision does he push that pawn
forwards and it's actually becoming very
interesting already because it's not
easy to defend that pawn there was very
quickly I had a very similar positions
to this when I was an international
Master on New Year's Day in Hastings and
um I was I played the movie E3 and I was
24 20 rated I think my opponent was 21
20. everyone is sure why that's a
mistake we can show and then can I just
clarify it was New Year's Day I just
want to say that one more time in the
Hastings competition the world's longest
ever running competition and I played
this move and it was a bit of a mistake
so my opponent took my knight and I said
what did you have possibly have been on
New Year's Eve I I was just having a cup
of tea with my friends of course and uh
some scones as we do in England I think
there's a rave on the pier until 9 00
a.m and um that was a long time ago I
don't do that anymore it's a really
funny show because even though Simon is
sort of making fun of himself we should
actually show that it's easy to make
that mistake because here's what you
calculate along your way to doing that
you say well
if I play D5 the Black Knight goes to E5
and now I have to guard C4 so I could
play E3 here but guess what the Knight
still hangs in that line and you might
even see it in that line so you back up
and go well if I can't protect the pawn
with my pawn bishop E3 feels super
awkward the truth is it shows how
interesting this position is that one of
White's best moves already instead of
Bishop B3 is actually all ready to play
F3 here and and that should tell you how
how crazy it is because after things
like H6 and the Knight goes back to H3
eventually we get a trade of the d-pawn
for the e-pawn and this is not a
position you see every day that's my
point how often can white play F3 on
move whatever seven and get away with it
and so anyway it just shows you why
blenders like that happen so I'm
defending you thanks offending
thanks man to make that mistake well it
was quite funny because like generally
people weren't looking at my games but
as soon as I blundered my night they're
like they're like wolves they can smell
blood you know no one was looking at my
games the whole tournament but as soon
as I plundered a piece there was 50
people there just pointing it's like
they could just smell my absolute pain
and Agony they were just there I looked
around what they had all these people
doing and yeah I had to resign that one
but
um it's a very interesting position and
this this is what uh Levon wants right
he wants something very chaotic so I'm
assuming he he should be quite happy
with the way things have gone here yeah
whether the objective evaluation is uh
fine or not for black I think just big
success just uh strategically it looks
really really imbalanced does he say
Simon and all the pieces on the board
just like in the other game
he's got Connect Four he's one connects
four with Black's Pawn chain on the king
side
what's not to like great game by the way
Connect Four I agree I thought you were
talking about the position which is also
going to be a great game no I'm kidding
Connect Four great game though wow so
love on our onion one more time going
for the imbalance in the position well
right now he's got to give it as all it
is his final chance to stay alive in the
aim chess rapid and we see a lot of pawn
moves so the narrative continues but
with every pawn moves there is a
consequent weakness that you make and
there is a lot of dark Square weaknesses
in Black's Camp here David yeah a lot of
weaknesses potentially in both camps I'm
wondering how tourism is going to break
in the center it feels like right now
black just has everything he wants so uh
you mentioned the dark Square weaknesses
let's just show some of those Tanya
there's uh potentially we see a knight
coming into this Square
to kind of harass this really awkward
Bishop for white you could make an
argument for pushing forward but now you
give black a nice square and yes you
might get a nice square of your own
later on but uh yeah I'm not sure you
want to give in order to take this one
it's really really tough this strategic
decision maybe you can push your point
to F3 as Danny highlighted in the other
line but again you have to be careful
that your king in the center is not weak
and not immediately targeted it's just
so complex and I wouldn't even know
where to start to be honest I'm inclined
to push F3 just because I don't know
what else to do but I think the more we
talk about it the more I mean we'll get
back to it again a little bit but as far
as what the two players got levonne
aronian has much better chances here as
black I mean objectively the position is
about level uh I think you just showed a
lot of lines that illustrate where white
could go wrong so as far as chances you
would want to get in a Muslim situation
is black I actually I really like Lev's
chances here and I do not feel the same
way about uh Mr Fabiano
yeah this is a good moment to check in
on that Juan as we see that the momentum
is Shifting once again in Wesley's favor
we will bring that up right now for
Lavon he has to he's done everything
right we will check back in with that
and here Fabi is still struggling to
make chances against Wesley yeah we have
seen the first trade of Pawns just on
this last move and the line has opened
up the white Rook on D1 appears down at
the black queen
I don't like what fabi's doing I've got
to say it feels like uh he started with
a hippo setup and he could be consistent
with the hippo setup normally you want
to make sure uh just like we were saying
yesterday all of the black pieces are in
the game before you uh start opening
things totally agree David I mean it it
seems like this captured a um black has
just played um is going to a symmetrical
position where only white can be better
and you don't want a symmetrical
position because there's more chance of
a draw and obviously you don't really
want your opponent to be better as well
so why did he do that why didn't he move
his Knight out first so he could have
captured on that square with the Knight
keeping it like a sicilian keeping it
Dynamic and that's what you're supposed
to do in the hippo and this is a very
aggressive move now from Wesley that we
we've seen played but um this is the
standard hippo set up isn't it David you
know you stay flexible day you can even
play H6 G5 you can do loads of quite
interesting stuff but um the way he's
played it in the game
um Wesley now playing this Pawn right
into the middle and those darts squares
they look quite scary Danny right not
only do I agree with you we should we
should call back to yesterday's game
with Magnus Carlson there's a reason
Fabiano didn't play the H6 97 thing but
if you remember it's because Magnus
pushed Harry the H Pawn he played that
H4 idea with H5 right which makes it
harder to sit there you highlighted that
there's even some sacrifices on G5 but
in this game Wesley didn't go for the
same approach so it seems to me that the
the idea you said of G5 and Knight G6
was on the agenda for black if he had
played for H6 so I agree again
um look Fabiano's in a tough spot no
matter what so it's easy for us to to
throw some shade But ultimately I I like
this position for Wesley and uh this is
going to be tough
gonna be tough immediately dropping his
Knight in the center of the board it
looks like a pawn sacrifice but I don't
think black wants to get greedy and
capture here it will cost him his dark
Square Bishop
that being said there is a pin on the
e-file what is Wesley's idea it's one
sacrifice right now oh no ah the night
night goes okay hold the phone maybe
bishop G5 Danny although yeah that's not
the drop it's just a trade we head into
an end game maybe this is uh going to be
great compensation for white only
needing a draw but okay we don't find
out he didn't test the idea there he
instead he hits the pawn with his Knight
but there's so many holes already I'm
looking at this Square this Square later
on I can bring his Bishop out to F4
looks like you're cramped with black
with not much compensation
the opening battle has been won by
Wesley and uh Fabi has to find a way to
not only keep things under control but
actually win this game earlier we were
talking about how Wesley's struggling
with farm and it seems as if Sabi as of
right now is the player in form what
worked for Wesley today so far
well it's it's funny because we we
talked about that how Wesley had been
struggling for him but we wondered
whether
sometimes with your back is against the
wall the best comes out right and and
Wesley finding himself facing
elimination has turned it around a
little bit and right now his back is
against the global championship trophy
that's true now his back is against the
global championship trophy he did switch
rooms and he's been playing better ever
since he switched rooms by the way is
that trophy yeah um so you know but it
is tough because Fabiano I mean we're we
didn't really get a chance to digest it
right really it's uh he's got to still
be reeling from that last game where he
was objectively better most game and
then maybe winning in the end and let it
get away so
I don't mean to sound like the writing's
on the wall but just looking at the
complete turnaround of these two guys in
their in their aim chess rapid campaign
it just feels like Bobby's going the
wrong way and and Wesley as I said isn't
going to be someone that anyone wants to
face going forward yeah and I I would
like to say a comment just came up on
the screen that I mean David just had a
little giggle about uh it was talking
about after party in the clothes he wear
and I just want to say that um don't be
fooled by David's smart clothes the guy
knows how to party as well you know he
he may come across as your English
gentleman but the guys the guy can party
I don't know what you're talking about
Simon I'm going straight back to study
some chess after this I don't want to
throw that in there so you know I'm
liking the shirt though we can all
appreciate a good shot thank you it's a
great show but Simon where is the after
body
um you tell me Tanya after the party
there's the after party after the party
yeah this was a party I don't know one
player who would approve of your fashion
choices is level neroni and Simon he's
known for his shirts as well did you
borrow one from him I I think we've got
different sizes but like I love I love
his shirts he's got a lot of cats on his
shirts doesn't he and dogs and I'm a big
fan but he's letting himself down a bit
this tournament we haven't we haven't
seen any really crazy shirts for him and
yet
um but I don't know his position as well
I'm just keeping an eye on that game but
also very interesting and he he may have
some chances though we also saw that
he's playing from San Sebastian so not
from his home right now I'm just
wondering he's just fresh from Dubai
well fresh from the tournament but not
really probably fresh and maybe it could
be the fatigue and the tiredness of
having played a really difficult long
event there and then not being home
playing from San Sebastian maybe that's
the reason that he's struggling with
Farm a bit it would make sense right
especially when you're facing someone
who's so fiery and and just so ready to
bring it right I mean churizaga this is
an opportunity that he maybe has never
had before right as he said so himself
and uh he he's got all the energy and
all the prep and and Lavon maybe maybe
Charlotte but of course we're spending a
lot of time talking about the the
players not on on screen here but
quickly back to this one let's let's
look at Bishop D5 because I worry that
that was uh an act of desperation a
little bit David trying to create some
chances but we might be heading for the
wrong kind of forcing lines here yeah I
agree Donnie also we could mention the
fatigue element with Fabiano he just
same thing yeah um so yeah let's jump in
and show this uh last move from Fabiano
he's planted his Bishop he's kind of
using it as a plug here to block the D
file to ensure that the white Rook can't
get through but I mean here I'm looking
even at the very minimum if you play a
move like dropping your Bishop back to
G3 for example you could trade off here
first and then drop back I just don't
see what black is doing next this Knight
is going to hop into D6 maybe even F6 in
some lines I actually think there's a
big threat of dropping this Knight in
for example uh let's say black waits to
move uh suddenly this Knight check could
be deadly you don't want to take it for
example uh suddenly a double attack a
hit on the queen a hit on the bishop and
um the other tactic in the position is
that you cannot capture on the East five
square with your knight because you're
simply walking into a nasty pin uh for
example maybe there's multiple ways of
doing it you can kick this Knight away
and suddenly bang you to capture and you
throw a knight out the way with a check
and you win a bishop due to this pin so
all sorts of tactics in the air he's
just taken this bishop on D5 so we're
headed in that direction
I was wondering whether you can take
with a pawn but again uh
uh feels like the tactics will work in
White's favor at the very minimum maybe
that's better you can plug uh you could
just plant the Knight and D6
beautiful for weight I've got to say
this Knight is dominating everything
instead a night capture on D5 and
instantly by Wesley dropping his Bishop
back Knight F6 may be a threat ideas
like C4 kicking this Knight away as well
everything against black right now and
Black's got three pieces attacking that
centrally five Pawn David you have to
show it to us why is it what is the
problem if black actually captures the
pawn all the tactics that do exist with
pinning and re-pinning yeah as I
mentioned Tanya Knight takes does walk
into the move C4 uh kicking this Knight
away first and as we show uh in a minute
wherever the Knight jumps same tactic
Knight takes Knight Bishop takes and the
Knight jumps out of the way I check you
cannot take this Knight because the
black queen will drop so yeah everything
just dropping with tempo for black
that's the problem right now
having big trouble
I think so strategically and as we see
there if he tries to initiate anything
forcing tactically in trouble as well
a difficult moment for Fabiano caruana
with the black pieces he could be very
well on the way of losing two games and
Wesley needs only a draw Fabi here
trying to gain some space on the queen
side with that pawn move is there some
hope of the knights jumping forward and
perhaps landing on D3 or is it too slow
he's got to try he's gonna try something
yeah he's got to try something but the
problem is a Black Knight can land on D3
so what when a white light lands on F6
is Checkmate
that's the problem uh you know the black
king is over there and it's a real real
Target so um yeah it just doesn't look
good there's too many holes and that's
the problem when you put all your pawns
on one color Square as you see black has
done on the king side all of his pawns
from light squares you naturally make
all the opposite color very weak so all
those dark squares around Black's King
they're just so juicy and there's
another dark square that a knight has
jumped into
yeah I was uh
just looking at that idea because I
think it's an interesting Gambit because
if you take it twice you're giving Buck
you're giving black the v file and a
whole bunch of pressure so when you're
when your back is against the wall you
got to come up with something something
to breathe life we can show it real
quick if it takes and takes white can
trade on A8 or not but I think the idea
is is really nothing special I think he
just wants to get some counter play on
the B file and uh that tells you how
desperate the position is though because
it's a pawn that's a pawns upon the
problem is you want to kind of put your
queen on the B file one of these squares
but this Pawn is also weak yeah and whoa
exchange sacrifice instead wait Wesley
is all in on the attack I love this
chest but Wesley I'm telling you Wesley
so is back I'm calling it right now that
this is this is like this is this is a
this is the thing to watch out for when
this guy gets going and I I regardless
of who goes to the losers bracket
between Notre back and Magnus I don't
want to face Wesley so anymore when he's
playing enterprising just like this he
doesn't even need to win and he's all in
this is this is the Wesley so we haven't
seen all tournament till now yeah let's
just show the idea he's uh blown open
the center now if this Pawn is captured
then suddenly it's a queen check and the
Knight jumps out the way ideas of
smothered mate but more importantly uh
this queen also just hanging so yeah you
cannot take this Pawn it's poisoned
Wesley looks like he's blasted his way
through to Victory what else can you do
you have to move this Knight out the way
but
white can take this Pawn white can step
forward spoil for choice so fun to play
as well you're getting excited
the heat is just coming off of you right
now I'm radiating it's just I mean look
at it it's beautiful yeah that pawn
diving down towards blank's King I I
love a good old attack it's one of my
favorite things you know having a having
a punt at the opponent's king and uh you
know you can even just win material by
pushing the pawn further and uh the the
dark Square Bishop of whites is so
strong why it's nice they're both so
strong everything is so strong and it's
for a measly exchange and I I think you
can see Fabiano body language his head
is slumped and um he knows he knows it's
it's getting closer to uh
the end our only friend the end but but
again but again in that rhyme that's
your friend Without End you can see a
friend without end and again we come
back to the fact that Wesley so didn't
even have to go for that in order to to
put this game away there were so many
simple ways to just take the B5 Pawn but
I I really am impressed by how he's been
able to stick through because this guy
was against the wall right about to be
eliminated by federal save yesterday in
Armageddon and and now is uh potentially
the man to beat in the losers bracket a
fetus have actually missed that win
didn't he that he pointed out yesterday
Daniel that King H4 so he has got a
Lifeline here you know Wesley and uh he
he could have been knocked out yesterday
and I I think that gives you more power
when you realize like oh I should have
got knocked out I'm still here uh let's
let's you know take advantage of that
fact and uh I think he's Wesley when he
he gets going is is just so strong as as
you say Danny taking down wall number
three right now and it's been very
convenient it's not just the scoreline
the first game it could have gone either
way but Westie really fought for it he
didn't go in with the repetition he was
ready to take his chances he did that
and this one was a Wesley so sure the
second game by the way he's I just got
word too from our fair play Team he's
playing in a secret lab chair so shout
out to secret life he must be comfy good
back support for him to be leaning in
like that uh but no I mean David I agree
with telling you because even though
Fabi I guess you could argue let more of
the game get away kind of snatch defeat
from the the jaws of Victory the fact
that Wesley didn't settle on a draw
right he smelled blood in the water and
he walked his King into danger I mean
again if you missed if you missed that
action it was wild and I think you could
sense a turning of the tide right
yeah and I think that's why I mean
firstly Wesley has so many fans because
he is so capable but it's also why some
of his critics do say okay we want to
see Wesley take more risk we want to see
him push because when he does go for it
uh it tends to pay off and yeah it feels
like Fabiano poked the bear and he's
woken up now Wesley and uh okay there we
saw black had to move the queen out the
way there was just too much tension on
that diagonal gave up a rook white
tonight isn't trapped though sorry I
just got a word in my ear that even
better Wesley is actually using his
Champions chest or a secret lab chair as
the desk the computer is on the desk and
he's leaning over
on the laptop I don't know if we can get
a shot from the fair play team we can
get Wesley's permission for that he'll
be fine with it just maybe for a later
show because I think he definitely is
playing in the most unique position of
all the chess players as we observe his
field of vision with the other cameras
you can't see so sorry totally off track
but I love it whatever he's doing it's
working
action so he shouldn't change the recipe
at all and as you mentioned David the
Knight isn't trapped because the queen
jumps in not only to defend the Knight
but actually to attack fabi's Knight as
well yeah yeah exactly Tanya multi
multi-purpose move there and I think
this is just the killer blue and the
question Simon is uh whether he should
resign just resigned there's a time in
life when you just have to resign we
don't want to do it but sometimes you
know it's inevitable isn't it it's tough
I get it we've seen it a few moments ago
I didn't want to totally call it but you
could see the dejected Fabiano losing
that game with white coming in here the
the tide has turned uh Wesley so gets
all the credit for for finding his form
right um but um but yeah I'm just super
impressed by Wesleyan unfortunately for
Fabiano he won't be playing in his third
Grand Final for the 2023 Champions chest
tour this could be the last few minutes
of my Fabi is running the aim chess
rapid yep
this level a piece is a piece and this
is a decisive material advantage for
those at home I think play on this
position there's always going to be
chances especially with Queens on the
board but yeah unless you're playing
Wesley unless you're playing Wesley
I think if you're playing a grand master
here that's uh you can resign with a
clear conscience an extra piece is going
to tell and okay Fabi reaches for his
Mouse what's he gonna do one or two more
moves here from Miz it's going to be
hard to keep the Queens on the board if
you want to keep the game going
yeah I guess the only chance that black
has and he needs well he needs like
three moves in a row uh without white
playing any moves uh is to use that
Knight try to take off White's bishop
and then win the white knight in the
middle trying to claim that the white
knight in the middle is a bit stranded
it doesn't have anywhere to go but uh
it's just not gonna work I mean it's far
too slow isn't it and Wesley has many
ways to to avoid that and I think he's
giving up he's giving up as he looks
like giving up yeah that looks like a
resigns resigning Furby face and indeed
he has that's it Fabiano caruana is out
of the aim chess rabbit Wesley saw
advances to the losers semi-final
winning the second game in convincing
style a heartbreaking day for Fabi
heartbreaking day especially because
he's a guy who uh well let's celebrate
Wesley real quick on camera he gets up
he knows that uh he knows he's back look
at that Global championship trophy there
which one is it it's the second shelf
it's in the globe the shape of the globe
well he's standing in front of it there
it is we see it there it is but uh
anyway no Wesley is dangerous in these
formats
Fabi is um
it's very still right now maybe he needs
a new lamp I just don't I'm not digging
the Vibes I thought it was a mushroom
when I first saw him but no back to your
point Tanya it's it's disappointing for
Fabi right he played so well day one ran
up against the buzz saw known as Magnus
Carlson his his old Nemesis right and
and and today uh wow the wheels just
came off there against Wesley so and
Bobby on the first match in just three
games and at that time it felt as if he
would be one of the big favorites to win
the whole thing but it's just such a
demanding and a grueling format and
every day you just have to show up in
your best shape and if you don't you go
down to a player like Wesley without a
chance yep well it tells you just how
hard this is right I mean this is why
punching your ticket directly to Toronto
which we can now talk about the live
finals you can get your tickets soon
fans is is a hard thing to do that's why
there will only be eight people there
um I'll reveal now too just because all
the players have been informed we're
also expanding it initially it was only
going to be four people brought to the
live final we will update your explainer
video we will have eight people so eight
of the world's best players will be in
Toronto it'll be worth your trip let's
let's go to Lev Because by the way I
said we would get one arm again I think
I'm Gonna Be Right oof David what are
the chances yeah uh firstly it looks
like a blocked tense position but I
agree with Danny it looks like Levon has
worked things in his favor not just
dynamically maybe there's something
right now but strategically long term
white Bishop whites Bishop G2 is utterly
dominated you can give it five six seven
twenty moves uh it's not going to break
out of the black pawn chain and Levon
he's just gonna slow play it he drops
his Bishop back the Black Knight is
going to come out the black king is
going to move Black's Rook that looks
really stuck on the king side is going
to eventually re-centralize and
meanwhile white unless you have a
breakthrough you just have to sit and
wait and Black's gonna improve I don't
think the same can be said of white
pieces it's going to be a long grind but
black has the advantage for sure but
this amazing Pawn structure that the lab
has all the Pawns in the light squares
you pointed out that light Square Bishop
that iterizaga has Simon is white
essentially playing a piece down right
now well the bishop is terrible right I
mean it says a horrendous piece but I
guess you you know White's real hope
error is that black can't break through
he's only got one break and uh the only
the only thing that black can do is this
move here that Dave is showing G5 and
that's got to work if that move doesn't
work black can't win this position so I
don't think it's as easy as I mean I
know the computer was saying that
Black's better but I mean that white
knight is fantastic White's got some
good pieces on the queen side I don't
think it's that easy to win this one
right it could be a very long game disc
though but but I think the the last
point we haven't highlighted is the
reason I'm so excited about Love's
chances it's the it's the 17th piece as
Tanya talked about it we haven't talked
about the clock and when we first went
to this game not just looking at the
eval bar and that bad uh Pawn of a
bishop on G2 looking at the clock was
really suggestive of what we're about to
see and I think here's what Love's Gonna
Do he's going to slow play G5 right he's
gonna Jamie Foxx slow jams this he's
gonna you know dim the lights turn on
some slow jazz and only when you least
expect it he's gonna play G5 and then
the position is going to get wild any
turizaga is only gonna have 30 seconds
on the clock
it's good tactic right yeah that tactic
and already we see maybe nerves or maybe
just a practical decision from a tourism
his last two moves have been Knight back
to D1 Knight to C3 he's just kind of
waiting he's saying okay I'm just gonna
almost pre-move this and okay we're
repeating the position just once
and uh second time we've seen this one
now
to recycle is he just going to keep
moving his Knight back and forth okay A3
not improving just waiting he's saying
to left okay I'm just going to play
quick moves you break through pressures
on you now you need to win probably the
right way to play right I mean if you
think you've got your pieces in the
right right position uh you've got to
wait for this G5 why I mean one thing
that I wouldn't do is white here is try
to move all my pieces to the queen side
and do something on that that edge of
the ball because if you do that then G5
this break we've mentioned will will hit
you and you're not ready to uh deal with
that one so you probably have to sit
here keep the Knight there keep your
rook in the corner and hope that that
move is not going to hurt you too much
will it will it really hurt why when
it's played I mean it looks like it it's
going to do some damage but how how
scaredy you think it's gonna be a killer
I mean blackouts it's time to prepare it
that's my point is he can do a lot of
things you can go slowly here you can
you can bring the knight from F6 out and
I don't know David whether the Knight
should come to G4 for black or uh I mean
obviously if you could put it on G4 next
you'd probably be happy but um
but even if it goes to H7 so I expect
okay he played Queen D7 love is still
hopefully not repeating again hopefully
he knows that a draw is bad for him
um but he knows it's not a best of four
oh he knows it's not a best of four it's
a good point but I think at some point
Knight F6 whether the Knight comes in
you will get G5 and the point is Lev
isn't in a hurry because why do it now
when you your opponent has time on the
clock he has to win right you have to
create mass chaos and you want you want
full out guerrilla warfare here with
with time scrambles with the best chance
to win yeah just look at what he's doing
though love he's slow playing it he's
blocked in this uh White Queen now she's
utterly stuck this bishop as we
mentioned is a just a big pawn and yeah
he's taking his time but I think he will
hit as soon as the tourism goes under 30
seconds under one minute uh then he's
gonna hit with this move G5 and blow the
position open he's the only one with the
dot squared Bishop remember and Dot
squared Bishop that was the key piece in
the previous game between these two as
well that's actually a great strategy
right there David Black's got one plan
for love he needs to get that break in
but wait for your opponent to come down
to those second and so that those
critical decisions get that much harder
for white to make and uh but meanwhile
we also see Lev's clock so when laying
down there less than three minutes for
him one and a half minutes the G break
the G5 break has to arrive but it's all
about timing it's going to come down to
those seconds on the clock yeah no and I
think it's the right strategy because I
mean he love his experienced and smart
enough to know that objectively there
isn't a concrete win on G5 you were
right sign right we all know that right
but or at least he hasn't calculated one
so again that's why I keep saying like
slow jam right take your time make sure
everything's improved and uh if you have
to win when objectively you know the
Breakthrough isn't isn't a concrete win
make sure that it only happens when mass
chaos will ensue and here we go like
okay I don't know if you played hd4 or
Knight H7 but he's he's still gonna wait
for it go ahead I think he's
I think it's a decision if a 2 a trip on
push he's gonna wait for it there is
August seconds to really go down on the
Block advances really shaking a lot on
the on camera yeah and by the way now
he's running the king
running shoes
I like it stay in the forest Camp
foreign
did you see Eduardo with the side eye
and I think he was looking at the camera
looking at Lev's Expressions right now
both players down to a minute and a half
on the clock and at some moment Lavon
has to take the big decision to break
and then it goes either way yeah that's
the that's the thing Hikaru would have
just played 50 quick moves and then
broken with G5 and 11 he's just way too
long it feels like yeah I agree I think
that that's again a little subtlety one
of the many that separates Hikaru
um from from others in these formats but
but I haven't given a pope yet I think
Lev knows it at some point we see him
give him a little shrug he's like all
right here we go he likes to kind of
Bounce a little bit he's gonna he's
gonna get G5 here it's coming that last
move hints at G5 getting the Rook ready
and as soon as G5 played this game's
just gonna explode it's gonna explode to
life because uh why can't why can't just
defend that move why it's got to try to
do something he's got to try to use his
Rooks now he's got a square for the
Knight to come into the queen side so
White's got to try to get something on
the queen side going now I feel maybe
now I might be coming in now let's yeah
the thing is in these positions you can
often wait so long because it's like oh
yeah I can always go G5 and you kind of
like you've got to play it at some point
you know so uh they're under him lives
under a minute now as well what still
doesn't do it and here comes that night
you see so why why it's not without
counter play here I mean uh that Knight
has a juicy square a really nice Square
it can plonk into I feel like it's all
part of the plan like Mr Burns like evil
I think he's just beating the position
to come forward because he knows G5
wasn't going to win on concretely on the
board anyway he needs it to work from a
practical perspective and both sides
have to be under a minute I think for
this to work he's got last time than
Eduardo right now it's true I agree it's
getting nerve-wracking but he's also
tricked white to putting everything on
the queen side so that when G5 comes G3
will be harder to defend and uh anyway
I'm uh standing by my arm again
prediction here it's getting very
exciting okay let's let's Okay I I have
to stick to my guns and say uh eduard is
gonna like draw or win I love it okay
just to keep it interesting I mean you
know I I what about you David
I've yeah I mentioned it earlier Eduardo
I'm scarred by losing armageddon's
against him he's super quick I'll say
Eduardo will hold although I like the
next position yeah Tanya so can can you
gonna back up Danny here two on two
um you know what I think Eduardo will
hold this oh my God I'm down three to
one okay I feel like if I would have
come at some point and love had more
time than maybe with this is 37 seconds
left double guessing himself when to
push that pawn weaknesses on the king
side for black as well the queen falls
back right now ugh I don't know but we
will put three glasses of water the good
night pub on it we'll see I'm down three
to one three yes that's a good night
here we go
and uh all right Lev I believe in you
man and that comes
but he's not pleased with the decision
that he just took why but why move your
knight away from such a great Square I
mean you you could have put the pawn on
that square or saying I mean it looks a
bit passive but maybe it doesn't change
too much right yeah I think it's just
reluctant to commit he also had very
tempting sacrifices White's Rooks could
have captured that black Bishop on B5
look for attempting but I think he was
shaking his head he doesn't have enough
time and now the flagging is uh starting
oh my gosh 15 seconds
and everything moving away from the King
side G5 is not happening anymore not yet
but you're right you're right the
pressure of the ears the other thing
though if it was that bad regardless of
how excited we are about the momentum
the eval bar would back it up I think
that Lev understands his chances are
slim but his best practical take is
still to uh repeat
it he's going to lull him into a false
sense of security
you'll scrape in the Battle Royale
you just hold the phone
it's gonna happen and why it just also
just waiting you got to do it before you
flag though
there was a threat Knight takes porn
there as well and Bishop takes F5 so
white is playing with ideas and now the
Rook can come in with a check which he
does he puts the Rook right in and uh
hello this is this is uh actually you
know why it's counter playing the queen
side is becoming very strong here
um with that Rook diving in and uh I
don't know this is I mean you don't play
G5 now move your king there surely that
that just looks weird you could have put
any pieces if you're King what is this
oh he jumps in he gives up the night but
he gets Black's Key Dark Square Bishop
is this going to backfire White's night
was also strong that was such a
beautiful night though wasn't it 56 now
and the bonds fall apart The Rook comes
the D6
and with it I might be three drinks down
oh my God five seconds for that he made
the last move with just two seconds on
the clock
he doesn't
Black's Queen was overworked there she
had to protect her Rook she couldn't go
and grab White's rook and white as one a
piece blacks Rook still undefended and
now there's going to be a mating attack
against the black king
turn around and you know what what is
too quick G5 just never happened that
g-pawn was just taken at the end he he
had to have played it right and love
shakes his head and makes a move with
just one second on the clock 36 and Rook
G8 and that's Checkmate on the board
Eduardo dursaga reacts he celebrates he
goes through he has knocked out love on
our onion
wow no Armageddon no Armageddon for me
my predictions are wrong I'm three
drinks down sometimes you can slow jam
for too long and the moment passes You
by at least at least the drinks are
cheap in Norway
look at that what a moment it is
tattoo that never give up and that's
what he did advancing into the losers
semi-finals after taking down one of the
best players in the world love on our
onion what a match that was one of the
biggest upsets that we've seen in the
Champions Chester Bayern Underdog by by
player low rated than anyone else and
that's a lot of reasons for Eduardo to
celebrate he should be celebrating we
see it we're getting it vamos Eduardo
right even though the prediction was
wrong about Lavon getting Armageddon you
have to be excited for a tourist Saga
and the guy continues to deliver when he
has his chance to do it
and David tell us what was the moment
that it all turned around it was 96
Tanya a beautiful move from a tourism
and this is why we love the Underdog
Story we saw how much it meant to him
and after waiting and waiting and
waiting for both sides
totally blocked position as well he
finally landed a blow he was quicker
than aronian and 96 was a move that
Iranian couldn't deal with with only a
few seconds left on the clock this is
due to the fact that the black queen is
overworked she wants to protect her
Bishop but she had to capture this
Knight it was too strong the bishop
Falls and this is where aronian did
blunder he needed to play a move such as
Knight back to D7 to block this white
Rooks path back to D6 instead he dropped
his King back and this was the killer
blow attacking the queen and next move
this Pawn dropped just to show the
winning tactic as well a blunder rugby
seven the queen overworked again Rook
takes Knight and if the queen had taken
Queen takes B7 would have been a killer
Beautiful Finish to the game
a beautiful match there played by
Eduardo durizaga and a classy finish
there with tactics on the board let's
take a look at our score line we didn't
get the Armageddon but we got fire on
the board in both matches as Wesley so
took it away with two wins against
Fabiano caruana and Eduardo durzaga
doing the same against lebanaronian it's
not a score many would have predicted at
the start of the day it's funny because
uh we we keep saying that the guys
who've had their back against the wall
maybe are finding their form and they
seem to be on more of a role than the
guys who joined them from the previous
winners bracket right and it worked out
that way turizaga and Wesley so who
started off with losses in the event
seem to be finding it and keeping that
form so it's impressive to watch in fun
games super fun games and with the
iterizaga talking
means to
be a big moment in his career a huge
moment and remember he could continue
he's still in the tournament if he wins
it that would be a life-changing
experience for him and yeah
congratulations I'm so happy for him and
I think it's inspiring for everyone else
who's outside the elite that they can
make their mark on Wheelchairs and we
are being joined by the man himself
Eduardo terizaga after is fantastic win
and a big smile there congratulations
Eduardo
hey guys thanks thanks I'm really
excited right now I'm really nervous and
really emotional because it's very
special to play
like I said yesterday against the super
Elite and and then I played this match
at getting iron the first game I think I
play really well and the second I don't
want to play this kind of position but
then I think I I I made some some moves
to
to have some chances to try to win or or
Draw and he have to push with G5 in some
moment that is not easy right to to push
but amazing
a really emotional window Eduardo tell
us taking down live on our own and
winning in this style what does this win
mean for you
is
I don't know if
motivation to try to
to to get better in in chess right they
always have a dream to to have 2600 and
and if it's possible more but of course
it's never easy right and then I have
difficult moments
even this year my my mom died in
marriage and it's a
of course I dedicate this for Harry
right
wow
that's uh that's a lot Eduardo yeah
Eduardo we're sorry to hear that in our
condolences with you and it's just 10
cents but I I I'm sure she's here with
me yeah
yeah Eduardo it's uh it's been amazing
to watch obviously you're you're taking
and making the most of this opportunity
and um is proud and they're with you and
I I wanted to say the internet has been
uh you've earned a lot of fans not that
not that I already wasn't a fan but
you've made a lot of people realize uh
just how good you are and how how well
you uh you play chess and a lot of
people are talking about your tattoo if
you don't mind telling us we know what
it means now because we we saw it
captured and it was translated on the
internet but what does it mean to you
why did you get that to that tattoo and
how is it a reminder for you to to kind
of keep your head up no matter what
happens
yeah because I think in in my career
like a chess player uh when I lost this
hearse really really hurts me but but
very bad and then I I try with the years
to improve
um
after the lost I always
I seen my tattoo and try to to get
better in the next one right now know to
try to lose two or three games in a row
but sometimes happen right but I have to
to try to mentally
stay in the in the tournament and in the
games and here in in the matches like
yesterday again Jordan and uh against
Farhan in the in the match in the
playing right that is
and of course I like to play tennis I I
sometimes I play more tennis than chess
but and
istanbabrinka has the the same tattoo
and is of course babinka is really
inspiring for for all the people even
not only in tennis because he's always
very competitive and if you watch some
games of tennis
babrenka you you know is always a fan
and and really competitive
and it I like I say I always see my
tattoo when I lost and then I try to to
get better in the tournament after I
lost
wow honestly Eduardo listening to me man
you're an inspiration uh this is this is
officially one of the best interviews of
all time and just everything you're
sharing is uh something I hope people
are making note of I I want to ask you
though
it's been so big right we can see how
big this is for you and you continue to
deliver now how do you do the thing of
keeping yourself focused and realizing
that as awesome as it is that you just
beat Lavon aronian you got more chess to
play and you might have a chance to come
back and win this whole thing so what
are you doing to keep yourself in the
right mindset one big win after another
right now I I just wanna share time with
my daughter my wife and my dad and and
then like in two three hours later I
will think about tomorrow but of course
tomorrow I will fight with all of my
heart and everything to to try to
to play one more day
Eduardo we're really looking forward to
that your chest is inspiring your story
is inspiring and your strength is
inspiring as well we wish you all the
very best for tomorrow
thanks guys thanks a lot
in an emotional interview and uh yeah
our condolences with him but he's
showing Amazing chess it almost feels
like chess's therapy for him
yeah when you hear someone talk like
that and it means so much to them it
reminds you that it is just a game and
it's awesome when a game can can bring
so much joy right and he do he does it
with a heavy heart right now right a guy
who's lost his mom too that was that was
interesting for me to hear and that
that's pretty awesome to see someone
bring it and really care so much about
what they're doing
and he's playing some amazing chess uh
beating Lebanon but more chess is to be
played by Eduardo and there's more chess
coming up as we will be having the
winners final the big matchup but we not
back up the sattro and Magnus Carlson is
coming up we will be back with all the
aim chess rapid action and just a few
[Music]
next Monday July 17th the bullets Chess
Championship begins where 16th of the
world's greatest speech chess players
will contend for the bullet chess Crown
will Hikaru defend his reign will feruja
block his path and take back the title
he held just two years ago and will
Magnus
bccw shake up the field entirely submit
your bullets Chess Championship bracket
now for chance to win 6 months of
diamond membership use comment fantasy
in the chat bracket submission close on
July 17th when game 1 of the BCC kicks
off
thank you
[Music]
foreign
click the link in the chess.com
navigation bar to try aim chest today
and increase your rating 31 faster than
standard tactics puzzles
when you sign up for aim chess our
powerful AI breaks down your latest
games and provides actionable insights
to immediately improve your game you
will also receive personalized lessons
created from your game history to help
you learn from your mistakes in a custom
made study plan to help you reach your
goals learn chess your way with aim
chess your digital chess coach
[Music]
unlock all your potential with aim chess
analytics and lessons targeted training
that's what you get with aim chess and
if you sign up now you get your first
month free Dakota CCT head over to
go.chess.com aim chess and right now
it's two players who need to unlock all
their potential because we've got a big
Winners final coming up in just a few
moments from now Magnus Carlsen and not
a back Abdu satra will make their first
moves guys clocks are ticking opening
predictions here what are we expecting
uh E6 by Magnus is he gonna take that
risk Simon no chance no I mean he's
going to take this really seriously uh I
think we got that as Danny mentioned in
the interview yesterday that Magnus
really wants this one he wants to show
who the boss is and he he's going to be
playing his toughest openings without
Shadow Without Andrea with this whole
new wave this new generations of chess
player is it extra special for Magnus
now to take them down every time he does
it yeah I think Magnus is more motivated
than ever especially against these young
players but that's no guarantee that
he'll manage to win because they have
showed especially after Satora for
himself that they are dangerous they do
not fear the king
They Don't Fear the game because they
want to be the king and let's take a
look at the regulations that we have for
the winners final it will be a best of
four 15 minutes with a three second
increment two and a half points is the
minimum winning margin it's uh double
elimination which means that the winner
books his spot into the aim chess rapid
Grand Final while the loser will drop
down into the losers bracket if the
match ends in a tie it will be
Armageddon Magnus there he's ready to go
with his chair with his hair not the
teapot pose just yet and look at that 18
year old not a bag of dosto he said it
he wants to play the world number one
and he's got his wish
he did get as well oh and magnus's runs
away in his chair going to fix his hair
uh maybe maybe um keep the rhyme time
going but uh yeah Magnus I think he I
think you guys said it right he wants to
bring it against these young players he
uh he likes the challenge likes to
remind everybody he's still the king but
I think the table's been so well because
these guys aren't afraid right and I
think it's something about the
generation who's grown up playing these
guys online like when their internet
didn't exist the first time you play
these guys in person you like freaked
out right now you're so used to it
they've had Blitz battles and bullet
battles and you've seen them streaming
it it kind of maybe works against them
right because they're not intimidated
they're not scared yeah often you need
to kind of be of a different generation
in order to not have that fear fear
factor and okay we're off it's a queen's
Pawn opening Magnus setting up will we
see a grinfeld a king's Indian defense
it's normal openings there no Asics love
to see the king's Indian
what are the chances say I vote I vote
felt good oh oh King's Indian yes
that's brilliant I mean uh I I love it
when Magnus plays King's in defense he
does it occasionally uh and this is uh
quite an interesting way of playing the
position a very aggressive way because
that Queen will obviously and often uh
swing to the other side of the board and
go for an attack against White's King
but a bit bit irregular there that that
that plan and that move David yeah a
very rare move order here we see already
Abdus who's actually one of the best
prepared players in the world even at
this tender age uh he did pause for
around 30 seconds there and he
eventually blocks this check with his
Knight so black has options now due to
the fact that this white knight is
pinned you can jump into the center
there we go Magnus asking questions it's
only move six but uh there is a
strategic threat on the board to capture
this White Knight on C3 Abdul satorov
how's he going to react to this I must
admit I am not familiar with this
exactly I'm gonna say I mean I'm
we're kind of on our own and I think
Notre back might be on his own too it's
kind of tactics here as well I mean
white could just move the queen uh to C2
here and then you know the bishop could
line up and another Knight could move
that it could get incredibly uh complex
here or already and I was thinking now
maybe the Knight could move to attack
that Bishop but I I don't know if that
works I'd have to calculate this very
carefully uh if I was going to play it
and as white I don't really want to
double my pawns so I want to have uh an
answer for Knight takes night I wanna so
yeah it's getting a bit complex an early
stage you know this is the idea you mean
so that you don't have to double your
pawns on C3 I guess Simon yeah that's
here you can play Bishop to D2 and
recapture next move yeah and just try to
try to say I've got a bit of a space
Advantage but uh of course I say that
and he's gone and double his pawns
immediately
which which with the queen on B3 makes
more sense because you're you're you've
got the open file to try and tie down
Black's Bishops here it's funny but
because it's sort of a nimso Indian
structure but black hasn't had to part
ways with the bishop here in order to
get it right and I wonder David how you
would attack this structure again I
don't play this opening or these
positions you said you're on your own
too because to me blackhead black could
consider playing C5 at some point right
as slow as it is just to fix those
double pawns and then try to re-maneuver
the queen side where you do things like
a nimso where you play eventually you
know the Knight to C6 to A5 and B6 and
Bishop A6 and it's a slow game but you
say those are doubled isolated pawns
that aren't going anywhere
um and I wonder I wonder what type of
plan Magnus will employ now that he has
a Target like that yeah exactly E4
notabec taking space here I think we
might well see your plan Danny it just
makes a lot of sense not just to kind of
create a nice Square for the Knight on
C6 but also to lengthen the diagonal of
this bishop on G7 essentially you have
to decide at some point to block with
either C5 or E5 you cannot allow white
to just continue stepping forward but
yeah big big strategic decision taking
by taken by another back here I would be
terrified having weak pause like this
against someone like Magnus who's known
for kind of capitalizing on these small
uh kind of minimal advantages but yeah
he's fighting dynamically here not
scared at all especially if we keep the
comparison to the nimzo going white has
this big Pawn Center again similar to
some attacking variations of the nimso
but normally black doesn't have a fee
and Kettle King side right which makes
this position harder to attack for Notre
back so again I I'm liking the dynamic I
anticipate Magnus to maybe Retreat the
queen before he plays C5 but we'll see
because you want that A5 Square
available right if you do play C5 so a
lot of Dynamics but a very original
position
that we have here and I think that
favors the uh now I have to say former
world champion
yeah no agreed um but you know I'm also
liking the center you know I I love I
love having space I I love having uh big
Pawns in the middle of the board which
which have potential and the white has
those pawns you know White's got free
pawns that can generate an attack at
some point if white moves the Knight
away he can get another Pawn going as
well that'd be something I'd be be
looking to do here maybe uh just get the
F Pawn going Freddy and just lunge that
up the board so I mean if I was going to
pick a side I'd rather be white maybe
it's personal choice uh even though I've
got the double pawns I've got more
chances to uh uh get active playing I
think naughty Beck loves loves attacking
loves active play so not all bad just a
very interesting position I think right
very interesting positions especially
because I think Magnus had the
anti-young player approach in the
opening going into unfamiliar territory
just getting him out of a book and it
could be because of the amazing
impressive uh prep that not a back
showed on day two as well when we talk
about Magnus often I think the popular
opinion is he's the best of all time one
of the best full-time and for some he's
just good and then it's like where do
you strike how do you beat him what are
his weaknesses and he just seems to do
everything better than every player and
while the other established elite
players of the world they do struggle to
score wins against him we often see this
younger generation right Prague for
example winning against Magnus from time
to time not a back uh Tata steel David
mentioned World rapid we've seen these
performances by them how are they
managing to do that what kind of play is
required to actually make that a reality
yeah I would even say artemia the year
before taught a steel that was a big one
too it's
it's a great question Tanya I think that
partly David touched on the fact that
there is a psychological Edge Magnus
tends to have against his generation and
sometimes that we see that historically
whenever a torch is passed it takes the
Next Generation to grow up and be like
no big deal right I got this guy just
because whatever ignorance is bliss if
you will but I also think there's
something to the specific X's and O's
that every Next Generation grows up in a
different period these guys grew up the
other guys grew up getting to know
Magnus in real time these guys grew up
studying his games they also understand
a little more of his style they also
have appearing with have been preparing
with computers in a different way where
we're talking about the Renaissance that
has been injected into the game with
with Alpha zero and the Leela neural
Nets where they just play more creative
chats so I think it's a number of
factors but I would I would argue that
the psychological one is probably one of
the biggest that they're just not scared
of him yeah they don't back down from
calculation battles that's something
that a lot of people were scared of
against Magnus uh back in the day that's
why he used to get a lot of end games
because they were happily taking things
down more simple parts now the young
players realize they can't back down
they just have to kind of Fight Fire
with firing
okay Push by four from uh tutorial yeah
it's I think it's just a good strategy
just not backing down and we can see
that with his decisions in this game
taking the structural weaknesses taking
the center taking up the challenge so
yeah I I think there's that like a full
Hardy thing of Youth as well I think
when you're young you just don't fear
anything you're like Invincible right
and it's like Magnus it's like well I
don't care who he is you know I can beat
him and I it reminds me I was playing a
young Wayne Jones I was a grand master
he was uh he wasn't even an
international master and I remember like
he was exactly the same and I think a
lot of strongest players they they just
don't have the respect you know it's
actually you they say you should have
respect for your opponents you should
have respect but actually it's kind of
the opposite you shouldn't have that
respect uh Hikaru another player when
when he was uh doing all these great
things he didn't really have that you
know he did I mean all of my opponent
kind of thing he just wanted to beat
them and uh I think it's actually yeah
just being Fearless is yeah and having
no respect is actually the thing to the
thing to try and on the chessboard it's
good to have respectful on the chess
board yeah in general yes only on the
chessboard I think um by the way I gave
the nod that maybe Magnus uh gave Fabi
the draw yesterday out of respect and
but I just saw a comment in chat that
Magnus actually purposely ended the game
as quickly as he could so he could play
and then win the late title Tuesday
yesterday for those of you who didn't
see it he went and played title Tuesday
after and then and then one and uh
anyway sorry that was totally
distraction but just give him Chad a
shout out that that was a great comment
no such thing as through my chest for
these guys
he takes on Fabi and then goes on to
crush title Tuesday and just going
forward on what you just mentioned Simon
perhaps for a lot of his own generation
and his own colleagues so Magnus Magnus
kind of lives rent-free in their heads
uh but for these guys they don't let
Magnus get into their head and that's
something that's really important when
you're playing against world number one
otherwise you just psychologically lose
the battle before the game even starts
yeah 100 I mean uh yeah you say you
can't be afraid of them in any any shape
or form if you want to beat them right I
mean you just got to show no fear I mean
David out of ocelot you've probably
played these guys more and uh what what
have you found is your approach when
you've you've played Magnus you've
played all these great players more more
than us our slot here yeah I mean uh
being from the same generation I'm
certainly uh part of the ones who kind
of we have this Fear Factor uh Magnus is
like the guy that's just unbeatable but
I've also played against some of the
younger ones and I remember analyzing
with players like Prague and and uh it's
just the confidence afterwards he was
saying oh I had this and this I was
always winning I was dominating I was
better I was like are you sure we'll be
playing the same game and of course we
chat with the computer and it said I was
never in trouble and I think that
actually that kind of helps them this
optimism it's like we're saying with
youth
um and I was also at training camps
where Magnus was there and prag and some
other young young players and
um like Danny was saying they showed
them respect they show Magnus respect
off the board they attended his lectures
and things but they played some Blitz
and there was some trash talking they do
not fear him at all so who who's got the
the biggest trash talk game out there
okay are you gonna let us let us in I
mean it's not a bad thing to say yeah
let's just say the uh the young Indian
prodigies
they've got the talk they've got they
walk the walk but they can also uh talk
the talk I'm surprised to hear that
actually you look at them they just seem
like the nicest most modest chess
players Prague and I just can't imagine
them doing the trash talk I can't say it
they grew up consuming Khan content and
they grew up watching Magnus and viral
videos like two week too slow right so
back to the point where like they say
the hero always creates his own villains
there's a reason that usually the best
player in the world is is unseated by
someone who comes up of the Next
Generation who watches them was partly
inspired by them I mean all these guys
are inspired by Mammy's but eventually
they're the one who takes you down
because they they not only probably grew
because they learned from you but
ultimately they're not as afraid of you
because they didn't grow up watching you
dominate they don't have any emotional
any issues there so I I think it there's
a reason it happens the way it does and
I'm actually not that surprised by their
trash talk because I know something I
don't yeah I've also seen it so yeah wow
it sounds like the story of when your
Idols become your arrivals and right now
uh of the Central in a bit of a tank
after magnus's last move developing the
Knight and moves the bishop twice
creating a threat of his own yeah so
interesting he's lost a move he's lost a
Tempo here Abdul sotorov by moving his
Bishop twice in a row but he has lured
the Black Knight to D seven Danny was
highlighting the Black Knight wanted a
more active Square he wanted to come out
to C6 to put pressure on White Center
but he's saying okay I'm happy to take
that take that hit that temper loss but
your knight is inferior to where it
should be standing interesting move and
now he's forcing Magnus to react do we
think Magnus is just going to shuffle
just defend uh this E7 Pawn with this
Rook it's a bit of a slow turn this last
couple of moves I've got to admit this
uh this bishop maneuver is slightly
mysterious to me at least
yeah I mean it it does make Magnus do
something
um I
I'd be a little bit worried if I was
white here because uh White's just sort
of playing normal looking moves but uh
Black's plan seems a bit more concrete
right and I think you've pointed out
already Black's just going to Target
White's double pawns it's very simple
you can attack them with your knight
attack them with your bishop and uh if
white doesn't do anything you know
you're going to be in trouble so so
white has to come up with a plan and and
it does seem like there's maybe a slight
drift there with the last couple of
moves I don't really know if White's
found that plan yet I I love what David
highlighted that the purpose of the
tempo loss was to kind of put the Knight
on an awkward square and then when it's
not on C6 where it would have guarded
the E7 Pawn now I go to G5 where I can
Target it and maybe if I force you Rook
to E8 that's a position where the Rook
is later is later awkward but I expect
Magnus to play rookie eight and I will
say that just from a practical
perspective this type of game where the
players are uncomfortable with the
structure it's a it's it's awkward and
they're really I mean how many moves are
we in here right we're 10 moves in and
they really lose a lot of time I feel
like this is what Magnus wanted right
and uh you referenced the the towel
quote yesterday Tanya right take your
opponent into into the dark woods I
think that I think that not only because
of what we saw notorbeck do against
Iranian where some prep got wild and and
notabeck was super dangerous I think
that just because of magnus's uh
approach to younger players this is this
is what he wants to do as far as um
getting the game off the beat off the
well-traveled path
and he is getting a game but also on the
clock both are levels so who would you
describe this as favoring the opening
outcome who's happier here out of the
opening I would say both sides are happy
there we go Magnus played the move uh we
predicted just keeping everything
defended I think Abdus is happy because
it's imbalanced and he doesn't want a
slow grind where magnus's kind of
superior experience and we saw the aim
chest stats magnus's end game skills
might come to the fore here it's in the
middle game peace trades are unlikely in
the next few moves so I think Abdul's
tour of has some reason to be happy
Magnus he's happy because he survived
the opening objectively he's fine and uh
he'll still believe long term he can
profit from White's slightly compromised
structure so I think pros and cons right
now in the next few moves will be
critical in this middle game fight and
Danny your idea coming up on the board
Magnus targeting those double Bonds in a
different way but same concept and he
could potentially even be looking at
offering a queen trade David endings who
does that favor in this kind of a setup
going to say Magnus I just think long
term if the Queens disappear White's
pawns look weak just having this
extended Center looks nice and pretty
while it's the middle game but uh yeah
the more pieces disappear the more
responsibility they'll be for white and
more weaknesses potentially
and uh yeah if Magnus can trade on his
terms then great Abdu satorov will be
looking for ways to ensure that doesn't
happen or if it does that it will be on
White's times completely agree with the
last points you made I completely
disagree with the first one you made
about Notre brick being happy here I
think that Magnus is the happy one here
and I and I I think that I think that
Magnus played Knight B6 quickly I expect
that uh again like it's it's equal and
these guys are both super strong Grand
Masters but I think Magnus is
objectively very happy here Here Comes
Bishop B7 here comes a traditional nimso
style maneuver and assault of the queen
side pawns and uh I think notrex clock
is only going to keep ticking here for a
little bit
worrying how much I agree with you Danny
they still don't do that
I mean look they put us on camera
together oh no hi hi everyone
and um but it it is I mean I agree I
mean I think Magnus if he's going to
play this opening he's got what he
wanted right and he's got some
weaknesses to attack I just kept the
piece on the board there's you know it's
it's going the kind of way it does and I
was just looking at I was just looking
at magnus's chairs in the background I
was just like thinking to myself my
brain kind of like drifts off
occasionally and I was thinking like how
could we improve his bedroom and I think
it could we get like you know because
Magnus said yesterday he's got those
chairs of people like David to come
along and Stream So I was thinking could
we get like maybe uh some kind of dull a
lot even mannequin made with David's
face on it just put it in the background
while he's streaming it might just been
really weird
in my office laying around I got Magnus
over there and Fabio I I get a fan of
David I gotta get that I'll put you in
Magnus together can we do that but
Magnus in the background maybe someone
else there just just to make him feel
like he's you know that social character
he really is you know we've seen some
mannequins and David's crib previously
in the Champions Chester season that
video
it didn't happen you see some mannequins
in David that's all I'm gonna say really
it's all on the internet are you sure
they're mannequins they're not
life-sized life-sized don't say it Simon
back to the position
poor Dave is called defend himself at
least there's too much out there just
pointing out norabeth continues to think
I I I think that uh this is
uncomfortable for the young guy and um I
do want to share a comment because Magna
said on osclid's uh podcast working
super hard in the back shout out to you
Oscar that uh well he's he everyone
knows he kind of dubbed all he res as
the next best talent of all of them but
he did specifically call out abusa turov
as a guy that he that he's taken a note
of and seen that he's always in the gym
working out and he uh and he's got his
eye on him as a fighter so anyway I but
like I said when I accidentally poked
the bear yesterday I had a feel I said
it last night I said I have a feeling I
told you I have a feeling Magnus is
going to show up here like wanting to to
remind everybody that uh may not be as
good as he once was but he's as good
once as he ever was and I think Magnus
wants to win this match yeah yeah I must
admit uh I was watching Magnus stream
tied to Tuesday when he won and
afterwards he well he was still
streaming and I thought okay let's slide
in with a sneaky challenge I challenged
him and on stream he literally rejected
me he said nah I need to go home and
sleep we've got a big match tomorrow so
that shows how much he wants to win
today wow or he's just terrified
because you might have crushed him and
then uh you know like you know you've
done it before
Magnus wants to win this one and I think
uh Danny or absolutely right you might
have poked him a little bit there with
the world rapid Champion situation and
look at that uh not the back of the
satrobe offers a queen trade if Magnus
accepts it that would mean his Pawn
structure improves but Madness I don't
know if you got his uh expression Queen
a little bit he was surprised by this
move no he did and it was a wince of
kind of like a Hikaru number seven like
uh I don't think so buddy he's like it
was a wins over I don't believe it and
whether that means David he can take C3
or not you're the you're you're the
Super Girl
honey ah there's a hanging Rook on E8 so
oh okay I wasn't even paying attention
to that why was he wincing then is that
uh maybe he just didn't expect it I
think Magnus was dreaming of ways that
he could trade queens and then he's
saying okay you go for this uh on your
terms how dare you and uh either you
have I mean there's two moves that I can
see either you have to trade off and
like Tanya says suddenly white has a
better Pawn structure connected pawns or
maybe you can be a bit sneaky and keep
the Queens on like this x-ray vision
protect your Rook
um I'm just borrowing an idea you
mentioned earlier Danny that's a nice
move though Queen A4
and it does come at the cost of some
calculation you have to wonder what
happens if white captures a pawn and
maybe grabs on C5 but as far as I can
tell you might be able to take this Pawn
uh you might be able to take this pawn
it gets a bit spicy gets hot here but I
like Black's compensation even if you're
down upon because long term these will
simply fall off the board uh they're two
weeks so knowing Magnus I think that he
wants to keep the Queens on and he's
paused which means he does see options
he doesn't go through the automatic but
commentators curse he does trade off he
might have seen something here to do
with the fact that White's Pawn at least
temporarily on B5 is a bit weak
go home
this is the move I think uh he had lined
up right I mean this is uh I think he
should play this poor white can put a
Pawn on that square and uh it kind of
looks like summer White's pawns are
still a little bit weak white doesn't
have those double pawns anymore but you
know there's still targets over there
right so I I was I was gonna say that
because even though I think we
objectively looked at Queen takes B5
like all right that fixes Pawn so that's
the quick thought Knight A4 proves that
they're they're maybe maybe they look
better but they're not totally fixed yet
and I'm gonna keep them separated with
Knight A4 and even A6 is a possible move
now right because when you when you
force him to take the A2 Pawn comes
Under Fire and I yeah I like that the
computer likes it because A6 is a way to
expose that The Rook had to leave the A1
Square in order guard C3 so 94k Bishop
E6 next now we see it but watch out for
this A6 move coming because both the
bishop and The Rook would be lined up on
that file hitting the a pawn
yeah weaknesses in White's Camp I just I
just feel every time Magnus players and
the Queens are off the board it's time
to
just resign it is I mean whenever Magnus
gets more than he gets these like little
he just finds his little nibbles don't
he's like
I don't know what that was again he's
like nibble away like a little like you
know I was thinking like you know a
little rabbit at your ankle you're not
annoying
he's like that and it's like get off
your little rabbit and it's like before
you know the rabbit's eating you what's
happening
I don't know it's been a long day Danny
and um that's what Magnus does he
nibbles nibbles nibbles and uh yeah I
agree Tanya when the Queens are off it
it is quite an uncomfortable situation
um certainly certainly Magnus is better
here right I mean he's got targets to
hit someone else help me out please I
was I think it was actually the perfect
description of what it's like playing an
end game against Magnus he's a nibbler
he's a nibbler
I've been watching too much Monty Python
or something or something thinking of
yeah I was thinking of the rabbits in
Monty Python definitely meanwhile yeah
awkward move there from Abdul Soto if he
puts his rook and see to defends his
uhk2 Pawn but suddenly I'm thinking
about those incest stats Magnus end game
accuracy was what almost 80 percent
finding the best move
so often here and yeah just looks like
awkward pressure there's tactics in the
air A6 Danny I'm loving it just
strategically really desirable
to activate that black Rook on A8
too so and here he goes he plays it
recall A6 on the board and uh trying to
create more weaknesses in white spawn
structure that would be a bad idea to
open up the A-line so he does fall back
with the bishop and now perhaps black
has to avoid trading on B5 giving this
Tempo to White
yeah if you again trade on your
opponent's turns then you might regret
it uh for example here there would be an
awkward hit on the black Rook when you
move the black Rook then you might just
lose this Pawn uh still some calculation
to be done here but instead Magnus
doesn't want to calculate at all he
plays a really nice move first he plays
H6 kicking the way away this Bishop from
the attack of this pawn and when it
Retreats maybe now Tanya is the time uh
now if it's uh there's no pressure on E7
to take and just park your Rook on C8
all of Black's pieces are kind of
peering now down towards these
weaknesses and if you can sense the
X-ray the pressure on this C pawn and
it's just a bit awkward
I love what you're highlighting in this
position really shows why black is in
control here because shout out to our
guy Robert Hess who always loves
highlighting Paul intention because
usually you can evaluate again who's
better based on who the brakes would
favor and black gets to build up and
take at the right time like maybe right
now it's pinned but if you if you back
up and point out that nothing nothing
good could happen for white if white
pushes the d-pawn you open up the dark
Square Bishop right if you if you take
on C5 the Knight Will capture and you
open up the Rook right and in all of
these you could have taken C3 even too
but I guess we're proving the point that
usually we can evaluate captures as to
whether they're good or not based on
does this capture give me more options
for my opponent every pawn move for
white gives black more options which is
which is a really tough spot to be
because your opponent gets to kind of
build the water against the dam right
and eventually it breaks and it's hard
to find moves here for abusive Turf that
don't make the position a little worse
and he's forced to put his two Rooks on
really passive squares and uh still no
way to get out of this awkward tension
for white it looks like Magnus if he can
we'll try to just slowly improve the
position you can already start for
example kicking away away this bishop
from this active post on B5 and yeah it
feels like one-way traffic right now but
he's covered all the holes so we should
praise him for defending so far and
still level on the clock I think it's a
sign of great players that you you don't
always know where one side's gone wrong
right I mean Magnus has suddenly got a
good position but where did he get that
good position from right I mean what did
actually white do wrong in this game and
it's not really that clear you know he
didn't do any bad moves he didn't do any
blunders he didn't do any positionally
big bad moves uh so it's like yeah that
is that's again a sign of real class and
I really like this last move because
this is something you see in uh in the
grunfield a lot and I think White had to
play this poor move because otherwise
the the bishop was going to slide past
that and gain a very nice Square so uh
um yeah so this this looks kind of
forced and it's there's just a lot of
holes that Black Knight has a lot of
potential and the black Rook as well on
the open files so it's it's very tricky
for white it's funny I think I think the
only move that abducator did wrong was
the one you were telling him to avoid
which was doubling the pawns early on I
mean after that it's been it's been just
a slow slow as you called him nibble
Carlson nibble constant nibble the
rabbit Carlson yeah we could perhaps say
that uh that kind of loss of tempo where
he was trying to be a bit clever but
yeah
actually it helped the Black Knight
Black's night turned out to be on a
great uh kind of a great circuit there
but uh yeah can he hold this this is
what Magnus would call anti-young player
chess it's like Queen's off the board no
risk but your extra piece
the extra piece the 17th piece is the
clock and right now Magnus Carlson
touching the two and a half minute Mark
offers another trade and I like it
because uh you were mentioning the night
the Black Knight has all these jumping
squares there's one piece in White's
camp that actually defends those squares
and that is the white Bishop Magnus
trying to get rid of that makes a lot of
sense yeah I mean it's it's really
important when you're playing any
standard when you get into the middle
game you just gotta exchanges are so
important and you just got to work out
if I exchange these two pieces does it
help me or does it help my opponent and
you've got to have reasons you've got to
be able to explain to yourself how it
helps and the idea of this is that the
Black Knight gets more squares it's as
simple as that white does have this open
B filed out and we were saying a lot
about how Magnus is playing
fantastically and he's doing so well
it's certainly not over yet uh with that
last move White's trying to gain some
counter play on the B file but it is
just like you know going really in
magnus's way so far I think this game
will he grind this one do you think
you'll be able to with given the clock
situation with the slight Edge but is it
enough
I think so because like everyone else I
suffer from Magnus biasitis it's it's an
Affliction
um and Magnus bias tells me he will and
his accuracy in the end game has earned
that bias but but I do love how
noterbeck has played these last few
moves really tenacious defense here uh
Rook to B1 is a nice is a nice chance
again if that light Square Bishop Falls
you pointed out telling you C4 becomes
available even A4 so I think it's tough
and you can't double Rooks because the
bishop is going to grab C3 so I'm still
struggling to see the best moves here
for for Notre back but but okay I mean
the clock I love that this is becoming a
mutual time scramble if I'm an
abusator-off fan right let's take this
thing into a scrable and uh and take my
chances at the king there
until you remember that Magnus is great
at Blitz as well darn it
he's just good at everything
but we're talking about a guy who
doesn't let that get into his head I'm
gonna predict a drawing this one I think
Abdul satra will be able to hold this so
are we uh going double or nothing on our
good night drink situation or is that
six glasses of water
I'm just you know being PG here for the
kids because the water is the only thing
you can drink and that's what you should
drink no more soda stay hydrated throw
away kids drink water yeah and uh right
now I'm just a tour of okay he's tanked
there but drops his Knight back to D2
quick trade Magnus Retreats look at the
speed speed yeah speeding up that I mean
uh yeah you've got to change Pace aren't
you as well that's another sign of what
the top players do uh you know when
you're getting shorter time you just
gotta like hang on a bit right I'll just
move up the Dodge put it into Speedy
mode and uh Magnus is doing that I mean
his Knights uh hasn't found a great
Square on on the queen side Queen side
the Black Knight but he's his Pawn
structure is so solid and that's another
problem that white has look at White's
paw on the left hand side on A2 that
pawn on A2 is a straggler it doesn't
have a brother next to it that can
defend it it's all on its own uh it's uh
Billy Billy no mates or Ari no mates
over there hasn't got any friends to
look after it and uh black can just line
up against it right the other Rook could
come over and this is another issue just
little positional things that that white
has to worry about here no weaknesses at
all for black here maybe B7 slight
weakness but not a major problem right
and you know what Magnus wants to do
eventually when he's all lined up once
the black Rook lands on A4 he's going to
switch his attentions to the other flank
is that theory of two weaknesses two
Targets you kind of focus all your
opponents energy on one side and then
you switch suddenly and Magnus has Pawn
breaks you can play moves like E6 or F5
at the right moment and uh start
chipping away there after satora's gonna
have to be so accurate and that 17th
piece but yeah I was gonna say abusive
is going to be accurate he's gonna have
to go quickly he's got 20 seconds make a
move and there's still big decisions to
be taken in this game this is just
getting started and you mentioned the
Rook moving forward creating more pawn
moves and now the doubling up is about
to happen I was gonna say that was a
huge moment there because Magnus induces
C4 who does it take the Square from the
Knight which allows you to play B6
because there's no more Knight C4
targeting B6 so the technique there
phenomenal right Rook A4 first and do C4
and then slide The Rook over with B6
that's a great point because so many of
us would just push the pawn already but
you actually take away a key Square from
your opponent and right now it feels as
if Abdullah is hanging by a thread yeah
just keeping things defended but it's it
it feels like one more attack and David
will fall apart where will it come from
Wow Magnus argue is just going to fall
apart on the C4 Square he's giving up
his own B Pawn in order to get some more
some more juicy targets and I thought he
was going to slow play it white pieces
were utterly stuck utterly paralyzed the
white Rooks Knights but he's trying to
cash in now oh seven oh he's got it
swing on he needs to make a move three
yeah two oh he moves and he goes
passively and now yeah I mean this
that's a free Pawn it's a free well this
is e66 so maybe Magnus will slow play it
just defend his own weakness on B6 the
threats persist I don't see how he does
that F4 might you have to be careful not
to miss your chance and I think Magnus
is so good at not just smelling blood in
the water but having that sense right
for the moment where you can't keep
building because if you play If you
defend the pawn just wake it at four I'm
happy to part ways maybe with the dark
Square Bishop as long as I hold so
I think that's what Magnus is
calculating right now and he'll be the
one to tell okay he allows it so the
question is
I think practically it was working I
think exactly it worked out yeah and now
maybe black is just going to go porn up
I mean uh this is this kind of Pawn
structure this is so important to know
your Pawn structures at home you see the
structure and the benko and the benoni
opening and I think it it's well it is
very well known but as soon as the
Queens come off white is so exposed
those pawns and blacks pawns are are
really Compact and these kind of middle
game endings are nearly always losing uh
for white uh so so know your Pawn
structures you know if you're if you're
playing any opening you've got to know
what you're doing in the later stages of
the game not just in the opening and uh
okay this is a very sensible movie I
mean he he's not rushing maybe there's
something a bit more Dynamic but he's
taking his time and oh look at my jumps
back
a beautiful little game of tickle oh
hello and now and now maybe just night
oh hello
F4 was too late and E4 is going to fall
and with it it's just too much with it
the house is going coming down I think
um 10 seconds and it doesn't even matter
you could have an r on your clock
against Magnus in this position Magnus
will still perhaps take it yep do you
finish this still a draw Tanya it's okay
later
six glasses of water wow we talked about
one week porn suddenly three dropped off
in one go yeah yeah and that's that's
how you do it right you strangle you
strangle the position they're a boa
constrictor is his style sometimes right
um
this is how Magnus burst onto the scene
just known as an engine yeah
like I said you know I think I think it
is really like the timing is so is so
important I mean this is saying that
Bobby Fischer was famous for timing
things so well and uh we saw that Lev
you know his timing wasn't right they
didn't play G5 he didn't get that move
in on the other hand Magnus just picking
the time to make his brakes and it's a
really hard skill uh to learn that one
when to sort of uh change gear in a game
of chess but Magnus is one of the best
in the world at that the best in the
world and I wasn't thinking about what
you said earlier sorry that it's so hard
to really understand where it went so
wrong for not a back the move that we're
pointing out moving the bishop twice
that one small inaccuracy has cost him
the game Magnus has played flawlessly
out of the opening
and just impeccable timing with picking
up the pawn taking away your opponent's
counter play this is the Magnus Golden
Touch and end games great I feel like
that comment from chat must be sarcasm
or something because Notre back did not
get a good position at the opening in
this particular game um but uh yeah in
fact it I agree with you Tony it's been
Magnus the little things done right in
the beginning he's gonna win with black
in the first game of a four game match
just like he did against Fabiano caruana
yesterday we'll see if Notre back can uh
can Strike Back unlike Fabiano it's
under 10 seconds now so he's right
they're very calm you're right it's it's
not over but it's I think it's uh oh
four seconds for another back
town population
one second on the clock I think and I
don't know the pawn Falls oh very nice
forces the Rooks off
get out of here it's just too it's too
good
Here Comes C4 it's explosive it's just a
little touches right that Rook exchange
it resigns before the dynamite over
Magnus Carlsen shows who's boss with the
black pieces wins a round one in
convincing Mana in that end game and
look at him he's on the screen this one
matters to him a lot he wants to win
this match against not a bag the new
generation the front runner of the new
wave of chess players David
tell us where did it all go wrong for
not a Beck it went wrong quite early the
more I look at it the more I agree with
Danny just giving Magnus a strategic
Advantage was in the end fatal Magnus
zeroed in on those weak white pawns and
eventually captured them I want to
highlight this one moment as just being
really classy not rushing a lot of
players they'd see a pawn and they'd
grab a pawn but the key here is that
Black's Knight is super strong so just
retreating allowing white to go passive
and only bringing the Knight back on his
terms this was the killer blow suddenly
white is overwhelmed this Pawn is
attacked twice if you move a rook to
defend it then this Pawn will drop and
as we saw after F4 simply the house
collapsed Knight takes pawn and blacks
Rooks did a mopping up job just the
final nice moment here was when White's
Rook looked to be getting active a bit
later on Magnus shut the door again he
spotted a tactic a double attack trading
Rooks off and the rest was history
what a game that was Magnus showing how
it's done in the end game do not trade
Queens when you're playing against this
guy the Magnus touch in full display
there which means that now not a back up
to such Rob is playing catch up in the
winners final he has to win a game to
level the score and we will before going
into round two of the winners final we
will go into a short break we'll be
right back but before that here's a
sneak peek at what happened when Dany
and Simon took to the streets of Oslo
with a fun chess challenge
Simon has a distinct Advantage because
his openings are so bad they tend to get
more blunders look at this look at this
slow position which is going on over it
[Music]
three three three okay I'm coming for
you
we go that's the subtlety you didn't see
at the end of the line I'm in the lead
Simon sack your queen queen come on
freaking out here where is the wind bro
there you go there's another one
Precious on I'm playing against two
enemies here Simon Williams and the
clock
[Music]
thank you
Secret Love is Here to provide the
support for players on and off the stage
and for a little tutorial we hired the
services of two well-known Grandmasters
[Music]
hi everyone my name's David this is
Simon the ginger GM and today our
challenge is going to be building a
secret lab chair Simon how are your DIY
skills they're pretty bad they're pretty
bad but um we'll find out as well I
won't be soon David maybe it's something
I can actually beat you at building a
chair yeah I'm pretty nervous I think
Simon's got this in the bag but let's
see how we get on
cheating
[Music]
what's up
hydrocolic piston
come to the Champions chess tour they
say
commentate on the chest they say
you'll have lots of fun looking at
magnus's games having some banter but oh
no all they want is for me to put some
chairs together things we do for chess
there we go
it's actually a very smooth fit
brilliant chairs they go together very
nicely oh no the other one
this is not going well man
so happy I've got to go out to the pub
later
installed okay
okay
[Music]
this perfect chair look at it no problem
but it's at all absolutely oh yes oh my
God
so clearly David is a good chess player
but when it comes to DIY making chairs
he has a lot to learn let's just put it
that way a lot to learn but uh very
comfy chair very nice very easy flexible
secret lab chairs
wow so you won that one you looked
really comfortable in the end dude it's
still struggling there yeah I I mean
they didn't show it like three hours
later I was still struggling fair play
Simon you did well it's nice to be here
you know you can't be chess so I've got
to be putting chairs together you know
but uh but what that didn't show was
just how hot it was it was really hot
there you know and we were boiling and
boiling doing that but uh yeah your DIY
skills Dave you might need a bit of work
on them yeah so wasted childhood I was
studying the elephant Sicilian I wasn't
building chairs when I was a kid but uh
it was worth it they were comfy chess
wow Simon there with his DIY skills a
lot of fun to watch that one and right
now in this winners final the player
who's having a lot of fun is Magnus
Carlson who's taken his lead against not
a backup to Saturn I was world champion
Bobby Fisher who said that he doesn't
believe in Psychology he only believes
in good moves while Magnus was the one
coming out with the good moves it's
chance it's a chance for not a back to
play all the good moves next now we know
what a beast he can be on the board
let's take a look at what he believes
about the inner battle
how much of Chess do you think is a
psychological game the chess is very
tricky thing because you know if you
lost your concentration it's very hard
to get it back and to to get the
initiative in the game so
um
just by improving your psychological
stamina I think you can improve your
overall game
I like to look to my opponents because
you know I like to to see what they are
thinking and what what's
into your mind during the game and if I
see some kind of you know disbelief in
their position or skills then I get you
know I think I get some confidence in
just it's only you and your opponent so
nothing can distract you from game and
that's the most important thing I think
in chess to
to be in the game and to
to to read your opponent's mind during
the game
When I Look to someone like Anish or or
Hikaru I would have a feeling of
something funny might happen just right
now you know and you know they are very
charismatic and you know they are making
this every kind of
a face you know face acts and yeah it's
really really fun to play against them I
think
in order back up to such trouble you'll
have to focus on the players as he said
and try and get into the minds of your
opponent and right now this is their
head to head going into that round two
of the best of four Magnus Carlsen leads
we're just one game they haven't played
each other that many times
got that win it was in the world rapid
Championship when he did go on to win uh
and become the world a rapid Champion
when he was just 17 years old he lost
the first game with the the white pieces
there and when you play such a game when
you lose in the style you can't really
point out where you went wrong how does
that affect you psychologically
it's not nice I mean uh it's it's like
right this guy just outplayed me and
it's like uh okay and you've got to like
maybe change your style so uh you
realize if you go down and do the same
kind of thing again exchange the Queens
play a bit quietly maybe this is not the
way to play uh so I think he's got to
try to just go a bit more sharper and
tactical in the in the games coming up I
agree with you I think sometimes it's
harder to lose a game like that than one
where you just got destroyed because of
preparation at home or just you played
bad a game that a game that you lose in
the boa constrictor style fashion leaves
the Mark it's why Magnus has left a mark
on so many people for so long so luckily
not Rebecca's young he can forget about
it um but uh that's a tough one to lose
yeah we shouldn't forget nodabek he has
many strings to his bow remember what he
did against level and aronian if he can
land a punch like that in the opening I
think he needs to be more direct like uh
you guys were saying keep the Queens on
I just hit in the opening that's uh the
only way I think he's gonna win this
match now what's really important for
another back he starts with the black
pieces and the next one is to stop the
bleeding to make sure that he doesn't
lose control of the match Magnus he will
have the white pieces how much will he
push and we've got the players ready to
go Danny you keep talking about magnus's
style of being this boar constrictor of
just you know clumping down on the
opponent it's very carpovian and a lot
of uh the truss World believes that
Magnus is this perfect mix of Fisher and
karpov would you agree I I think it's a
great I think it's a great comparison
and uh
karpov was was known there were all
kinds of famous phrases that go with
karpov like uh you know by the time he
wins your Pawn you're gonna wish that he
had already won the game because he
strangled you so much and tortured you
you just wanted him to win the isolated
pawn and that was a good example of that
game David you talked about when the one
Pawn fell it the house went with it
right and and I think but Magnus also
has a little bit of that edge you you
gave the great Fisher quote where uh I
don't believe in Psychology I believe in
moves Magnus doesn't believe in
fortresses he believes in winning
um and you know these uh these guys
um those are great comparisons and I
think Magnus being a combo of the two is
uh really accurate despite that ever
since he said that statement about not
believing in fortresses David we've seen
him hold a lot of games with fortresses
he
did a chessable course with him and I
brought up the fortresses topic Magnus
wasn't happy with me he was like stop it
stop it I know I said it once but yeah I
think he's uh he's got mixed feelings on
this now I think it was a great quote
actually I mean I I know I'm saying I
know Magnus has defended many games with
a fortress and he sort of set it in jest
and we hold on to things uh but at the
same time I mean the point is he he
doesn't believe in a lot of things
besides winning and he does that yeah
and before we Deep dive into this I have
for you if you had to give one advice to
why is it now taking on game two would
it be do not trade queens or what would
it be I think do what he's doing keep it
complex uh play something very Dynamic
naughty Beck is an amazing tactician
really one of the strongest players
around when he has the initiative so I
think he you know picking a sicilian
good choice so far so good yeah I like
the choice of a sicilian as well
especially against Magnus but Magnus
knows his opening so well he often
surprises opponents with the rare lines
and this is quite a rare move order but
he's got what he wants he's got this
moroxy bind we talked about it yesterday
actually Abdul satorov was on the white
side of this porn structure yesterday uh
in one of his games against lebonaronian
and
it looks like white does have this kind
of nice Pawn structure where you've
clamped down and black is the one who
has the onus of trying to break out
Magnus just moving instantly so far just
looks super confident I was just about
to highlight that because I think the
other comparison we can already draw
between this game and the second game
abducer Turf isn't taking time that says
like he's lost or anything but he's not
blitzing out the game right and he's not
he doesn't have more time than he
started with like some of these players
will when they're really in prep or he's
not nearly as up on the clock as he was
against aronian and again I think it's
indicative of the fact that Notre brick
of course knows these positions as part
of his opening repertoire but he wasn't
expecting it or there was some little
subtlety that surprised him or he's a
little uncomfortable and it just you can
you can see early on that he's uh making
sure he doesn't misstep against Carlson
yeah he doesn't mess up and he castles
his King Magnus is paused I think most
humans here were just Castle kingside
get on with the game uh if we were white
but is Magnus may be contemplating going
the other way with this King throwing
some pawns towards the black king Simon
Simon no no chance no that's the only
kind of thing that I would do
I I would probably do it but only down
the good night very late on in the night
um because I mean castle and queen side
is kind of just too much here for white
I mean it's maybe playable but I I mean
you think about magnus's style here I I
would very much think he would castle
and then you can decide where you played
do you play White Squad at the side you
play the king side as you play on The
Queen side there do you just keep
pressure in the center and black really
is quite passive and less black can play
D5 uh in this type of structure and you
know it is like that typical kind of
Hippo
um where you've got to play D5 or B5 or
black or you just got to sit there and
wait and one thing that I think naughty
Beck really doesn't want to get into is
waiting against Magnus because in a
waiting game where you have less space
and probably a slightly worse position
Magnus is just gonna Magnus is gonna be
so happy with that you know he's gonna
do what he did in the last game probably
outplay you uh use that space so uh if I
was black I'd really be trying to break
here I'd really want to break somehow
and I'd want to do it quickly so that
maybe that's what Magnus is thinking
about just that break how he can stop it
if he can stop it potentially
I I agree I I also think he might just
be
thinking about whatever subtle bag of
tricks he has maybe he has no
intentional counseling long but a move
like Queen E2 David
right um flexible I'll move okay I'm
maybe not A3 but I'm looking at F3 like
there are other moves you can play that
sort of keep the question in the air
right and queen E2 is one of them so
maybe he's just considering move orders
he might try or he'll just castle and
improve us wrong we'll see but I'm I'm
suddenly surprised by how much Magnus is
thinking here and indeed he does this
Castle so interesting that he took more
than two minutes there and eventually
deciding that he wants to park his King
on the king side very logical and Simon
you highlighted this move D5 if this
works for black great you'll break open
the center everything will disappear but
we do see the evaluation bar react if
this does happen and I'm not 100 sure
why I guess the key question is whether
white just pushes forward and just
clamps down and says okay I'm gonna
attack your knight when you move uh
wherever you go I might just push my
Pawn forward again here I'm just tempted
to take and it looks like white pieces
look at them they're just so centralized
so ready for the action to happen and no
debec says okay no that's too scary and
he sets up like a hedgehog he's going to
plant his Bishop 37 bring his Knight to
D7 and just curl up into a ball yep and
white spoons almost played themselves
you're gonna put the queen on E2 you put
the Rooks on D1 and C1
um you know you can decide how
aggressive you want to be either with A3
or F4 at some point but uh this will be
okay wow Magnus is being more aggressive
right away not no uh leaving nothing to
the imagination here no subtleties in
terms of where he puts the pieces he's
all in with that four yeah nice move
commit to move as you mentioned Danny
because this Pawn might be a bit weaker
than it otherwise would be but maybe
Magnus is thinking of a pawn store maybe
something to do with F5
Simon maybe G4 G5
that's just just kill just kill you know
you can smell Bloods you've gotta you've
got to go for it and rip them apart in
in chess and uh F4 is the most
aggressive move so I'm really happy that
Magnus has gone for this and I think one
of Black's normal responses this is to
play now E5 at some moment but his his
night's not quite backing that up enough
I feel but E5 is a move you can consider
it looks a bit weird here though to be
honest
um so yeah chooses Queen C7 instead so
preventing white from breaking with E5
just covering the square but yeah maybe
Magnus if he's feeling aggressive we'll
go for something on the king side in the
near future can he swing it baby can he
swing it around yet or a white Rook yeah
get the get the Rook to H3 and just
check mate I mean that's how my little
brain works
and that's why we won't see it
um but uh yeah I mean there's loads of
bees you can put the queen behind the
pool and you've just moved put the queen
on F3 can't be a bad idea and you can
think about doing one you know F5 as
you've already pointed out as G4 is is
there's so many ways you can play this
as white maybe that's why it can get a
bit confusing as well are we surprised
to see the evaluation bar so far up on
white side already that's really strange
because we're on move number 10 right
now and again black seems to have made
all the natural moves developing the
pieces creating squares for the queen
side pieces bringing the king to safety
while the valbar does seem to creep up
for white but once again these kind of
positions can be so deceptive and for
black as well you want to hold on for
white to start over pushing on the king
side start extending too much on the
king side and then suddenly it blows
open on the long diagonal and Abdul
satrov's the one who's trying to uh
Checkmate the white skin so it's a bit
of a waiting game in these maroxy bind
setups and all of you called for that
that sometimes the position is deceptive
because I think this is still one of
those there are very rare positions left
where I feel at times the computers can
misevaluate at least in terms of what's
really be practically possible right
where the computers love space and this
position objectively is dominated by
white because of space and and so but
when you look at the concrete lines
um you know there are literally
positions like this where you can study
with a computer and they'll say white is
plus 1.4 but the best move is like King
H1 and because they also can calculate
deep enough to understand that none of
the pawn breaks work there is no F5 or
E5 you know what I'm saying it's so
again computers would beat all of us
here I'm not undermining their their
their power over us but I also agreed
that objectively speaking like the
advantage isn't that big yet but the
potential is there you have to be you
have to be very careful if white does
get one of those breaks but I think when
you are trailing a match and you want a
position that what you want to fight for
a win but not a bad this is a good
position to get to try and get those
kind of uh imbalances here I've played
these structures with black and David
always the big question is where do you
develop that Queen side night because
the last move that Magnus has played
does set up some tricks it does Tanya
and I think you've got this one in mind
the Black Knight might sometimes want to
jump to C6 to trade off for this piece
in the middle because you are cramped
you want to trade pieces but uh show us
Tanya which move now
I wanted to jump in with the Knight
lined up on the C file you want to go in
to that Central Square and look at that
pin coming into play and this would just
lose on the spot which is why we see the
other developing move it might look
passive at first but that Knight is
eventually headed over to C5 he does
play Knight to D7
he plays Knight to D7 it's heading to C5
the other idea you mentioned move
carried the Jeep on love it it's coming
love it what we want to see just going
for the crush not messing around right
next business even though a draw is
probably fine for Magnus he's in the
lead right now he wants to win he wants
to end this match as soon as possible
second game of four and G4 G5 his idea
Simon I think you're right after you
push the pawn the Black Knight Will
Retreat suddenly the white Queen's gonna
come out and that swinger that Rook lift
I love a bit of swinging action with the
Rook you know just bring it around aim
your opponent's king and uh it's just
really like you know we we call it
caveman chess there's there's no
subtlety to it you just put your pieces
near your opponent's king and Chip make
them and uh it's kind of nice to see uh
I was gonna say the world champion but
he's he's not really is he it's nice to
see Magnus play like this world rapid
Champion World rapid Champion play like
this
um
I mean these top players that's why
they're so good they adapt to the needs
of the position we saw grinder Magnus in
the previous game now we're seeing
caveman Magnus just impressive stuff
we're gonna see him continue advancing
those Pawns
yeah and and I mean the downside of that
move there you know uh the G Pawn is
that you do weaken the white king so at
some moment if white over extends we
talked about it's for those pawns that
move forwards they are your bodyguards
I've said this before they do look after
your king and if uh if they go too far
forwards the white king can suddenly get
very exposed especially by the Light
Square Bishop that that uh black has on
the queen side that could shoot down the
diagonal and you know counter attacks
can can often uh be be very nasty so
it's not one-way traffic for sure this
kind of Advance yeah I was just
piggybacking because Tanya Tanya made
that point earlier I think it's even
though it's Advantage for weight and it
is Magnus Carlsen playing weight this is
scary I agree that you know there's a
chance you know this is not a bad weapon
when you want to win as neutral back
right because the explosive nature is
that at some point the position is going
to blow open and probably both Kings
will be under Fire at some point because
of expanding the pawn so
um you know it's a deep dark Forest that
we're talking about Michael's Deep Dark
Forest of complication where you bring
your opponent out and the path out is
narrow enough just for one to get out
and queen to F3 defending that Central
Pawn Mac is making his intentions clear
even though he's got the uh lead in the
match he wants to try the win with the
white pieces in this one it's a math
strategy that can backfire clock
situation right now two minutes ahead on
the clock there I still think that
you're underestimating Black's position
here simply because black has his own
defensive ideas you can move the king
side Rook away get the bishop back and
just really try to keep things together
on the king side and the over extension
with that g Pawn very often it does
backfire you sound like you play these
positions as black yeah I like that it's
okay your bias is creeping in and I
think that's okay can we have a match in
this I'll take white you take black oh
let's do it later at the good night and
that last move that was just played it's
exactly so that if you push the Jeep on
further the Black Knight does have
another square and it's on H5 where you
block up the H line you have that option
yeah I think we might see that happen
Tanya and uh okay first Magnus kicks the
other night what is this why are all the
white pawns on the fourth rank gaining
so much space that's just greedy Five
Pawns now on the fourth rank for white
and yeah Magnus just going for it
normally I see him on the black side he
normally likes to say compact but going
for all the space I just saw karma from
Chad that Magnus setting up his pawns
like he sets up his chairs
I love it um well look he's playing fast
here and the eval is is slowly getting
closer to equal and I think your point
changes is no I I I I didn't disagree I
I think that the position is aggressive
and white has a small Edge but these
positions are I'll put it this way I
think these positions are harder for
white than they are for black right
because white has to be super accurate
to justify what they've done expanding
the Pawns in front of their King black
gets to be like all right come on and
then I'm gonna get my chances and
Visually it's just so appealing for
white right you've got all the space you
got all these nicely placed pieces the
pawns the Avalanche in the center but
actually every break in these kind of
positions has its own drawbacks what do
you think is going on in magnus's mind
right now David yeah I think a bit of
panic Tanya actually I wanted to throw
the question to you because uh you're
the expert here on these types of
positions let's say I just play a move
I'm just going to control my Pawn how
will you break out as black how will you
set up your pieces so very often you
want to just wait with black and you
could have the idea of bringing your
queen side Rook to see it
or you could also move the king side
rook and what you want to do David is
put that dark Squad Bishop on G7 so one
of the Retreats is Bishop to f8 and
Bishop to G7 hello so these are the two
fans what just happened oh my gosh
I was gonna suggest this but I thought
I'd be a Wally if I did
it's like yo I love it
this is the game sorry Tony I wanted to
learn some things but Magnus Magnus says
nice no we're not going to let black do
any of these re-maneuvers the boss what
is
probably because he didn't want he
didn't want notorbeck the chance to
re-maneuver like Tanya over here and I
think he's like you know what
blacks pieces are are a little
dysfunctional right now where they are
like the tempo and the queen like maybe
the bishop on E7 if I put the Knight on
C6 so he's all in on taking advantage of
it right now nothing back says no he
buys the bluff oh wasn't a bluff David
I feel it's a bluff I would have just
taken the bait and asked Magnus to prove
it now I'm looking at the fact that
Magnus can at the very minimum take this
bishop off the board is there something
else okay I'm going to dig deep here
with our silicon friends and Knight D5
wow after he takes D5 computer says
what this is beyond most humans
capabilities but Magnus engines they see
this type of stuff another night lands
and if this Knight is captured then
wow okay I'm just to read one like take
a sample oh take this one attack the
black queen now I'm gonna take this
Knight and apparently there's gonna be
disaster on this diagonal in the near
future white would have been winning
here
unbelievable these players are too good
knight D5 immediately ignored by Abdul
Satora so credit to both of them and now
the queen is dropped back if the Knight
captures the bishop at least as Tanya
mentioned this bishop is very strong
still
anything could still happen beautiful
sacrifices Knight D5 with the idea of
giving up the other night that is
incredible and the speed with which
Abdul satra refused to take that also
shows his understanding of these
positions
risk management from
besides that Magnus realizing that
planting the knight in was strong cost
him a couple of minutes calculating it
but uh yeah risk management from empty
tutorial of realizing no I don't want to
get involved no calculation just feel
that you reject
three this is the big dog Forest by the
way I'm starting to like you know I'm
maybe looking at evaluation bar too much
but I'm also starting to think I'm yeah
the position of the black's actually not
that bad is it I mean
look I've tried a sack a piece you
didn't want it you know I gave it a good
shot what do I do next do I do I throw
the other night in like you know well
actually no no I say it you're not wrong
and again like those pawns have advanced
sometimes you get in a position where
the best move is to move upon backwards
exactly and they you can't move those
Pawn backwards now and uh you know
there's a lot of holes it does get very
holy and I'm I'm not sure how you can
attack right anymore I mean I don't know
I mean it's it's the this this queen d8
was a real quality move because I think
the whole of magnus's play was built
around Knight D5 and sacrificing the
piece I think if Magnus had maybe I
don't I don't maybe he saw he didn't see
queen d8 or take it that serious nicely
obviously he saw it but maybe he didn't
expect it I don't think he would have
gone B4 and I don't think he would have
gone G5 I think it's I think it's very
you know he's extending himself a lot it
shows the depth of understanding too for
an outer back that you can part ways
with the dark Square Bishop even though
you play G6 right that's that's a scary
thing to do when you've got those holes
on the king side H6 and G7 and F6 all
those all those dark square holes so he
understands that there's no real way for
white to take advantage of that and and
that's kind of a deep understanding
to do that with most people I think
would be really afraid yeah Magnus it
feels like like you say Simon who's
trying to be too clever maybe and
actually trading off one set of minor
pieces just makes Black's position look
so much more attractive visually blacks
the fact that he's slightly cramped
doesn't uh doesn't well it's not an
issue now simply I have a question for
the expert in the position Tanya I'm
gonna answer it before you ask when does
black go for E5 oh that was your
question I thought that was another one
I think when white can't jump on to F5
and then tactically that can be a very
risky situation to allow white to get
that night into the camp so E5 Knight F5
would be very scary
uh I don't know if tactically it works
and I think I see Dave albar it seems to
work the night is hanging but the last
move but not it back there's another
sneaky idea it has in these positions
it's all about rerouting your pieces and
maneuvering around with black so the
queen can fall back to its original
place and actually go all the way to A8
line up on that battery remember we've
been talking about this Pawn extension
by Magnus G4 G5 you want to make the
most of that diagonal and that's an idea
always to keep in mind I love it and
that's that's a super strong idea and a
very typical hedgehogy and is that a
word hedgehogy and ice now to relocate
the queen to the battery there and at
the end of that line if you can go back
the reason I was asking E5 is because
obviously the eval was disagreeing with
me but I thought after E5 Knight F5
takes takes H5 I thought maybe there was
Bishop takes E4 so I was asking
concretely because I was like at some
point and this doesn't look great but
also look at the white king so you know
what I mean at some point white has to
be careful because black might shoot
this out and then all of a sudden it
falls apart I don't know why white is so
much better here because I'm like this
is looking kind of scary but what's oh
taking a five okay there you go that's
the idea yeah as long as white can keep
the lines close towards his case for the
black king maybe but like you say Danny
it's really concrete you have to be very
careful of this stuff yeah I think I'm
doing sort of calculating exactly this
because yeah if it works for black
you're doing great but hopefully not
hopefully he goes for Tanya's idea
because Queen d8 I think is much better
yeah it's quite nice as well Queen d8
isn't it it's a nice move to make yeah
it's kind of a pretty way too we've done
it once before in the game by the way
there you go it's good that we got our
expert here
I got your back yeah I was wondering if
white can put the Knight on G3
um because I don't like this E5 move
this E5 move I want to play F5
Simon verses
a hedgehog it's on who's sponsoring the
match we're gonna play a thematic
please wait and tell him to play's black
yeah it kind of makes sense pretty well
because this Knight on H5 is just
annoying me you know and I want to get
rid of this Knight on H5 I love to open
up the the H file and I just want to
give my queen some uh lift as well so
yeah
so I guess maybe Queen A8 now is
critical though because that pawn is now
weak in the center so possibly I don't
know yeah I think it's coming that will
be consistent at least and uh yeah I
Want To Praise both of you that's why
knowing the ideas in openings even if
not just the move orders is so important
for everyone at home uh clearly Tanya
has done the hard work she's done her
hard yards and it shows off kind of uh
yeah when you find these ideas and no
deck the one thing I'll say for him is
that the 17th piece is going to play a
huge Factor now three and a half minutes
against seven and a half so despite the
fact we're liking the way this game is
going it feels like momentum black uh
it's still very tense and clock in these
types of positions gonna play a huge
role I got him into a lot of trouble in
round one as well and now down by more
than four minutes on the clock in a
position that's just starting to heat up
right now all the pieces on the board
white has still got this King side
tension black needs to Target those
overextended bonds they're going to be a
lot of critical decisions to be made on
seconds not a back needs to take
decisions quickly
yeah he needs to take them now I don't
understand why you play Queen
oh that's not a good thing I thought I
stopped that move I literally made some
decent predictions today but I was just
asking for science I wasn't suggesting I
was asking for Science and now he goes
for it in my backfire for Notre back I I
actually thought the night Retreat just
stopped this move because of F5 yeah you
were right I don't just don't think it
you know this what I mean I know Black's
trying to open up the king side but
surely White's in a better position to
deal with that why didn't we go with
Queen A8 like what was he I feel like
he's worried about Knight G3 you know
and The Rook comes to H2 maybe maybe
even after winning the E4 Pawn maybe
it's interesting uh I feel like he he
either saw a ghost which sometimes can
happen not just because you're playing a
world champion by the end of those lines
and what we mean by seeing a ghost is
you see something that's not there right
and it's an Affliction that all chess
players should avoid when you're nervous
and and I feel like Notre Beck saw a
ghost there because E5 is a panic mode
exactly I think it is that 17th speed
stalking right now sometimes you have an
idea you don't have enough time to
really think about it and then you just
go full panic mode and make it anyway
and the fact that Magnus paid the most
obvious response to E5 and not a bet
goes into a big think again is bad news
yeah very bad news yeah yeah it feels
like he's lost the threat just with two
moves here uh after store have gone from
a very pleasant position to suddenly
facing some serious threats and it feels
like he's playing on the wrong side of
the board like Simon says white pieces
are amassed on the king side they're
ready for the action there Magnus was
the one trying to create and have two
tutorials kind of giving him a helping
hand and okay Rook F7 looks like he's
contorting now to get his pieces over to
protect the black king the question is
what does Magnus do next is it your move
Simon just get rid of that Black Knight
on H5 uh the kind of plug that's
stemming the flow on the king side right
now be a bit worried about Knight F4
that's that's the only reason I might
not rush into moving the Knight there
but maybe it's still playable maybe I
don't have to worry about uh this this
move but I'm just thinking like it's
kind of typical to sack a pawn and love
it something like this you've got a
natural feel for these positions bro
well when I'm hacking give me give me
some hacking chances and uh I'm off I'm
off for the fairies no but it's a great
idea and now the G5 hangs the E5 square
has opened up for the Black Knight yeah
this this seems like it could be
stopping Knight over there but uh but
yeah it's you know magnus's play is
still not that natural Maybe
time should you build up more Rook F3 or
I'm not sure really I'm not sure it's
not easy for either side you can maybe
go after the Deep one as well but
Black's Queen will move Alex Queen has
targets as well on this side of the
board he I think he has gone off to the
depot yeah
switching to that one I'm waiting for
Magnus as well to push his port and
maybe switch the Bishops
that's full board awareness homes get
some yeah okay it might be coming soon
everybody
that could be quite uh is even more
accurate I think right now because you
have the protection of the of the A2
Pawn for the B3 Square
it's a really fascinating game this one
though isn't it I mean it's uh this you
know I
both sides it's so hot it's so so uh
rich with possibilities
um so many different ways to play and
it's
all tension on the board I mean look at
what's happening
with that Bond
the FNG bonds and then there's also
action on the center and then the over
extension on the queen side there's a
lot going on in the position and he does
get the bishop here this also does give
the possibility for the C Pawn to
advance one step ahead at the right
moment to create that counter player off
along the a to G8 diagonal yep
C5 and then C4
sorry I gotta say it gets explosive
right now
such a fascinating game we saw Greg
shahadi and Chad earlier saying this is
a fascinating game I agree this is a
fascinating game where I'm learning a
ton and it's funny when you see
positions that still so many pieces on
the board yet clearly there's just so
much subtlety and and this is It's Gonna
it's gonna blow up here in just a minute
yeah the eval bar is deceptive if there
we go it does drop because this position
could still go either way very very
quickly yep it's starting to open up now
Magnus taken a pawn there and moving his
Bishop in I mean uh but it's you know
it's scary of a black no it feels loose
for both somehow but stop dark Square
Bishop really powerful it is it's great
piece isn't it that one so you kind of
don't want to take that rook in some
respects I was gonna say I wonder if
there's a I'd love a capture on F5 takes
f8 in a capture on e4 right a couple of
tempos yeah I you know I would not be
surprised from these two guys as well I
mean oh my gosh they're playing great
chess and these are the moments that you
wish you had those extra seconds on the
clock yeah because it's such a critical
moment you want to think about giving up
your look for this really strong Bishop
but do you do it do you take this
critical uh decision with just a minute
and a half on the clock
and uh yeah time management it's such a
crucial part of these formats and maybe
we can get the engine suggestions up
right now does fdrop have to move his
Rook away uh what does the computer
think because to me it looks like the
stakes are high and whoa
what a move but if it's good or bad
it's a move all right I mean look at
this the engine says you have to take it
with the queen or Bishop you cannot run
away otherwise if the advantage passes
to black but he wants to open the G file
he's going for the white King right he
can take this with check and take the
Rook I mean yeah you know you know okay
unless the Knight really doesn't want to
retreat does it I mean it's a crazy
move I would never consider yeah I mean
it
beautiful because it's crazy yeah yeah
yeah I love seeing you know moves I
never predict
um but I'm trying to work it out I mean
it doesn't it just loses a pawn
click it with check and then the
exchange I mean just take it off and see
what happens the thing is now you have
some threats against your king now
suddenly this Pawn on e4 is attacked one
I would say queen H4 I would just go
back I'm such a genius
it comes to G4 now
actually and this is like I'm wearing
wow okay he's gone for it by the way
he's in this exact position so wow
taking the rock I don't know I mean this
is an amazing idea from Nordy back but
it looks I mean now I'm kind of like
well I love the attack Black's now got
the attack so I'm like hang on a minute
I I wouldn't
again this is where you dig the eval bar
and throw it out of the window yeah it's
still one of those positions Anything
Can Happen David is highlighting the big
threat in the position it's a basic one
but it's a huge one that Magnus has to
take care of also notice that Center
Pawn if that falls apart and Black's
Bishop becomes active that is bad news
for white imagine a battery down that
diagonal and not a back Fair how do you
think he's evaluating this position and
and you start playing on intuition now
with a minute on the clock how do you
handle this complicated mess I think the
first time you first thing you do is do
exactly what he's doing setting an
example for all young viewers he's
working so hard on magnus's time you
have to be ready to play so many times
you see people just not focused like
pretending they're not under pressure
and only have a little bit I love how it
just zoned in he is and I love that we
need an update and I love you Windows
um but um Knight G3 has been yeah good
good time for an update you know it's
time for an update most exciting
position we've maybe had all day and
windows comes along so long yeah I mean
incredible though yeah it's a
I mean you know who naughty bet reminds
me of I mean we've talked about Magnus
and how he reminds people of carpool
from Bobby Fischer but naughty bet
reminds me of Gary Kasparov just because
he's always getting this energy and
Kasparov was one of the most energetic
players out there always finding very
interesting ways to just energize his
pieces and uh you know playing actually
similar positions to this similar
openings to this but a sacrifice like
this would be I don't know I it was
either kaspar of sound or Tau unsound
but I'll tell you in a minute I don't
know because you know Tao would do lots
of sacrifices that didn't work and we
will find out see won't we see whether
it works or not this is the mark of
Genius G5 yeah in Practical terms this
would have just stumped most opponents
this would have just confused them and
Magnus taking a time to uh just
well his senses it still might pay off I
mean like I agree with what Tonya said
the eval bar can be thrown out the
window not because an engine would
objectively maybe win but this is a
blunderable this is the definition of a
blunderable position Magnus is going to
get under two minutes right now so both
players uh you know under the two minute
warning if you will and there's so many
tactics here right I mean there's Knight
G4 coming in all these positions the E4
opponent is weak I'm
I will not be surprised if uh if Magnus
defends it but a single move could
strike that evil bar down a really nice
feature chat that this is what not about
did yesterday to win in a lost position
and this was game three against Levon
where he created this complete mess
sacrifice that night Knight G4 what a
move that was David and we're seeing
similar sort of signs and motives of
that I love how nordeback has just given
up material and he's just playing for
compensation there's no immediate
Checkmate on the board there's no way to
win the material back on the board but
he just keeps the tension yeah he keeps
the tension and look the eval bar
already reacting slightly Magnus he's
trying to trade off pieces he's trying
to get his uh maybe get some counter
play White Rock on d1's opened up so I'm
just sort of needs to strike now or in
the next couple of moves well and I I
love that Magnus played Bishop E2 and I
love the comment from Greg shahadi in
feature chat again it's not on the
screen but I'm I got it right here in
front of me and he made a great point
which is magnus's time Advantage was
super useful there he just burnt about
90 seconds and that shows you why you
earned that Advantage earlier in the
game so that in big moments like this
did not have enough time to play The
Right Move yeah
yeah I mean they can't but can't white
just eliminate this one this is this is
why I thought this was maybe not the
correct way because you now white can go
Rook takes Knight I'll be taking that
night you know without
without any thought now I mean uh trying
to just stabilize it change yeah
well Magnus now touching the one minute
Mark will he get rid of this night and
he does a great call there by side and
uh picks up the pawn the d-pawn is weak
as well and not a bag with just 25
seconds on the clock down two pawns now
in the position but he does pick up a
key Central Pawn I didn't see Knight
takes even
the move why they're so good they see
one move deeper Magnus had foreseen that
he's dropping the E Pawn but he just
gets his King out of Dodge the white
king now is actually just running away
and okay nice pin there from madridorah
don't pick up that Black Knight The
White Knight is needed to block the G
file there's Checkmate threats there
it's crazy crazy position and I really
have played by both sides brilliant I
mean they're both under a minute now and
it's only a one Pawn advantage and
Magnus giving the pawn back now I think
it's a great idea if he gets to the end
game he's he's the only player who can
win and we know he loves the end game
and if Knight takes well then now D6
Falls I think you could probably take
both ways but Rook take seems to be the
not about just avoiding any Queen trades
here he has to go for magnus's King yeah
but Rook takes D6 is Rook f8s isn't it I
mean it's it's such a wild position this
that again the evaluation bar I think is
misleading and they're both so short of
time I wonder if Queen takes is better
so that if then I move you can play
Queen D4 and get the Queens off the
board nice Danny I think that might be
the key the White Queen and King were
both lined up on the FL you needed to
move one of them there would have been
too many tactics as Simon pointed out
look now the evaluation bar is pretty
easy we removed though he just walked
through the king to the center of the
board anyone's getting this I like that
anymore because now he'll take the
Queens off the board even if he doesn't
win the D6 Pawn I think he might have
tried to play Queen D4 just using the
Practical Edge but what is that a win
Queen D6 yeah four seconds and look at
he reacts he knows he's made a mistake
he goes back first mistake of the game
in terms of uh practical play there he's
just lost a pawn with gain of tempo but
the queen guards G1 now so Knight F5 is
on the agenda oh he's just swapping off
uh that was a shame one second and did
he get flat oh under one second when he
made that move but it's not gonna help
him here two pawns down and he's had to
retreat his Knight attack has gone this
is a mathematics equation now
look at the Queen's board geometry she
doesn't guard G1 anymore but she guards
G5 so there's no more checks that follow
although King F1 would have allowed
Queen H3 so Magnus is very careful and
this queen
he didn't he lost on time yeah he's
losing he's right here
loses on the clock
what a game what a win an absolute wild
right there and you can see not the back
disappointed but he really did give it
his all
he was so close created his chances we
got a glimpse of his genius with the
sacrifice that he made but when you're
playing against Magnus Carlsen sometimes
even genius is not enough look how bad
he wants it he's devastated Magnus
shaking his head because he knows he
might have just gotten away with one
against someone who he might not get
away with too many more in their future
their future matchups
relieved with the outcome of that he
takes the big lead David a wild ride a
roller coaster of a game yeah yeah a
roller coaster and praise to both
players for playing really creative just
imaginative chess there and it all came
down to one move in the end abdusitorov
had worked his magic found nothing out
of nothing and it was here where Magnus
I think just surprised nodded back by
playing King to E1 this was actually a
move of Genius in the end if he had
taken this Pawn with his Rook Knight to
E4 would have actually been winning for
black we would have seen a full 360 due
to the fact that there's a pin you
cannot move the Knight there would be a
Checkmate on G1 and Rook f8 would be a
deadly threat so Magnus moving the king
Shifting the king confused Abdul satorov
here and rather than playing a move such
as D5 getting the pawn out of Dodge or
maybe just pinning the white Bishop
after it's a tour of London he played
Queen to E7 forgetting that this Pawn
could be captured and now he had to move
his Queen away he'd lost time lost a
pawn and Magnus took the win
wow great breakdown David I'm sorry
Tanya go ahead
try to move test I'm still thinking
about all
and the Knight D5 Moon mag
and upon an absolute craziness on the
board let's take a look at the score
line right now not a back up this outro
with a two-point deficit can he do what
seems to be an impossible task make a
comeback against Magnus Carlsen here he
needs to win game three on demand to
start with Magnus needs just to draw in
this upcoming big round and that's where
we're headed right after this break
don't go anywhere
[Music]
air things Masters chessable Masters
chess kit cup and now aim chess rapid
they all lead to one thing the Champions
chess tour finale the finale will be
played between December 9th and 16th in
Toronto Canada
top eight players from the season will
compete to be crowned the 2023 champion
three spots are already taken and the
remaining five will be decided in the
upcoming tour events so follow us to see
who will join Magnus Carlsen in Canada
in December
it's the race to Toronto and it's
heating up as we are in the fourth stop
of the Champions chastor the aim chess
rapid and this is the winners final
between not to back up the statue of and
Magnus Carlton it's going to be a fun
ride over to Toronto and we've also been
seeing a lot of fun happening in Oslo
and uh Danny you and Simon took to the
streets to hustle it out we sure did who
won uh well Simon do you want to spoil
who won or should we let them watch it I
think we I think we should see the video
I can hear everyone yelling don't spoil
it of course they're not going to spoil
it but um we'll just say here's a
spoiler it was a lot of fun and uh
you're gonna want to watch this
Grand Master Simon Williams Ginger GM
and I are about to play a whole bunch of
chess players and in 40 minutes we're
going to see who can rack up the most
wins non-stop speed Chess Championship
style the clock is running and we're
also secretly keeping track of who is
the best trash talk but we already know
who wins that
um and so we'll we'll see if he can keep
up I'll be gentle let's go clock Stars
Simon has a distinct Advantage because
his openings are so bad they tend to get
more blunders look at this slow position
[Music]
okay we knew when he showed up in his
tank top he meant business so come on
Fight Man fight man there we go that's
the subtlety you didn't see at the end
of the line I'm in the lead Simon stack
your queen
come on I'm freaking out here where's
the wind bro
there you go there's another one
Precious on I'm playing against two
enemies here Simon Williams and the
clock the Dutch is an opening he plays
which should tell you how good it is
yeah I took his course
there you go bad idea first mistake can
I give you a little bit of rules for
trash talking yeah you can trash talk if
you're doing okay on the board yeah it's
your turn terrible on the board and
don't really have the right to track at
all
this is too close to cool yeah
Jesus Christ
David this is not what we talked about
man we're done you're doing well
man you're doing well
really wait he wants to draw oh I
actually missed my queen
oh no not the grind man not their grinds
the David grinds this is not fun
[Laughter]
[Music]
oh here we go he's back oh my gosh I'm
falling apart here I'm messing this game
up you're messing up yeah come on man
come on it's not going good and you've
got David to come as well just to put a
little bit of pressure on just Danny
we're even how's your position looking
down your car seat as I open my big
mouth
[Music]
your check
come on come on on that port
I got a little wild all right but I
survived
all right what's the score how much time
I think it's even man no no it's not
even I think it is what's the score no
no I'm not sleeping I've been winning a
couple of games here man yeah yeah yeah
look at that
can I just get a picture of that again
one more time how is that possible
wow what is this what is this I have no
idea
to endured me I tend to perform better
on camera that's a little known fact
what's happening I've heard of London if
I beat David house
oh my gosh it was over and I buttered my
brother
no no
[Music]
I feel like the score got away from me
how do you beat David Howell and lose
anyway
[Music]
it all comes down to Tanya suchdev
what's the king doing over there
[Music]
I'm a little
perplexed yeah so am I a little
perplexed and a little
okay
um
okay I don't know about that one
I have my doubts I'm actually not sure
what happens next here no that's my
problem
here we go here we go here we go hold on
I've got more I've got more comments a
little bit scary everything is
working how did you get this going I
don't know but I'm very excited about it
this is this is nasty man
Everything feels good again
barely
[Applause]
that was awesome to watch
uh sigh how are you feeling right now
yeah
okay
no honestly I didn't I I didn't deserve
to win that but somehow somehow
Armageddon was kind to me I'll take it
I'll take it and you you've been kind to
me in a lot of our Rivals matches and I
appreciate it yeah thanks Danny
very Modesto Danny you know I think it
was a setup it was definitely a salad I
did beat David and again first of all
but did you play tan yeah I didn't yeah
hang on a bit so you didn't play 10 yeah
I know we're just picking on David over
there I mean also another thing I've
just got to say
my opponents weren't resigning they were
playing till the beer and I'm sure that
you were giving out Diamond memberships
have a diamond membership if you if you
resign as soon as you sit down and lose
a piece I'm sure well not that I'm a
sore loser at all at all we need to get
to the bottom of that but Daddy you're a
very competitive I I uh why not be right
I mean you're in the moment the whole
point is to win right so you play the
game to win and we had a lot of good we
had a lot of fun and I am I am
competitive I guess
and it's getting pretty competitive here
a twin situation uh while this one went
into an Armageddon we're not so sure
we'll get an Armageddon and the Winner's
final as not the back up to such robe
has to win on demand this next game he
is trailing by two points and take a
look at their aim chest stats there
opening accuracy 100 it's so close their
stats David here we see their end game
accuracy right next to each other but
the match so far hasn't been that close
yeah it feels like Magnus has always
been in control the first game was just
a master class in strategy there in the
grind the end games the second game
despite the fact that I've just drove
was blowing blowing us away and just
surprising us on every time with these
amazing moves he was never uh he never
held an advantage Magnus felt like the
one who could pull the brakes at the
right time and yeah that is reflected
now in the scoreline usually we talk
about whether we'll have an Armageddon
or not but right now the question is
whether we'll have the fourth game or
not because this man on your screen has
been dominating today winning two
back-to-back games against not the back
up to such trouble but not the back has
to win with white he never got the
chance in that game one he starts with
the Queen spawn opening are we expecting
a repeat by Magnus and he says no it's
not happening
yeah you
again we didn't get to comment too much
on just how uh devastated Notre back
looked after that loss right we moved
quickly to Magnus but I wanted to
highlight not wasn't to rub it in but to
just highlight how much he really cared
you see the passion in that kid's face
and how how upset he was about that it
just makes me excited for all the future
matchups to come but the reason he's so
upset is he knows how difficult this
task is right when you lose the first
game with white
now
now you're coming back to white but
you're already down two games to Nils so
this is um this is a very very uphill
battle
it's an uphill battle he starts with the
Catalan opening Abdul sotorov remember
this is one of Magnus Carlson's
favorites ever since the 2021 world
championship match and Magnus he's
tanked now for 30 seconds of course he
studied the position probably hundreds
of hours but uh he's just choosing which
weapon is going to get him that desired
draw and get him through to the Grand
Final okay he chooses to play C5 the
most uh kind of direct move to just try
and destroy the center trade off as many
pawns as possible and it looks like
Magnus certainly is going for a solid
reply here he trades off on D4
White Castles okay what do we think of
this opening Choice oh I'm still
thinking about them
just move on somehow
I won but they all seem to they all
favor you which is big surprise go ahead
oh dear no it was close it was close and
Tanya beat me as well in a good game so
and I did offer Tanya a draw not that
I'm bitter about that but yeah sorry
we're looking at it okay
it was a lot of fun it was a lot it was
good fun I think we can have a rematch I
think so yeah I think we've got to get
down the good night and do it again run
it again I think Danny just wants to run
away with that Victory he's not he's not
looking like he's up for a rematch
I don't get many victories but that's
okay that's my design so um I'm all in
I mean back to the the real match I
guess yeah and yeah I I was going to say
I think it's quite a good choice this
opening against Magnus I mean I've seen
Magnus uh losing the champions tour to
do both actually in this line a couple
of times I think and uh him Magnus
playing C5 seems like a wise choice just
to clarify the center as quickly as
possible even if he's going to be
slightly worse he's going to be in less
danger in those lines than some of them
more sharper stuff so I think he's just
realizes I need to draw
I'm gonna play lines that gravitate
towards that yeah and uh these players
of course at the top level need to know
all sorts of openings this one it
started as the Catalan is going to
transpose into the tarash most likely uh
where black might even have an isolated
Queen spawn but Magnus knows those lines
he actually has studied them like you
say Simon there with dubov okay a
capture of Pawns and this is the Moment
of Truth Magnus doesn't go for the iqp
he takes with his Knight
um there's also transpositions there to
reverse grunfels where the players would
be trying to work out move orders and
okay he steps back with this Knight
abduce a tour of his banking on the fact
that although it's symmetrical he has
this Catalan Bishop White's light Square
Bishop on G2 peers down this long
diagonal exerts some pressure there
blacks pieces meanwhile on the queen
side take a while to get out sometimes
yeah so uh minimal uh kind of uh yeah
static Advantage here for white you
pointed out these players obviously no
all the openings they need you to be
playing chess at the top level or they
wouldn't be here but now another brick
has to think about all the openings he
knows that avoid simplification right A
lot of times when you come into a match
you know you're testing the water seeing
what your opponent has prepared but
worst case scenario you Peter out to a
draw not an option here so he has to
make sure he keeps the most dynamic uh
lines on the board and I love your point
the bishop on G2 right that's the
advantage white has here also note the
bishop on C8 if that Knight on on D5 has
to move or can't move because the B7
Pawn might be tender so uh yeah that's
that's one advantage but it is something
that white can hang his hat on for now
and the move you kind of want to play
here is the move Knight to C3 just to
get rid of this blockader and the key
question here is whether damaging your
Pawn structure is worth it here white
would have isolated pawns on C3 and A2
and I think nodabek has scarred by the
first game having weak pawns on those
two squares uh as well and therefore he
doesn't go for this direct approach he
first Parks his Bishop on D2 so that
when he does try to remove this blockade
on D5 he can capture back on C3 with a
bishop nice uh small but important
detail that assignment yeah I think this
is the kind of position naughty Beck
would I love to have had in the first
game right he'd love to have had this
position where you you shouldn't really
lose the white ever if they call it a
two result game uh because you know
you're the one with the advantage of the
bishop it's symmetrical Pawn structure
but your winning chances how high are
they and um you know that I guess you're
gonna win I don't know like 60 of the
time with this kind of position but
that's a complete guess in this in this
game as uh you know you've all pointed
out it's a must-win scenario uh for
Naughty Beck so Magnus just has to do
something with those Bishops I'm
wondering if he can move his Bishop to
C6 immediately here
um it's the kind of thing you'd like to
play uh the bishop on C8 try to get that
one and exchange it off I mean if you
can get rid of those Bishops you're
absolutely fine so uh that would be
something worth thinking about but okay
a normal developing move instead
now I like that idea Simon I think that
would have been my choice bringing
Black's light squared Bishop out often
if you leave it too long that Bishop
never gets out so that might have been
one opportunity but magnus's move looks
very healthy very natural as well and
I'm used to seeing Magnus on the white
side of this uh type of position where
there's minimal risk where he can apply
a little bit of pressure and uh yeah
test his opponent here and there let's
see whether noddybeck can use the Magnus
approach against the master himself here
to take the win and prolong the match
Mission Impossible it's called on the
twitch chat there but I think he's got
some chances I like the way this opening
is panned out still enough tension
enough pieces left on the board to pose
problems later
yeah agreed all pieces left on the board
at the moment so it's a it's um yeah I
mean I'm just wondering what magnus's
plan is do is light Square Bishop maybe
he can move the pawn in the center of
the board to to give it a bit Freedom
that way at some point
um but yeah a little bit better for
white Danny this position
yeah
um but I'm sitting here trying to think
of creative ways to keep the edge 93 is
an interesting one in in slightly
unorthodox development you want to go to
C4 maybe even B5 in some positions I
feel like these positions often come
down to the question of
I was just gonna say can black get the
bishop developed without any tactics on
the D5 Knight and he just answered it I
was actually considering E5 the moment
when I played Bishop D2 because that's
the other Square the bishop can go to is
E6 not just C6 right but it only works
because that Knight isn't hanging and I
don't know if E5 was possible back when
the bishop was first played there but I
really like this idea by Magnus you know
he's got his Bishop out and blacks
pieces look really healthy now uh I
guess the one idea for nordebec is to
plant a knight either on the C4 square
or maybe even the C5 Square to try and
gain the bishop pair a long-term uh
Advantage there but if you bring your
knight into C4 firstly is this really
such a big threat maybe not uh for
example if black just plays a very kind
of slow logical move maybe actually
taking with the a pawn is nice here for
black you open up your Rook this white
knight is utterly dominated now by the
black pawns can never jump anywhere it's
just misplaced and looks solid looks
like Magnus has got everything he wants
if he goes for the other option uh NoDa
back here then again the question is is
it such a big deal he has played this
move is it such a big still that you
might gain the bishop pair Magnus says
no he trades off and uh how is he gonna
solve the tension here some pressure
gets the Black Knight still maybe he'll
just drop his Knight back maybe he'll
bring his Queen up to gain some time
first connect his Rooks feel solid for
black but at least some imbalance now
with the bishop here for white
Magnus taking that critical decision of
giving up the bishop bear really quickly
what do you make of this strategy by
nordeback he comes into this game three
he has to win it to just take it to game
four and then he chooses the opening
that is magnus's specialty in the world
championship against janapanushi we saw
Magnus win the match with the Catalan uh
it's something that surprised me
how do you make sense of that
I mean it's again a mark of Champions we
saw it with Magnus yesterday he entered
the Lion's Den he played an open
Sicilian position against Fabi and it
paid off sometimes you have to fight the
opponents where they're strongest
sometimes it's the only way you can't
always duck and dive and Dodge and Dodge
their preparation dip dime duck and
Dodge the five D's of dodgeball died
I'm already confused sometimes you can't
Dodge the opponent's preparation is what
I'm trying to say yeah I think you know
a big difference between these two
players though I mean they're they're
both obviously got all their strengths
but is the experience and the fact that
magnus's opening range is so much more
than naughty Beck's opening range right
I mean naughty Beck is younger uh he
obviously specializes in in if we
surprised aronium with a new opening but
his range of openings that he's
comfortable in is not as big as Magnus
Magnus can play anything and uh in a
situation like this where you have to
win and we see naughty Beck now taking
some big risks but he has to
um you want to have a wide range of
openings to draw upon in certain
situations but yeah this is a big uh
this is a big change in positions here
isn't it so do we like what White's done
here whether we like it or not I think
he had to do it I think he had to try
something and uh this is the current
position let's do a quick action replay
uh it was here that Magnus made quite a
committal decision I was surprised I
thought just Retreat the to this Square
back up the night with your other Knight
but Magnus said no I'm going to plant it
on B6 and he allowed a capture on C6 and
the reason Simon I guess you're saying
this is so risky is because white has
parted with his beautiful Catalan Bishop
there are holes on light squares now
around the white king you have to be a
bit careful here especially with
opposite color Bishops favoring the side
who can whip up an attack but the whole
idea is to capture on E5 and Magnus in
move to be honest I quite like it it
takes a while for black to ever kind of
create a Checkmate threat so you can
plant a one H3 but white just
Dodges a Pawn on F3 wall later guard the
light squares at uh maybe magnus's ideas
to take this Pawn
at least now there's a nice safe Square
for white Bishop on C3 black has
weaknesses here even in an end game
maybe some small chances what do we
think but it's called Bishops too right
so and here he goes he does take the a
pawn because
white better get something on the dark
squares in forms of an attack right
Bishop to C3 a rook to G5 and you know
Muse your imagination in terms of what
could happen over there on G7 but
outside of turning the obstacle Bishops
into a strength which is where you
really assault and attack on the color
complex your opponent lacks this is
getting closer to a draw yeah place it
to a drawer we should also point out
that white couldn't here have trapped
this black Bishop on A2 normally this
happens if you go Behind Enemy Lines a
famous example in the game spaski fisher
from 1972 where he took a poison Pawn
called his Bishop trapped but here maybe
that's even better actually firstly
Queen D6 I've spotted now with the
double attack but at the very minimum
black could play Bishop takes pawn and
get his Bishop because the White Queen
is overworked uh suddenly this bishop
would fall and Magnus would be safe so
you couldn't trap this bishop and uh
we're gonna see maybe an end game if the
Queens come off that's got to be bad
news for norderberg if this goes into an
opposite color Bishop end game although
there are still some Dynamics against
that g-pawn that you highlighted white
can combine the rook and Bishop to put
some attack I'm not expecting him to
trade Rooks now on the board we see
Queens have been traded off the board
Magnus offers a rook trade yeah he's got
to avoid that interesting we had a
comment from feature chat a moment ago
that said we have had no draws today
which was a great comment although I
think we might get our first draw right
now right so instead of commentators
curves a bit of a Chatters curse here
but only because it suits Magnus it gets
him to match yep
I think he's got so many different gears
he's been going in like uh quite high
gear trying to win these games Magnus
but now he's kind of taking it back he's
saying okay I don't need to push I'm
just going to try and neutralize you and
I've had it myself often in must win
situations these top guys they don't
even give you a chance they can shut the
door when they want to yeah and they
don't even mind being a little bit worse
dude that's the thing that impresses me
you know I I hate being a little bit
worse in a position where I have no
winning chances I just really don't
enjoy those situations but you know
Magnus can do that he can be a little
bit where he did it in the world
championships you know he did it in many
of the games he's he knows he's a little
bit worse but the the danger of him
losing was so low it didn't worry him at
all and uh here equal material opposite
color Bishops white has a better Rook
yes white has maybe a better Bishop but
is it enough to win
the one danger obviously we should
highlight the back rank as long as it
exists right right there can be a back
ring check made if Magnus loses his mind
and uh grabs up on but I expect
something even like H5 or H6 depending
on how he wants to use the uh Harry over
there use the boy wizard
um
but uh yeah I really like F3 by
notorbeck whether he plays king of two
or eventually when E4 comes because not
not just because it's a majority David
four on three but that pawn on e4 holds
the D5 Square which is actually kind of
critical for Black's coordination either
the bishop or the Knight would love to
use it so king of two and E4 again it's
it's hard to expect a victory in Ops
Code Bishop endings but keeping pieces
on the board is the first thing you want
it to be not just the dynamic of the Ops
Code Bishops that's the first pro tip
and the second Pro tip is you want to
keep your opponent's pieces from using
Central squares that's usually where the
best blockades are started and here
Magnus is not going to let that Knight
be sidelined I like it puts it on D5 you
know I think important Point here Danny
because if black hatch is taking the
time out and move to pull and then maybe
E4 would have prevented this uh this
concept so Magnus sentencing the element
of time here knowing it might be the
only chance he gets to block the D file
and offer this trade and okay King F2
plate I guess the e Pawn was attacked
there as well and now big decision does
Magnus eliminate this bishop I think he
has done David I think he's already
taken it wow oh he already has this yeah
I mean this this has changed the nature
of the position right because uh no more
opposite colored Bishops
yeah that's that's kind of good and bad
it favors the Practical argument that at
least we're not an obstacle Bishop
ending if you're not a big but the
bishop is better than the night when
there's pawns on both sides of the board
and I see an a pawn as the A5 and A4 and
Bishop B3 and and
I don't know Queen it's coming okay here
he goes he plays A5
I love these very simple ideas as well
you know just push the pawn as far as
you can guard it and ask your opponent
what he's going to do next
um so kind of tough to understand that
with the air Pawn pushing down the board
why is the valbar saying that white is
fine because it feels like if anyone can
push for an advantage or a win in this
position it's got to be Magnus if the
Rooks disappear it's only Magnus who can
uh ever win this one but maybe it's just
the fact that temporarily for now
White's Rook is more active than its
counterparts and whites King slightly
more active than the black king
but yeah I agree with you tally I would
be slightly afraid here with white that
if you lose control for one second if
Rooks come off suddenly black is the
only one with winning chances also
notice how the White Knight is being
dominated with that ship and the
pawn on C6 which is somewhat a weakness
but taking away key squares from White
Knight and it feels like another bag's
Rook at night is really struggling to
find that coordination and Harmony to
bring in the counter player I think it's
a great point we haven't talked enough
about the night on the rim because Simon
is maybe he's out rhymed himself
he's still thinking about the match
um but black is going to play King f8
and then King E7 this is looking more
and more like the direction of the how
the Fabi game went where maybe in the
end Magnus will be the one pushing for a
win and Notre Beck will be happy to uh
to receive the mercy draw I mean why
though I mean what you must do in the
ending is look where you have the
majority of Pawns so we talked about
Black's Pawn that's a past pawn and that
is what you want to make a queen but
where are whites assets well whites
majority of pawns are on the king side
he's got four pawns versus the three so
you really want to use your majority and
I I think white should just use Eddie
the pawn uh to to support the rook and
this could this could give him quite a
nice hole in the center he can move his
King in behind that and he can start you
know causing some problems in the middle
of the board I think he's he's very well
positioned so it's not it's not
completely over by any means I mean this
this gives him chances right to to to
play for the win yeah still some life
left uh still some chances but he needs
to preserve Rooks and he needs to ensure
he's still active Abdus so I think it's
just very wise decision for him now to
tank to kind of think for a couple of
minutes because it's a critical moment
he needs to find something in the next
few moves so he needs to keep the energy
in his position otherwise it will fizzle
out but I love Simon's point I think I
think using the Palm majority is the
first thing the other thing you often
want to do when you have a knight versus
Bishop is centralized the Knight right
so a centralized Knight can can compete
with a bishop it's hard when there's an
a pawn that you're worried about over
there right the Knight is being used as
a bit of a block hater unfortunately but
I was imagining a line like that where
you get the pawn to E5 you're also going
to use the f-pawn to try to create some
pressure in the center maybe the White
Knight lands itself on D4 and
um okay and he's played Knight C2 with
that exact idea in mind to try to bring
the Knight to D4
so it's not over yeah it's not over
yeah nice move there from Abdus if the
black a pawn pushers now the White
Knight can maybe spring to B4 uh yeah it
looks like it's jumping somewhere and
will Magnus bring his King as we predict
the black king is the only piece not
participating is that the luxury of time
White's night is it going to start
jumping to the center and picking up
pawns it's a bit of a race in a way
black gets the king to the center you're
comfortable but I'm not sure you're
reaching there in time yeah I mean it's
the moments white white does potentially
have a threat here right just move the
Knight to D4 take the pawn okay I have
an interesting idea here though let's
say we play King of f8
and Knight D4 happens I wonder if we can
play A4
and the whole point is that if the
Knight takes I'm just gonna play A3 and
if you ever move the Knight the c-pawn
things I I love it thank you engine and
now this is what I was wondering is you
you wouldn't play King E7 because then
the Knight would have taken on C6 with
check and won the A5 fund but you play
A4 and if you back up if you took with
the Rook I think you just lose I think I
just trade Brooks and my past Pawn is
just going to win
and uh you'll move the bishop and then
the Knight will have to sack
anyway so I think that this might be
what Magnus is looking to do but you
should play oh he played King of Fate
but notary played Rook D7 so they're on
top of this line and instead of Knight
D4 but Magnus already all over it with
A4 and the idea here after the bishop
protects this Pawn is that I guess he
wants to move this knight uh just tour
up but the question is where if you jump
to D4 black is just going to hit you and
if you ever trade off black is ready to
cement this past Pawn
feels like this is going to fizzle out
and wow Magnus uh nice geometry there he
pushes the pawn first do not capture
because you'll get forked very nice it's
rare you get the entire Bishop but
double attack it's these little details
right he's able to kind of piece the
minute details in a position and we're
talking about defending the the a pawn
first then pushing the spawn and he does
it he's able to combine tactics with
these strategic ideas and he does it in
seconds
just makes him so strong and is it also
difficult for not about given the math
situation the opening approach he had
trading off Queens going into this Rook
does it feel like a player somewhat
loses that motivation or that belief
that you can come back in the match I
think I think uh it's hard especially in
end games as we know because he just
takes the life out of the positions
although I will I am wondering why does
the advantage has gone up for white here
this is really interesting is he just
gonna win a pawn not B2 taking that
black a pawn oh wow I'm uh wow speaking
maybe maybe Notre bag has one has one
more shot in him here and that's going
to be a rook ending which is hard to win
but he's going to Corral that apron it's
something wow it's the best position
he's had all game yeah
yeah I mean uh
that I mean that I really like what he's
done I mean you know I I was saying move
the pawn and sense of report but uh the
positioning the pieces has proven to be
a lot a lot more important he's put his
Rook behind the passport another bit of
advice for anyone out there in the
ending if your opponent's got a passport
and try to get your Rook behind it tie
it down but his Maneuvers were the
Knight and I think Magnus just moved a
little bit quickly there I think he
forgot I don't know maybe just somehow
missed that that night as David
mentioned is going to come back to B2
and just pick the pawn up and uh there's
no easy way now to draw this at all I
mean if Magnus was white here I'd be on
the verge of saying he's just going to
win so uh I mean it's a it's a free porn
isn't it yeah I mean I can't see
anything have you seen Magnus a moment
ago he kind of just moved his hand it's
like I missed it I missed it yeah he's
just made a mistake
where did he go wrong that he just loses
the spawn because we thought C5 was
brilliant yeah if we backtrack maybe it
was the move C5 that was a small mistake
like kind of forcing white to find a new
route for the Knight into the center If
instead he'd played this move now the
White Knight dropping back I don't know
here but maybe the black Rook has more
options to try and get active maybe for
example you could try and get active via
D5 and if the knight ever moves you kind
of come for this Pawn that's such a hard
idea to find if that's the case what a
what an engine how often do you Rook
lift in an end game in front of your own
pond at the age limit what a save that
would be for black but it's just great I
think the match is going to go on and I
think naughty Beck's going to convert
this I mean like we know Magnus is still
a brilliant end game player so it's by
no means clearly winning but it is a
clear pawn and uh naughty Becker's
played fantastic so far in this game
really really well Magnus is now
trying to think of the optimal the
optimal Rook ending right for a draw
which is this is a huge moment because
you he may even want to try to give up
the C Pawn so that he gets the other C
Pawn right so like you try to give up
both the C and the a pawn along the way
to get the E Pawn the C Pawn because
that actually is a draw the four on
three it's not the easiest drone in the
world everyone remembers the famous Gary
Kasparov loss to Jerome Pickett right
we've seen world champions lose four on
three so it's much harder than any any
other version but look at that H5 is
also usually where you want the pawn in
these end games it's trying to set up F7
g6h5
anyway obviously it's going to remain to
be seen whether he can do it but when
you're about to go into a bad position
Champions try to find the optimal bad
position yeah and the evaluation bot
doesn't like it maybe it's a timing
issue that the black book can't get
active now but yeah it looks like white
can just go for that pawn and grab it
like you say Danny if the C pawns
disappeared from the board Rachel
insurance is probably just the draw when
it's Magnus involved but yeah with those
C pawns on the boards it's going to be
white having a king side majority and
the fact that no I think that's huge the
C Pawn staying on the board yeah
increases White's winning chances like
tenfold like literally right now you can
do principle two weaknesses you can Flex
a king a king that gets in the center to
attack a pawn so this is going to be
really difficult for Magnus if he can't
eliminate the queen side pawns but he
needs to make a decision fast an
autoberg needs to catch up on his speed
he can't just let the seconds go down if
he has to go for the pawn makes that
move is there is there an alternative
that he's thinking about because the
idea you mentioned you want to play it
immediately on the board yeah that's the
most obvious move going for that point
the most to move and as we see there the
engine says it's by far the best move if
you don't seize this moment maybe then
the blackrook will get active later on
and he doesn't go for it
strange
I remember
um a famous saying of Tony miles uh
Britain's first ever Grandmaster he just
uh his most famous saying was simple as
good it's just you know there's no
reason to over complicate it if there's
a good simple uh solution and in that
position you win the pawn it's simple
it's good so why why over complicate it
it you know it's uh it's probably still
good for weight right but it looks good
what what can black now do even but I
agree simple is good and I'm surprised
he didn't but I'm also still thinking
this is really difficult because the
rookie if I move is actually kind of
creative in a way because now if the sea
Pawn Falls he's pointing out that the H
Pawn is under Fire immediately
um and again I don't know what the
engine would suggest here in regards to
how is black
how is black holding here or why did the
eval get worse right it still looks like
a really difficult position for Magnus
is there a bishop C2 and you you race
the king and if uh a night on a I'm
trying to get rid of the C porn right so
and I want to race my king in here
hopefully you take the a pawn I'm trying
to get this ending yeah you're trying to
get the victory you mentioned before
where I've got great drawing chances but
four versus three is a draw here but
yeah there we see the engine suggestions
and they're all to do or at least the
best movies just activating The Rook
what a move though Rook d8 is such a
that is an engine move I've ever seen
when you're giving up the C Pawn in both
ways so that the Rook can get active
like Rook D2 I I I I
assume something like that and now you
can take on A4 but then Rook C2 and I'm
gonna win the pawn back yeah
yeah oh no apparently enough apparently
not maybe you get pinned here uh it was
Bishop C4 instead of Rook C2 and the E2
was fine I didn't see that it must be
yeah you can go for this point instead
but Magnus needs to find let's show Rook
d8 again because this is for a human
incredibly tough just not even trying to
get through to them and he doesn't find
it that's my point is Rook A5 was
frowned upon by the eval bar but Rook d8
that is an impossible move to find yeah
agreed I think uh maybe if Magnus had an
hour by process of elimination but can
you sound much more human he's going as
Simon Says racing towards his bones and
uh the problem is I don't know if you
should take because King D6 as you
mentioned Simon this Pawn is going to
drop most likely so maybe you should
still go for this one I think there'd be
two still keep the pawns on the board
but once you haven't played it once
right will you play the next move when
you've actually lost the tempo right
[Music]
psychologically it's hard to play yeah
because you've given yourself more
complications you now got free pawns or
free ways you can take a pawn right and
you gotta you gotta decide upon one of
them uh which is you know a little bit
trickier
so keeping his chances alive he wants to
keep those seat pawns on the board goes
for the air pawn and now also up on the
clock
how easy is this an easy converter
requires world-class technique
I think it's going to require technique
but I think you made a great point about
the clock as long as he's not down on
time you know he he's he's not really
he's not also playing behind there
although this is a nice little trick he
wants Bishop C4
oh he's found the idea just uh one move
too late maybe but you as you say Danny
there's a threat coming to C4 Rook A2 is
also a threat winning a piece dual
threat
um so is there is there a knight takes
Pawn on a check or something I'm just
trying to think what how you uh deal
with it now let's show this uh as Danny
mentions for example if the white king
moves forward then suddenly a pin and uh
White here is forced to bail out I think
with a move like Knight to C5 but uh
this would only lead to a draw uh
instead if you do take this Pawn the
most obvious then suddenly yeah as you
say Simon it's not easy to take this one
if you give a check I'm not sure where
the black king goes just be careful you
guess you go back
yeah yeah as you say be careful don't
move forward you walk into a night Fork
those pesky Forks but yeah it looks like
still impossible in this position to
defend the E2 Pawn counter play it's
such a hard moment to be a young player
facing Magnus Carlson right you're both
getting under time pressure you're in a
muslin spot and he's doing what he does
as far as making it messy okay but Notre
back is up to the challenge he finds the
most accurate approach which includes
giving up the e-pawn to activate the
king that's a great move I I just didn't
see that move here bringing the king in
and supporting your past Pawn at the
same time right beautiful that's really
nice play yeah coming in with the tempo
to the center of the board
that's
and that's it because the white can jump
forward yeah I can continue marching I
think the issue was Black's Bishop was
lacking squares he wants to capture the
E2 Pawn with his Bishop instead just to
get it out of the way but evaluation Bar
says blunder and nice move from Abdul
sotorov brilliant move he finds it and
the point is that Brook takes C3 Brook
C5 and you pin the bishop oh it's a
brilliant play yeah I mean he found it
so quick as well so quick the match is
on the match
this is wow it felt like it was going to
be a matching tree but not a back after
he is on his way to do the impossible
make a comeback for one round at least
against Magnus can he still can watch
this because both players are two and a
half minutes David how close is he to
actually winning this one I think he's
on the brink now just one or two more
accurate moves and he should have this
in the bag let's just show again the
genius of this last night Retreat night
uh stepping back is always the most
difficult visual move but Knight D3
clinched it because Rook takes C3 now
does just walk into this pin next move
simply King to D4 is going to win the
game for example if black tries to keep
things alive at the very minimum you can
grab a second Pawn on H5 I think that's
even better there but uh yeah we see
instead catching up with the game it's
still a two-point advantage
as long as he doesn't allow too much
counter play with the Rook going behind
he's got this in the bag he drops his
Rook back to A2 what a move brilliant
technique these are the kind of games
that uh that earn your stripes as maybe
a future world number one the fact that
you didn't go quietly into the night you
were down two games and you Rose to the
occasion it doesn't mean he's going to
complete the comeback but the comeback
has to start somewhere it can only start
with one win and these are the kind of
games that like
show Magnus like hey like I'm I'm ready
to play with you for the years to come
and there aren't too many players who
can beat Magnus in an end game yeah
exactly I mean that's it he's outplayed
Magnus in an ending I mean all the
Magnus on Magnus he has yeah I mean how
many players outplay Magnus and ending
there's there's a handful uh that can do
that and uh if you can do that then it's
quite phenomenal actually see yeah and
there's two previous wins against Magnus
came in Queen end games and actually I
think Magnus is the best Queen end game
player of all time he always seems to
know where to put the queen when to
start running with Kings but I have to
satoroph out maneuvered him there twice
uh so he shows he's capable and you can
tell Magnus has almost given up on this
I'm not a body language expert like you
guys but it looks like he's just playing
moves out of inertia here and all you
need to do is combine when to push your
pawns this weight
white truck looks like it's perfectly
poised just defending and protecting the
king from checks here we go the pawns
are going to start running now
a matter of time got two extra pawns
there he's got less than a minute and a
half magnets with two minutes but Magnus
isn't gonna give up and getting a
winning position against him is half the
job done
he is going for the pawns forcing not
about to take a decision does he
actually just ignore the threats on the
pawns and think about advancing his own
sea passer
I think it's too early to do it just yet
because the only because the black king
can come over and help I think if there
was a way if the black king was cut off
by The Rook if your own white king
wasn't in the way maybe but I think
you'll need to play a move like for D3
if I had to guess first just defend the
pawn
Rook D3 also has another purpose which
if which is It prepares Rook C3 okay he
doesn't go for it but that allows Rook
C1 so I'm surprised maybe he's just
repeating to gain time but I think if
you go back to that same position Rook
D3 Rook D3 is the move I mean you can go
King oh he's going this way I'm worried
about his clock oh wow yes
that 17th piece he's trying to transform
his Advantage here he's going for blacks
kingside pawns he's happy to use the
white C Pawn as a distraction where we
see him play a move such as H4 now maybe
or will he just push his Pawn C5 for
Glory uh it looks like there we go he
keeps it for now and yeah maybe Black's
just not in time to create counter play
right now the white King's keeping
everything protected and yeah he might
switch his Focus he's made his rook and
his King passive here's why but I think
he's going to go for black king side
pawns I love how he switched up the king
in The Rook right because the Rook now
cuts off black skin from trying to
defend the C Pawn from queening uh
meanwhile White's King is defending all
the king side bonds so a nice structure
thereby not a bad way how does he make
progress because for now Black's Rook is
stopping the C Pawn from advancing I
know I know who comes to the rescue who
comes to the rescue Gary hurry hurry
always always H4 is another reason why
the Rook on D5 is so good because when
you play H4 you force the fifth ring
open that Rook can gobble up the H5 Pawn
while protecting the C5 Pawn I think H4
is white stripes and you've also got
Freddie as well if you if you really
want to start using them all you could
just push Freddy a couple of squares
forwards that's Harry and Freddie but I
mean this is this is quite I mean the
white rookers are now a beautiful place
it defends everything it cuts off the
black king and you can start using other
other bits can't you on the board like
you know like say the H Pawn or
something like that so it is of course
just uh just a win isn't it just a
matter of time he's giving up the pawn
now that's interesting that was your
idea Tanya now the timing was right the
King has cut off first time right yeah
you can't take the pawn because the C
Pawn would be unstoppable then yeah
let's just show that really nice move
sacrificing upon temporarily Abdus he
dropped his King back to D2 if this Pawn
had been captured then C6 and yes the
Rook can get back just in time but
suddenly the other Rook is there to face
off against it and why it makes a new
Queen and okay the game has progressed
he couldn't go for this and okay he's
trying to create counter play Harry did
arrive on the board but this one looks
like it should just be over white can
play moves like King D3 kicking away
this black Rook this Pawn is going to
drop very shortly
okay he takes it takes it I think King
D3 was you know expecting that but this
is also going to be good enough Magnus
is going to be super angry with himself
how he let this one slip away in a
Catalan having everything under control
and then suddenly in an end game he gets
out played by Naughty back
it's gonna be annoyed yeah yeah I mean
but again it's uh it also he's I think
he will tip his hat right and he knows
that uh he knows that Notre Beck is a
fighter and there's a reason we're all
hyped up right we're not making fake
drama here this is a big match they know
it did to wrap this up in three he
wanted to assert his domination and
that's gonna annoy him Danny that he
didn't he wasn't able to do it
I agree
maybe it was just look at that
deflection don't take that black Rook
black would remain a new Queen but of
course the pawn disappears instead and
now it's just again simple math three
versus one on the king side and Rooks
behind past pawns we've said maybe
it's running that h-born Harry Simon
called it always a winner
winner winner Harry dinner and uh it's
gonna come I mean uh you know you might
as well play it on just in case this
position but don't spend too much time
on it and uh yeah I mean we should talk
about the the last game really because
you know now uh what naughty Beck is
gonna have to win with the black pieces
but he he created a lot of chances in
the last game with the black pieces with
claws it was very close and uh I'm not
you know I don't think it's going to be
a walkover by any means I mean as this
game has shown uh we were assuming this
would be a drawing he he outplayed
Magnus so I don't know it could be an
amazing comeback If he if he gets the
next one he beat Magnus with black and
Tata steel Masters he's done it before
yeah yep you will believe and okay a
check both players leaned forward I
thought he'd resigned there Magnus but
uh yeah all hurricane games 17 seconds
left yeah he's yeah there's still a
little bit of the outside chance on the
clock right so he's still can't write it
off
it's really not over till it's over
against Magnus but Abdullah I'm doing
everything right
and now the Rook will move on to the
fifth rank
is defending really changes really well
and if the Rook goes to the fifth or
sixth ring The Rook will come back to F1
so you enter the king first but now
there's Rook F1 Rook F4 obvious okay he
goes for notabrick must have calculated
it
oh I was worried about this I was
worried about Rook F4 what's happening
oh my gosh King G5 that just moves to
the king king Five Guys
we found it oh my God nobody's in
trouble but now the g-pawn drops what's
he done
he's going round with the white king is
he wait but now the e-born oh my God
Magnus knows that he just gave you the
madness like nod he's locked it back
that was me right here oh my gosh the
bin
no another bag knows he was so close
laughing how did that slip I can't
believe it what a fight it was by
Naughty back but it's really not over
till it's over against Magnus Carlsen
and he does it again
he offers a draw Notre back is laughing
oh
these top players how do you beat them
if you can't win from those positions
they're just such Fighters and he was so
close Tanya called it she said hold on
it's never over against Madness until
it's over we thought we were here for
another hour and a half turns out it's
time to go home everybody seen it
happens so many times and look at that
Magnus himself in disbelief at how he
saved that one just unbelievable and not
a bag so close and look at that
heartbreak oh
we're gonna see this match up so many
times over the next few years not about
what says Magnus Carlsen and what a
fight this was but today it was the
world number one who was dominant he won
the first two games and then from a lost
position manages to survive in that end
game David what was the turning point
there the moment he let it slip Tanya
was this one where he just chose the
wrong moment to go for it with the white
king if he'd taken a slower approach
maybe starting with the move Rook D6
first maybe bringing his King around
this way a bit later on once the black
pieces are passive then he surely would
have won but he's did need to slow play
it a bit instead he went for Glory now
with King F5 but it backfired after a
check maybe the move he'd missed was
Rook to F4 a double attack against his
two pawns and suddenly it was difficult
and the win did slip away after the move
rookie to King G5 suddenly White's Rook
is passive you cannot defend both the E
and G pawns and as we saw one of the
pawns dropped off and that was enough
for Magnus to guide the game to safety a
huge missed opportunity for at least
Toro
we were all so close to thinking this is
going into game four but once again
Magnus surviving it so you really have
to get that point in Tilly hits that
resign button the game goes on and look
at that taking the winners Final in just
three games two wins the first one
dominant and then finally holding that
third game Draw and we are being joined
bye Magnus Carlton he's here Magnus can
you hear us
well while he fixes that we will get
back and ask all the questions to Magnus
but what a save that was by him in a
difficult moment for not to back
so difficult uh but it wasn't the
cleanest three-game Victory so I guess
um Magnus if he faces Notre back again
remember there's a loser's bracket where
norterbeck will have an opportunity to
redeem himself so I think Magnus will
remember that I think Notre Beck is
going to remember that and I think any
future matches with these guys just this
delivered in terms of the drama
it was a dramatic day of Chess and
Magnus is back with us Magnus
congratulations
yeah thank you
it was quite an exciting match you took
it in three games but Magnus is it fair
to say that the scoreline doesn't tell
the full story
[Music]
there we are
um yeah uh I think the first game was
fairly convincing but uh
the second game just became a complete
mess and I mean to be honest like I just
completely fell asleep at the wheel in
the third
and um
yeah I mean he just started to to
outplay me and I didn't I didn't realize
there was any danger before I was just
busted uh that he was just picking up
and picking up the pawn and so that was
incredibly careless uh and really really
poor uh after that
uh it was just completely lost at first
um and there were so many ways to win I
was considering to resign like let's not
spend more and more any more energy on
this and just focus on the fourth game
that I thought
uh he's been kind of shaking the other
games let's keep it going for a bit and
yeah sometimes these things have
happened
and Magnus they're having a lot around
you and that's an incredible skill you
have and I want to ask you do you enjoy
the challenge of playing this younger
generation is that extra motivation for
you
well I like playing anybody but um
when when you're playing young players
it's good to get them while they're
young so you can
there are a lot of players that I've
played with for a long time that I kind
of have a SQL psychological Edge against
and then you got to get the the young
guys early to get that
Magnus I wanted to ask specifically in
regards to your your prep or at least
your mindset coming into the first game
of these matches because you won with
black against Fabiano caruana where you
challenged him in an area where most
people Fear To Tread in those open
Sicilians then you went with black
against Notre Beck in a very different
game but seemed very deliberate in terms
of the type of position you were trying
to reach you got the end game how much
effort are you putting into making sure
that that first game goes your way
especially when you have the black
pieces
I try and be solid so I just
I just felt that it's better
you know in the mood that I am recently
uh or sorry lately it's better just to
try and
try and fight and um yeah it's been it's
been
working out well
usually I kind of prefer starting with
uh
with with white in these matches but
when you come in unseated that's
that's another choice you get
um
and um
of course like winning with the black in
the first game is even better than
getting your wife in so I can't complain
yeah
and the Magnus tomorrow you get arrested
it's been quite a few long weeks for you
of Chess and finally you'll get some
time off meanwhile in the losers bracket
Wesley itarizaga and not a back will
fight it out to challenge you in the
Grand Final do you have any preference
of who you'd like to meet in the Grand
Final
thing to to play Wesley
I did beat him in the losers bracket
last time out and
it's uh it's his play has been really
really shaky here but um
maybe that um
that the win today will give him some
some confidence
it's really interesting because even
yesterday in the interview you mentioned
about the other games are you following
the other games while you're also
playing your own match how are you
finding the time to do that
uh sometimes I check them in between
games and
now that
um
now that there's loser's bracket first
yeah then you'll have a little bit of
time to to follow yeah yeah that's
really cool and Magnus with your rest
day tomorrow how are you planning to
spend it
uh I don't know uh so we'll see but it
will be will be nice because it's uh
it's the first real rest I have had and
uh at least a week and a half
and uh Magnus I just have one question
for you yesterday I was watching you
stream title Tuesday you won it I
challenged you and you rejected me live
on stream what's up with that man
well you really think I wanted to play
Blitz after
after a big match with Fabian then a
bunch of uh with games nah I am
uh
I am I'm sorry about that let's be
honest you were scared right
in the title Tuesday no such thing as
too much chess Magnus you enjoy playing
uh these title Tuesdays
yeah I enjoy
no I wouldn't necessarily say it I enjoy
it when I do well uh but sometimes I
usually I when or usually I get to like
seven out of eight or something like
that started and after the last break
break or start start choking but you
know sometimes Day joke is fun
missing you back in the Grand Final get
some rest
thank you
Magnus Carlsen there with a dominating
performance taking his March and three
but like he said it was close in that
game three for not a back not a back
also have some positive takeaways from
this match Danny I think he definitely
does the uh the focus has to be right
now on facing whoever he does between
the winner of so and iterizaga right and
he's got to take care of that business
first but should he get another chance
at Magnus this is a building block for
him in his career he's only what is it
12 I'm kidding he's 17 years old 19
years old so I think he'll have another
chance and I think he'll remember the
positive things about this match I think
it was really uh cool to see the way he
ended the match as well because uh
obviously he's up six he's outplayed
Magnus but he actually smiled yeah I
think that's a really good sign he's
going to be annoying himself but he's
also already thinking okay there's some
positive about this so that was uh
giving away a good uh I think a good
fighting spirit that he's got yeah and
Magnus might have said he's Keen to face
Wesley in the Grand Final but I think I
speak very everyone here we want to see
a rematch we want to see after satorov
have another shot of Magnus because the
way he played in that last game he'd
definitely have a chance I don't know
I'm gonna say that Wesley so has found
it and I've seen this Wesley before this
is this is I think that a match between
Magnus and Wesley given that Wesley
again was on the brink in Armageddon in
the losers bracket that would mean by
definition that Wesley took out
eturizaga and Notre back I would also
love to see a Wesley so Magnus Grand
Final
I I feel you guys but I'm rooting for a
tourist Saga I feel like his story has
been just phenomenal in this event and I
would love to see him go down to the
distance and make it to the Grand Final
let's take a look at the action that is
coming up this is our bracket at the end
of day three and what a day of Chess it
was wait there is knocking out love on
our onion Fabiano caruana goes down to
Wesley so Magnus Carlsen wins in three
games against Notre back Abdu satro we
will have the loser semi-finals with
Wesley so first taking on iterizaga the
winner in that match plays against Abdul
satrov to decides to decide who
challenges Magnus Carlsen in the Grand
Final David prediction time who is the
player who's making it to that Grand
Final oh this is a tough prediction
Tanya as Danny mentioned Wesley so he
has found his form before today I would
have been uh skeptical but he will start
the match as a favorite against
ifturasaga surprise is of course
possible but yeah that final if it does
get down to it abduce the tour of
against so could just go either way
either way we are guaranteed a
phenomenal final yeah I mean I I think
my head says so but my heart says
Eduardo definitely I'd love to see him
uh get all the way through as Tanya said
after that brilliant issue that
everyone's got to watch
I couldn't agree more again I made my
point about Wesley I think chest for
chess pound for pound Wesley versus
Magnus would be an amazing Grand Final
Notre back has been great buddy turizaga
that guy stole my heartstrings and that
was that was an amazing and amazing
interview what an inspiring guy in an
inspiring story so uh rooting for
everybody if that's okay
we are here
inspiring
kitchen from division two Kathy's
joining us caddy how did it go it was
absolutely amazing today for division
two we had such a big fight between
garakowski and Samuel Sabian they had
four decisive results and this batch
went all the way to the Armageddon where
some had 12 minutes for oh and black
pieces and garakowski had a winning end
game but he flagged himself and he is
now oats we're gonna have then um Dennis
lazovic and some Savion in the finals
and Tanya you know what happened
has not show up for his game uh because
he's playing over the board tournament
he cannot play two tournaments at the
second time at the same time so that
means that Las Vegas goes to the finals
in the division two I was looking at
that score line the Dennis last he wins
with 3-0 how did that happen against the
player like I'm in topai now that makes
sense and he plays for that big ticket
to division one of the next championship
so I went against Sam Sabian it's Dan
Laz versus Sam sabrian in the winners
final Katie is there a favorite there I
I couldn't say who is the favorite
because what I have seen today Sam
sawian is in a great form and we have
seen also Dan is playing so so great I'm
looking forward for this match but Tanya
there is also third division a lot of
actions going on there youngin
absolutely dominated the match and won
this match against mainly and he will
wait for his opponent which will be
known tomorrow after the matches
this is uh incredible stuff and you
yangi with a Two Zero Performance uh
there catty and we also see some more
results coming in right this is the
lizard's bracket and one of these guys
are gonna have a chance to fight against
you Yankee in the final day of the
division three
there is so much at stake for these
players and in the Champions Chester
this is a brand new format a brand new
season and it's all roads lead to
Toronto take a look at what's at stake
air things Masters Chester bull masters
chess kit cup and now aim chess rapid
they all lead to one thing the Champions
chess tour finale the finale will be
played between December 9th and 16th in
Toronto Canada
top eight players from the season will
compete to be crowned the 2023 champion
three spots are already taken and the
remaining five will be decided in the
upcoming tour events so follow us to see
who will join Magnus Carlsen in Canada
in December
it's all about getting to the Champions
chess store playoff happening in Toronto
we've seen exciting chess happen there
in the city and it's all happening in
these three divisions Katie was
mentioning about all the action in
division two and Danny there's so much
on the line so much motivation for those
players to try and make it to Toronto I
mean yeah for anyone who's individual
one they can punch their ticket but
division two I think people forget they
are they are fighting for a golden
ticket into division one right and for a
guy like ichirizaga the Cinderella story
is on right it's living and who knows
how far he can take it we're obviously
going to find out tomorrow but you're
totally right I mean division two is
hard fought chess for a reason
yeah yeah I just hope uh makes it there
now so after that interview earlier so
definitely yeah we shouldn't forget
division two division three the players
are fighting for points they will be
happy that Magnus Carlson is now in the
final he already has a ticket and it
might come down to those one or two
points in the end to decide who makes it
to Toronto
rapid is who will make it to the Grand
Final to challenge Magnus Carlton for
the championship at aim chess rapid not
something to think about we will find
out the answer to that tomorrow we'll
see you then
what was it part of the planet did you
miss it David oh wait he plays on no he
wants more slap shakes his head and
makes a move with just one second on the
clock Eduardo Saga reacts he celebrates
he goes through he has knocked up love
on our onion very nice forces the Rooks
off
get out of here it's just too too good
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
outside